GOOD AFTERNOON THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOUR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION
WILL NOW COMMENCE HEARING GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME I HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY
WE ARE IN ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING. A
ROOM FOR THREE SEVEN CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP. SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANT
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISH TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. WILL
LAST AT THE PUBLIC RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE ABSORB
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITED ELEVATOR USED
TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
ANALYSTS ON THE AGENDA AND THE
L. A. O. R. APPEARING REMOTELY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. THERE
WILL BE NO VOTE IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE NUMBER TOLL FREE
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE. AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB
FOUR THAT'S THE NUMBER FOUR AT
THE END BUDGETS UP FOR. AT ASM
THAT CA. DOT GOP. WE HAVE SIX
DEPARTMENTS WITH THIRTEEN
ISSUES TO BE DISCUSSED TODAY.
WE WILL TAKE MEMBER QUESTIONS
AFTER EACH ISSUE WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
FOCUS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL AND
REVIEWING PAST FUNDING
INVESTMENTS FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY. CALIFORNIA HAD
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
OF ITS RESIDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
AS REPORTED BY THE CONTINUANCE
OF CARE OF THE U. S. DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT. SIX THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWO WERE FAMILY
HOUSEHOLD TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE WERE
VETERANS. TWELVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX WERE
UNACCOMPANIED YOUNG ADULTS AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR. AND
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO WERE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS. PAST
APPROACHES TO HOMELESSNESS HAVE
RELIED ON ONE TIME SOLUTIONS.
HOWEVER AS WE SEE. HOMELESSNESS
POPULATIONS ON THE RICE OF
HOMELESSNESS APPROACH NEEDS A
LONGER TERM SOLUTION. AS PART
OF OUR WORK IN THE COMMITTEE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THESE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
INVESTMENTS TO SHAPE FUTURE
FUNDING. TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS. OUR FIRST ISSUE
OF THE DAY. IS DEALING
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY.
DEVELOPMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
HOMELESS PROPOSAL- WILL START-
WITH OUR PANELIST- SACRI OWN
STATE THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. OF H. CD CHRIS HILL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND WITH THIS MODEL IS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
PART OF THIS PRESENTATION ON
THE GOVERNOR'S HOMELESSNESS
PLAN I HAVE US MR ALMOST A TO
PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL REVIEW OF
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN HOUSING
BOND. PROPOSITION ONE INCLUDING
WHAT THE STATE STANDS WITH.
FUNDS AWARDED OBLIGATED AND
EXPENDED EXPANDED. AS WELL AS
TOUCH ON STAFFING AT HDD AND
THEN LAUNCH INTO MORE DETAILS
ON ISSUE ONE. I BELIEVE IT'S
BACKGROUND THE STATE'S. I
BELIEVE US BACK INTO THE
STATE'S FUNDING APPROACH TO
HOMELESSNESS. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CONSIDER THE HOUSING BOND IN
TERMS OF LONG TERM FUNDING
ANTICIPATED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS THAT COULD HELP. WITH
HOMELESSNESS. LET'S BEGIN WITH
PANEL NUMBER ONE. MR ALMOST.
THANK YOU HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
HEAR ME I UNDERSTAND SOMETIMES
THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES GET
STARTED. WE GET TO GO. YOUR
GREAT THANK YOU. ALSO WILL HAVE
TO COMBINE- COUPLE THINGS WITH
THE OVERALL PROPOSED ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUE CHRISTOPHER FINANCE
WILL DO THAT BUT TO YOUR
REQUESTED MAN SHARE BEFORE
DRESSING HOME KEY I DO WANT TO
TAKE THAT PROVIDE A FEW UPDATES
ON A. T. OPERATIONS AS YOU ASK
FOR RELATING TO THE HOUSING
FUND BALANCES. AS WELL AS OUR
DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS- ONCE
ACCOUNTING FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS THERE'S ABOUT THE WORDS
ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
AVAILABLE TOWARDS ECD PROGRAM
THROUGH THE PROPOSITION ONE.
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND TO MAINTAIN CONTINUITY FOR
DEVELOPMENT THOSE FUNDS ARE
SPREAD OUT AMONG SEVERAL
PROGRAMS OVER SEVERAL YEARS-
AND TO DATE ONE POINT ONE EIGHT
BILLION OF THOSE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN AWARDED. AND THE REMAINDER
IS ARE CURRENTLY EITHER
AVAILABLE OR NOTICES OF MONEY
AVAILABILITY OR WILL BE LATER.
IN TWENTY TWENTY OR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR THE NEW PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM WAS-
AUTHORIZED PROPST TWO AND
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. ONE POINT
ONE THREE BILLION OF THE
POSSIBLE ONE POINT EIGHT SIX
BILLION HAS BEEN AWARDED AND
ANOTHER FUNDING ROUND OF
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE FOR THAT
PROGRAM LATER THIS YEAR. AND I
CAN ELABORATE ANY SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS WHEN IT COMES THAT
TIME JEFF QUESTIONS WE DO HAVE
I WOULD NOTE TABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE WHICH OUTLINED- THE
FUNDS AVAILABLE. TO FUND
AWARDED THE FUND EXPENDITURES
IN EACH OF THOSE PROGRAM FROM
PROPS ONE INTO OUR CHART WE
HOPE OR HELPFUL TOOL. AND HAPPY
TO DIRECT YOU GUYS THEIR THIGHS
HELPFUL. FORTY QUESTIONS OF
THREE PROGRAMS. ON DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONS OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT ADDED A
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR POSITIONS
TIED TO THE C. ONE HOUSING
PACKAGE IN OTHER ENACTED LAWS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE- IT
DEPARTMENT ALSO GROWN
CONSIDERABLY BEYOND THOSE
POSITIONS IN OTHER AREAS
ESPECIALLY TIED. TO SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN RESOURCES RIVER
CITY IN FEDERAL RESOURCES FROM
PAST DISASTERS AS WELL AS KOBE.
THERE'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS
GROWTH IN OUR DEPARTMENT
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR POSITION TO
GROWTH TIED TO YOU SPECIFICALLY
HOUSING PACKAGE AND- AND STUFF
BUT AND THEN I DON'T PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE. OVERALL OUR
CURRENT VACANCY RATE THE
DEPARTMENT 11% WHICH IS IN LINE
WITH AN AVERAGE BEACON STREET
FOR DEPARTMENT OR SIZE BUT TO
PUT IN PERSPECTIVE THE VACANCY
RATE WAS EIGHTEEN PERCENT. IN
JULY OF LAST YEAR FOLLOWING THE
LAST INFUSION OF NEW POSITIONS
SO THE NUMBER CONTINUES TO
REDUCE EVERY MONTH. AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT- WE'RE ACTUALLY ON
PACE OVER THE LAST THREE MONTHS
WE'RE ADDING OVER ONE HIGHER
EACH DAY TO KEEP UP WITH OUR
GROWTH AND WITH DISTRICT COURT
TURNOVER. CHAU BEFORE WE GET
OUT OF THE OTHER ITEMS- I KNOW
THAT- YOU'D LIKE HEAR ABOUT ON
THE ACTUAL BUDGET PROPOSALS.
THOSE ARE- SOME THINGS I'D LIKE
TO COVER- GIVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THOSE ITEMS BEFORE YOU MOVE ON
TO THE ACTUAL- BUDGET ITEMS
BEFORE YOU TODAY. WILL TAKE THE
CLASS FROM AND MEMBERS AT THE
END OF THE PRESIDENT. ALL AT
ONCE. SO WITH THAT I THINK HILL
SHOULD GO. THE SUMMARIZE THE-
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE
EACH SHE DOES HAVE THE HOME KEY
ASPECTS SO I'M HAPPY TO. FOLLOW
UP AFTER HE PRESENTS THEIR- AND
THE CRYSTAL FINANCING ACTUALLY
BRITNEY THOMPSON WILL PROVIDE
OFFICE OVER THE POOREST. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON BRITNEY THOMPSON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SIX TWENTY EIGHTEEN ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN PROVIDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADDRESS THEIR
IMMEDIATE HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES TO THE HOMELESS
EMERGENCY EIGHT PROGRAM ALSO
KNOWN AS HE AND THE HOMELESS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN
AS HECK. AS PART OF THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE THAT
MINISTRATION ACTED SWIFTLY TO
MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF KOBE
NINETEEN AMONG THE HOMELESS
POPULATION THIS INCLUDED ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
DISPERSED BY THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL A HUNDRED TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PROJECT
ROOM KEY TO PROVIDE SAFE NON
CONGREGATE SHELTER. IN EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR HOME
KEY TO CREATE PERMANENT
HOUSING. THE HOMELESS PROPOSALS
BUILD UPON THE STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS AND THE SUCCESS OF
HUNKY THESE PROPOSALS WILL
EXPAND FACILITIES TO SUPPORT
HOUSING FOR ALL END OF ALL OF A
BROADER PORTFOLIO HOUSING
NEEDED TO AND HOMELESSNESS. IN
TOTAL ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IS INCLUDED FOR
THREE PROPOSALS SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR A CD
TO CONTINUE HONKY OF WHICH TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IS
REQUESTED FOR EARLY ACTION.
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TOP OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO ACQUIRE AND REHABILITATE
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
AND WE'RE AND RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
THEIR SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ACQUIRE AND
REHABILITATE FACILITIES TO
EXPAND THE COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. TOGETHER
THESE PROPOSALS I AM TO REACH A
BROAD SPECTRUM OF POPULATIONS
WHO ARE EITHER EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR AT RISK OF
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IT
MIGHT AND MIGHT NOT BE HAVE
YOUR HEALTH NEEDS. THE SOCIAL
SERVICES AND HEALTHCARE
SERVICES PROPOSALS WILL BE
HEARD IN A DIFFERENT SUB
COMMITTEE HOWEVER I CAN TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT. HOME KEY
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU FOR THAT LET'S HEAR FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE
BEFORE WE BEGIN QUESTIONS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARRY MEMBERS I LOOK
THAT'S WHAT I WAS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AS THE ADMINISTRATION NOTED-
THE HOME KEY PROPOSAL IS ONE
THREE MAJOR PROPOSALS RELATED
CHIU HOMELESSNESS I WILL FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON THE- HERE THOUGH
AND THAT IS THE ONE THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS JURISDICTION OVER.
AND SO I'LL JUST NOTE HERE THAT
THE PROPOSAL BUILDS OFF- THE
ROOM KEEP PROGRAM WHICH FOCUSED
ON THE SCENE AND PROPERTIES THE
PROPOSAL BUILT ON THAT BY
FOCUSING ON THE ACQUISITION
CAPITALIZATION OF PROPERTIES.
AS A RESULT- WE DO PROVIDE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO FEDERATION ONE
OF THE MAJOR QUESTION ON OUR
MIND HOW THOSE PROPERTIES WOULD
BE MAINTAINED. THERE IS A BIG
PROVIDED OVER THE LONG TERM WE
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT AS PART OF
THE APPLICATION PROCESS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE THEIR
MAINTENANCE PLAN OVER THE SHORT
TERM YEAH BY STATE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL SOURCES OF COUPLE
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE SOME SORT
OF A WITH. THE CHILDREN. MORE
ABOUT THE LONG TERM YOU KNOW
FIVE TEN FIFTEEN YEARS OUT ON
WATERSHED Z. HAPPENED RESOURCES
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO ME TINO'S
PROPERTY ADDRESS- OF THE HOME
WITH A SEAT ON A LONG TERM.
BASIS HI OTHER QUESTIONS
CONSIDERATION RELATED TO HE- I.
REQUEST OFF ON THE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OFTEN. OF PREVIOUS FOR
THE- AS WE AROUND WHAT LESS
LEARNED RELIGIOUS IN OUR FOR
INCREASED. THAT COULD BE MORE
AND OF COURSE IN THE FORWARD.
AS WELL AS THEY IS A COME THAT
WOULD BE- REQUESTED IN. THE
BUDGET YOU. ON IT WILL BE
DIFFICULT FOR TO THE END OF THE
YEAR HAVE FROM MINISTRY. WHAT
IS THERE TO THE TINY AND WHAT
THE BENEFITS OF ACTING EARLY ON
THAT PIECE. OF HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY. THANK YOU. I THINK. THANK
YOU MISS I MAY YOU AND IF
ENOUGH TO TURN OFF THE VIDEO
YOU CAN OF CUT OFF AT THE END
OF YOUR CALL AT THE END. IT'S
FINE FOR NOW IF IT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN JUST- JUST NUMBER THAT'S
COMING FROM. SO LET'S THE I
WANT TO GO TO THE COMMITTEE TO
ASK A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS BUT
I'M I'M GONNA TAKE THE LIBERTY
OF IT OF ASKING A- FEW- I'M-
MR- OWN STATE I. ASSUME THAT
THE YOU MAY BE THE BEST ANSWER
THIS BUT- MAYBE NOT HOW MANY
UNITS HAVE BEEN CREATED WITH
THE PROP ONE IMPROMPTU BONDS. I
DON'T KNOW WITHOUT MY
FINGERTIPS- THE- I HAPPILY
HAPPY YOU GET THE THAT
INFORMATION THE COMMITTEE-
AFTER THIS ELECT. HASSANAL
NEEDED NEEDED I MEAN I MEAN THE
NATURE OF DEVELOPMENT IS WE DO
NOT. AWARD ARE SORRY SHOULD IT
SAY DISBURSE THOSE FUNDS UNTIL
UNITS ARE BUILT SO WHEN WE
AWARD FUNDS- IT FOR PERSPECTIVE
DEVELOPMENT RIGHT AND SO- MANY
OF THOSE ARE IN VARIOUS STAGES.
OF MEDIA FUNDS HAVE BEEN
EXPENDED AT THIS POINT BUT THE
NATURE OF THE BILL THE PROCESS
CAN HAVE A DECENT TIME HORIZON
AND SOME OF OUR FUNDS ARE SOME
OF THE FIRST MONTH AND THEN
THEY'RE TYPICALLY SEEKING TAX
CREDITS IN BONDS THROUGH THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. OFTEN. HAVE
LOCAL SOURCES OF FINANCING.
THINGS LIKE OF THAT NATURE IN
SO- WE HAVEN'T SEE A TO. OF
ACTUAL. COMPLETION OF
CONSTRUCTION FROM PROP ONE
GIVEN WHERE WE'RE AT IN TERMS
OF THE FIRST NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY FOR THE FOR THE ON
GOING OUT IN TWO THOUSAND. BUT
THERE HAS BEEN SOME IN A
CERTAIN PROGRAM AND NO PLACE
LIKE HOME. I'M INTERESTED TO
DEVELOP. SOME OF ON SAID I DO
HAVE SAY THAT I KNOW THAT
BUDGET STAFF DID COMMUNICATE
WITH YOU ON CERTAIN DETAILS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE FOR
THIS HEARING A SPECIFICALLY.
THE UNITS CREATED IN PROP ONE
IMPROMPTU BOND SINCE I'M
SURPRISED THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION READILY
AVAILABLE SINCE YOU WERE ASKED
BUT IN YOUR ESTIMATION AS YOU
CAN YOU ESTIMATE. HOW MANY
UNITS HAVE OR WILL BE CREATED.
WITH PROP ONE INTO BONDS. YEAH
WHAT JUST MAKE IT UP WITH A ON
THE- AMOUNT AWARDED EXPANDED
I'M SORRY THAT THAT INFORMATION
ABOUT UNITS COULD YOU COULD NOT
GET TO ME HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
AT A LATER DATE- SO IT VARIES
ON THE TYPE OF SOURCE HOW MANY
UNITS WILL BE CREATED- WE COULD
CERTAINLY- LOOK AT SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS A SPECIFIC WHEN WE
WILL BE RELEASED NOTICE THE
FINAL BILL BILL FUNDING
AVAILABILITY AS WELL AS
ANNOUNCE OUR AWARDS- WE
TYPICALLY PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION WE HAVE IN YOUR
REPORT THAT. THE LEGISLATURE
VERY RECENTLY THAT ARTICULATES
ALL THAT INFORMATION BUT I
APOLOGIZE THAT THAT SPECIFIC
PIECE OF OUR REQUEST NOT GET IT
TO ME I WILL WHILE WE CONTINUE
THE QUESTIONING HERE AFTER MY
COLLEAGUES TO OBTAIN THAT DATA
FOR ME AND THEN IT WILL SHARE
WITH YOU THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THANK YOU MOVING ON TO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WITH
FEDERAL DOLLARS THE STATE WAS
ABLE TO MAKE A SIZEABLE
INVESTMENT IN FUTURE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. HOW DD THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN TO INCLUDE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION PROTECT THE
CURRENT INVESTMENT. IN HOME
KEEP PROJECTS. DO YOU WORK- BE
MADE RIGHT NOW WE ALLOW DO MORE
OF THE SAME IN TERMS OF
ACQUISITIONS- WE WERE ABLE TO
WITH THE- US EUROPE DOLLARS AS
WELL SOME GENERAL FUND. FUND
OVER SIX THOUSAND UNITS WITH
HOKEY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY NINE
FIRED RUBBER THE NUMBER
CORRECTLY. SO WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO DO MORE OF THE SAME AND THAT
HAPPENED IN A VERY TIGHT TIME
FRAME AS YOU GUYS AS YOU ALL
KNOW. THE FUTURE OF COURSE HAD
TO BE SPENT. ON A VERY SHORT
TURNAROUND. AND DEMAND IS STILL
ON GOING THERE ARE WE GET ASCOT
QUITE REGULARLY WHEN THERE
MIGHT BE MORE RESOURCES YOU
MORE THE SAME THERE ARE MANY.
PROJECTS AT THE STATE THAT
COULD NOT MEET THE TIGHT TIME
FRAMES OF HOKEY- GIVEN WHAT WE
HAD TO DO WITHIN THE SIX MONTH
PERIOD IN THE CALENDAR LAST
YEAR. AND SO- THIS WOULD BE A
NEW STANDALONE YOU KNOW NEW
DEVELOPMENT NEW ACQUISITIONS
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS ALONG THE
SAME LINES WHAT WE GET THE
FIRST TIME AROUND. SO TO SPEAK
TO WHAT I THINK ARE PROBABLY
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS IS WE
DID. OUR DUE DILIGENCE IN
ACTUALLY ASKING PROJECTS TO
IDENTIFY FIVE YEARS OF
OPERATION SUPPORT AND IN ALL
CASES ARE ACTUALLY WILL PROVIDE
TWO YEARS OF THAT. UP FRONT
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAD.
A WE WILL BE ABLE TO DO THE
SAME THING THIS TIME. IN FACT
PERHAPS MORE BECAUSE THE FUNDS
WILL BE GENERAL FUND SO WON'T
BE. ARMED AS INFLEXIBLE AS. THE
FEAR HALF DOLLARS FOR. THIS
YEAR WE COULD NOT FIND ANY SORT
OF LONG TERM CAPITAL OPERATE
SUPPORT. SO WE HAD ON THEM
MATTER. FOR AND- SUPPORT THAT
OF THE OLD. LAST TIME. AND
WE'RE- THAT WE WERE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE TO YOUR OFFERING
SUPPORT TO ALL THE PROJECTS. WE
WILL NOT BE A RESTRICTED THIS
TIME AROUND AND HOW THAT WOULD
WORK AS WE WOULD CAPITALIZE
THAT OPERATING SUPPORT FRONT.
JUST LIKE WE DID LAST TIME AND
THAT IS PART TYPICAL FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- FINDING
LONG TERM- RESOURCES. IS A
CONSTANT CHALLENGE IN FACT-
IDENTIFYING UP TO FIVE YEARS.
IS NOT EVEN A STANDARD MANY
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE EXISTED FOR
FOUR HOUSING- OVER THE PAST
YEARS AND DECADES. BUT DID NOT
HAVE THAT OPERATING SUPPORT SO
DEVELOPMENTS WERE FORCED TO YOU
KNOW BY LOCAL SPORTS THE SORT
OF THINGS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AREN'T. TYPICALLY PROVIDING
LONG TERM SUPPORT LONGER
COMMITMENTS JUST SAY NO PLACE
LIKE HOME WITH A LOT OF CITIES
SOMETHING. UP PRETTY INNOVATIVE
AND- REQUIRE COUNTY RIGHT UP TO
TWENTY YEARS. IN THOSE CASES
WHICH WAS VERY VERY HELPFUL AND
IS VERY HELPFUL. HELPFUL- BUT
YEAH WILL BE DEBATING MORE THIS
ABOARD OF PROJECTS. LIKE WE DID
THE FIRST. I SENT AN MANY OF
THE PURCHASE TO PRO REQUIRE WE
ADDING LIKE THIS KITCHEN OR
GENERAL WELL WE HAVE BEEN. HOW
MUCH WILL THAT COST AND HOLD TO
BE FUNDED. SO WE REQUIRED ALL
THE PRODUCT AGAIN TO FILE THE
FUNDING UP FRONT RIGHT SO- WE
WILL HAVE A REPORT OUT AS
REQUIRED BY THE STATUTE IN
APRIL ONE WHICH WILL OUTLINE
ALL ALL OF THAT IT WAS A MIX-
OF. THE PROJECT REQUIRE WE HAVE
MANY PROJECTS ARE OPERATING AS
INTERIM HOUSING SOME INTERIM
TURNING INTO PERMANENT HOUSING
SO IMMEDIATELY IT'S PERMANENT
HOUSE. THE PROJECTS THAT HAD.
LOWER REHAB COSTS COSTS MORE
PER UNIT UP FRONT. THEY'RE
PRETTY MUCH MORE MOVE IN READY
RIGHT IF YOU THINK OF A TYPE OF
HOTEL OR MOTEL THAT MAYBE
ALREADY HAD. SOMETHING LIKE A
KITCHENETTE- SO THE AVERAGE
KIND OF COST OF OUR ACQUISITION
WAS VERY DEPENDING UPON UPON
THAT LEVEL. SO- IT HARD TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION ACROSS THE
BOARD BECAUSE ALL THIS PROJECT
VERY- I WILL SAY THE PER UNIT
COST WAS WAS VERY VERY LOW AND
IN SOME CASES THEY WERE
DEFINITIONAL SMALL REHAB DONE
IN SOME CASES IT WILL BE RE
HAVE COMING IN THE COMING YEARS
AND THEY MAY THEY MAY USE LOCAL
FORCES THEY MAY SEEK OUT TAX
CREDITS AND- A REHABILITATION
SOURCES THAT WAY IT VARIES FROM
PROJECT TO PROJECT BUT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO ARTICULATE KIND OF A
MORE. ROBUST KIND OF BREAKDOWN
OF HOW MANY PROJECTS CAN FIT
EACH OF THOSE BUCKETS- IN THE
REPORT KAMALA JUST LITERATURE
APRIL FIRST AND THE REPORT
COMING OUT ON APRIL FIRST HOW
IS THE DATA COLLECTED IS ARE
YOU WILL YOU BE PROVIDING.
INFORMATION ON AS TO HOW MANY
ASSEMBLY SEATS HOW WHAT THE
DATA WITHIN. THE ASSEMBLY FIFTH
IT LOOKS LIKE. LIKE LIKE ABLE
TO POINT TO COLLEGE IN CENTRAL
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND BE
ABLE TO NOTICE- WHAT THE DATA
LOOKS LIKE IN THAT REGION. SURE
YEAH WE CAN PROVIDE THAT DATA
THE PROJECT REPORTS WERE DUE TO
US ON A PROJECT LEVEL ON
FEBRUARY FIRST WE'RE THRILLED
WITH STILL FINALIZING PULLING
ALL THAT DATA- BUT CERTAINLY WE
CAN SHOW A MAP. AS WELL AS A
BREAKDOWN OF WHERE THOSE
PROJECTS ARE. THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD BE- THAT WOULD BE REALLY
GREAT AND IF WE CAN IF YOU
COULD PLEASE MAKE A NOTE THAT
IN THE REPORT FOR APRIL FIRST
THAT WOULD BE REALLY GOOD TO
GET INFORMATION BASED ON.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SO THAT WE
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON- BACK HOME
AND HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE BEING
USED I WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO
THE MEMBERS OF THIS BODY. OF
THE DITION ONLY PREVIOUSLY ONE
TIME FUNDING ALLOCATIONS
INCLUDED SET ASIDE FOR YOU.
HOWEVER YOUTH SERVE THROUGH
PROJECT FUNKY. SURE- SO I DO
KNOW THE TARGET POPULATION WAS
BROAD WITH THOSE EXPERIENCING
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS AND
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN-
BUT THAT HER PUBLISHING OF
COURSE INCLUDES HOMELESS YOU.
THERE WERE TWO PEOPLE HOME KEY
PROJECTS SPECIFICALLY. SPECIFIC
TARGETED HOMELESS YOUTH. IN THE
CITY OF EL CENTRO. IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THROUGH THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY HERE. AND WE JUST ARE
OBVIOUSLY PRELIMINARY WE-
GETTING THE PROJECT REPORTS IT
LOOKS LIKE AS MANY AS- TWENTY
PROJECTS. HAVE OR GRANTEE THAT
WE FUNDED HAVE HOMELESS YOUTH.
THAT THEY'RE SERVING. NOT
EXCLUSIVELY- BUT HAVE HOPE WITH
YOU THAT'S PART OF THAT
POPULATION THAT IS RESIDING
WITHIN THOSE PROJECTS. SO HOW.
WILL VERY HAPPILY BREAKDOWN
THAT AS WILL THE SUBPOPULATION
DATA. AS BEST WE HAVE IT. IN
THE REPORT THAT WILL BECOME.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER. THANK
YOU MENTION QUEST FOR A- OF THE
L. L. AND FOR EARLY ACTION DO
YOU HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT.
YES SIR- I WAS THE HOMELESS IS
A CRITICAL OF THIS IS A CRISIS
AND WE NEED TO BE MOVING AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE TO DO WHAT WE
CAN TO CREATE MORE HOUSING
OPTIONS. WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEMAND COMING THERE WERE MANY
WHILE WE'RE REALLY PLEASED TO
BE ABLE TO FIND WITH THE
ADDITIONAL FUSION. LATER LAST
YEAR- WELL OKAY OF DOLLARS TO
DEAL FUNDS ON THE WAITING LIST
WE HAVE THE FIRST ROUND. THERE
ARE STILL A NUMBER OF
INTERESTED PARTIES. INTERESTED
COMMUNITIES TO DO HIS TYPE OF
WORK AND WE THINK IF WE CAN'T
DO IT FASTER WE SHOULD- IT HAS
BEEN. VERY VERY HELPFUL TO GET
MORE OF LARA HOMES CALIFORNIANS
OFF THE STREETS. AND INTO THESE
THESE HELICOPTERS. SO THERE
PROP READY FOR PURCHASE AND
RENOVATION TODAY. JUSTIFY THAT
AMOUNT. WE BELIEVE THERE WILL
BE SUFFICIENT DEMAND YES SO
WHEN WE PUT OUT THE MONEY LAST
YEAR FOR EXAMPLE WE WERE
OVERSUBSCRIBED EVEN EACH REGION
SO NOT JUST STATEWIDE BUT WE
BROKE THE FUNDING DOWN BY
REGION AT LEAST TWO OR THREE TO
ONE. SO THAT WAS WHEN WE HAD
THE RESOURCE FOR THE LAST YEAR
WE DON'T OBVIOUSLY ARE TAKING A
WAITING LIST RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO FUNDS AVAILABLE
BUT WE GET A LOT OF ENQUIRIES
ABOUT WHEN WILL FUNDS BECOME
AVAILABLE SO WHEN WE ARE ABLE
TO DEPLOY THOSE FUNDS WERE
PRETTY CONFIDENT GIVEN THE OVER
SUBSCRIPTION THAT HAPPENS NOT
ONLY FOR HOME KEEP UP FOR ALL
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS
WHICH TYPICALLY AT LEAST TWO OR
THREE TO ONE. WHAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE THAT THE- AND WHAT
CRITERIA. TO AWARD HUNKY
FUNDING. THE FIRST TIME AROUND-
THERE'S SEVERAL CRITERIA WORKS-
ONE OF THE GREAT YOUR WE HAD HE
IS THE FIRST TIME AROUND WAS
ABILITY AND SPEED ON WHICH OU
COULD ACQUIRE THE PROPERTY AND
THEN LEASE IT UP WE WOULD NOT
BE SUBJECT TO THAT RESTRICTION
OF COURSE BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT CRITERIA WE
TYPICALLY- EVALUATE WHEN WE ARE
AWARDING PROGRAMS OF THIS TYPE
END OF OUR OTHER PROGRAMS RIGHT
SO. IT IS LEVERAGE OF OTHER
FUNDING AND COMMITMENT TO OTHER
FUNDING CERTAINLY THE ABILITY
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THE
SERVICES PLANTS ARE CRITICAL
IT'S- BEING ABLE TO GET TO THE
LOCAL PER UPPER HOLDEN AND
READINESS AND OF COURSE THE
THINGS ARE HAPPY TO ELABORATE
AND IF I COULD TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUES IF YOU LIKE- WHO ARE
THE KEY VENDORS THAT PROGRAM.
TO REALLY GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
LIST IF YOU'D LIKE- WE- HAVE
BASICALLY THINK THAT OUR
THRESHOLD AS WELL AS- THE
SCORING TYPICALLY OUR PROGRAMS
AND- WE CAN GO THROUGH THAT
LIST OF THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
NO THAT'S OKAY YOU CAN SEND ME
LIST THOUGH BUT IT ALSO DOES
THE HUNKY PROGRAM INCLUDE A
PLAN. TO FOCUS ON THE
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL. HEALTH
ISSUES. SO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE CERTAINLY ELIGIBLE- AND THE
FIRST AROUND OF COURSE YOU CAN
HEAR DOLLARS THERE HAD TO BE A
VERY CLOSE NEXUS TO COVER
NINETEEN THAT WAS THE MOST
IMPORTANT NEXUS AS WELL AS
BEING HOMELESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS AND OF COURSE WE
KNOW WITHIN THE POPULATION ARE
SIGNIFICANT TO PERSONS
EXPERIENCING MENTAL ILLNESS SO-
TYPICALLY HOW OUR COMMUNITY
WILL PROCEED CERTAINLY AT ONCE
THEY ACQUIRE THESE PROPERTIES
IS WORK THROUGH THE RECORDED
ENTRY SYSTEM- AT THE LOCAL
CONTAINS OF CARE TO
ESSENTIALLY- MOVE FOLKS FROM
THAT LIST AND I SYSTEM INTO.
AVAILABLE HOUSING AND WE
REQUIRE THAT PARTICIPATION THE
PROPOSAL IN WE ARE ALWAYS HERE
THE SEALS EVERYBODY ELSE THERE
SUPPOSED DEALING WITH HEALTH.
BUT DOES THIS ADDRESS HOW THE
HELL ALMOST WERE MENTALLY WHO
DO NOT WANT TO BE HEALTH. WELL
THIS PER PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR
IS NOT SEEKING TO. FALL FOR
THAT POLICY PROBLEM WE'RE
SOLVING FOR THE PULSE FROM OF
ALL THE MANY MANY PEOPLE THAT
ARE ON THE STREETS OF PROVIDING
MORE HOUSING BECAUSE NO WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF IT- AT THE
LOCAL OUTREACH LEVEL. OF COURSE
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
TAKES PLACE BUT THE HOME KEY
PROGRAM IS ABOUT ASSISTING
COMMITTEES ACQUIRE. THESE
PROPERTIES AND HELPING GIVE
THEM SOME RESOURCES TO OPERATE
THEM LONG TERM- AND THE
COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES OF
COURSE ARE THE ULTIMATE
PROVIDERS OF THESE OF THESE.
BANKS AND- RUNNERS OF THESE-
BUT STILL RIGHT SO ANY
PROPERTIES. SO CERTAINLY WE ARE
IDENTIFYING IS AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT. OF HOW WE ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. I WILL SAY THERE
ARE YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
FAR FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN NEED OF HOMES- AND WE'RE NOT
GONNA. WE'RE LIKELY TO SEE
THEY'RE NOT TO BE TAKE UP OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES AND HUNKY
OR RATHER FORMAL HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
THE DESIRE NOT TO THE WANT TO
GO INTO THIS. WE HAVE A STATE
PROVIDES THE MONEY IN THE
PEOPLE SEE ALL TOO WELL YOU IN
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO. A GOOD
POPULATION THAT IS MENTALLY ILL
I THINK IS MORE SIGNIFICANT.
PEOPLE WANT ONE OF KNOWLEDGE
WITH THAT SO IT IS THE
GATEKEEPER THE MONEY- BUT I'VE
NEVER REALLY SEEN A FOCUS MY
SEVEN YEARS HERE. ON THAT PART
AND OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU'RE
DRIVING DOWNTOWN. ANYWHERE ELSE
IN CALIFORNIA- YOU SEE FOLKS OR
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL. AND WE
WILL NOT PUT A DENT IN THAT. SO.
LAST QUESTION. I MEAN A NO
PLACE LIKE HOME PRO. IS BASED
TO PAY. WHO ARE MENTALLY ILL.
AND I. HOME RIGHT INTO THE
THEIR PROP TO PASS A COUPLE
YEARS AGO. THERE IS- NEAR TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. MADE AVAILABLE
AND WE HAVE. OVERBILLING OF
THAT ALREADY AND- FOR NEW
HOUSING UP BECAUSE THAT IS THE
STATE PROGRAM THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED TOWARDS.
PEOPLE TWENTY HOMELESSNESS WHAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA LET YOU THAT
THE QUESTION IS. HOW MANY FOLKS
HAVE YOU HEALTH THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM. THEY WERE MILLENNIALS.
EVERY IN THAT PROGRAM HAS TO BE
EXPERIENCED HAVE TO HAVE A
MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS SO. I
CAN I CAN I CAN FEEL IT RIGHT
FOR THE SECOND WILD WHEN ONE
THING. ABOUT IT- WE DO FOR THE
FOUR LARGEST COUNTIES THEY
RECEIVED THE MONEY FOR
THEMSELVES OF THE COUNTIES WITH
OVER 5% TO RECEIVE THOSE AWARDS
THROUGH THE STATE AND MINISTER
THEMSELVES OF LOS ANGELES IN A
CLASSROOM. A SINGLE COUNTIES.
DID MINISTER THOSE FUNDS BUT
BUT THIS THO OR BACK TO THE
STATE THOUGH THEIR NUMBERS
CORRECT. YEAH WE GET WE ONLY
MOVING TO THE NUMBERS BUT
THEY'RE YET SURE WE CAN I CAN
TRY TO GET THOSE NUMBERS YOU.
HEAR THE FRUSTRATING PART IS
HEARING THAT WE HAVE NOT BILLS
COMMITTEE SEVEN YEARS YOU GUYS
ARE ALWAYSGIVING US NUMBERS
BACK YOU GUYS NEVER HAVE THE
NUMBERS FOR SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW. JUST GIVE THAT
MONEY WITHIN COULD BE A MATTER
OF ROUTINE TO HAVE INFORMATION
ON NUMBERS AS A CHAIR AFTER
EARLY FOR SOME MEMBERS IT'S
ARCHITECT- IT BACK TO YOU
THAT'S THAT'S FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE- IF FOR GIVING US MONEY
TO IMPROVE THESE THINGS. WE
SHOULD HAVE METRICS TO MEASURE.
IT REALLY AVAILABLE THE
LEGISLATURE INSTEAD OF
ASSESSING THE HEARING- GIVE
BACK TO US SO. LET ME ASSURE
THOSE I MIGHT GET BACK TO YOU
WITHIN THE HEARING HAVE THEM
RIGHT NOW IF YOU'D LIKE FIVE
THOUSAND UNITS WERE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME SO FAR. EIGHT
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED PER PROP
ONE TO FOUR. THAT'S CAN. I
APOLOGIZE THAT. THAT UNIT MAKE.
THAT UNITS INDIVIDUAL HOUSE.
THAT UNITS SO INTO YEAH
IMPORTANT TO IGNORE THAT THE
CURSE AND WE WERE FIFTY FIVE
YOU YEARS OF A- WITH COVENANTS
WITH A THE HOUSE THAT WE GET SO
WE'RE SERVING FOR MORE. OVER
THE LIFE THESE- UNITS AND
PROPERTIES THAT JUSTICE WAS NOT
THIS PERSON'S AND WAS OFTEN
RATE THE EXISTING UNITS
ACQUIRED BY THE FIRST ROUND OF.
HUNKY FUNDING. WE'LL HAVEWE
WILL HAVE THAT BY THE- APRIL
FIRST REPORTS SO WE JUST GOT
THIS PROJECT REPORTS ON
FEBRUARY FIRST WE REQUIRE
SUBSTANTIAL OCCUPANCY- WITHIN.
NINETY DAYS SO IT'S QUITE
AGGRESSIVE OR THESE PROPERTIES-
I DIDN'T ASK MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE LINE WHO HAS THE MORE
UPDATE INFORMATION. BUT HAVING
TO WE'RE STILL COMING THROUGH
AS OFTEN THREE TO THIS PROJECT
REPORTS SOME OF THOSE
PROPERTIES THAT WERE FUNDED OR
CLOSED- ACQUISITION. IN IN
DECEMBER FOR EXAMPLE. ARE STILL
WITHIN THAT NINETY DAY CLOCK.
SO THEY THERE ARE MANY OF THEM
THAT ARE STILL THE THING UP
THAT IS STILL QUITE- QUITE
SIGNIFICANT AGGRESSIVE FOR MOST
OF THESE PROPERTIES. US
PRESIDENT- COMPARED TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION. AND THE LENGTH OF
TIME IT TAKES THERE. THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER UP. FROM SAID I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY A COUPLE
THINGS. CAN YOU PLEASE RUN DOWN
AGAIN THE FIVE COUNTIES THAT
YOU MENTIONED THERE THE
BIGGEST- YEAH THE FLOOR
ACCOUNTED FOR COUNTIES THAT ARE
ALLOWED TO. ADMINISTER THERE'S
NO PLACE LIKE HOME FUNDS. ON
THEIR OWN IT'S LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO SANTA CLARA AND SAN
FRANCISCO. GOT IT. SO WHEN WILL
YOU HAVE THE REPORTS THE
NUMBERS AVAILABLE IN TERMS OF
THE FOLLOW THROUGH THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER COOPER IS
ASKING FOR IN TERMS OF. THE
MONEY THAT HAS BEEN RECEIVED BY
THESE FOUR COUNTIES WHICH ARE
THE LARGEST- IN USE ART AND I
WOULD SAY L. A. COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY TO A DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES IN WHAT IS KNOWN AS
SKID ROW IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPACTED AREAS. WHEN WILL YOU
HAVE A REPORT AND INTO WHETHER
THE COUNTIES HAVE USED ALL THIS
MONEY OR WHETHER THEY'RE
SITTING ON IT. SURE THEY THEY
WE HAVE THAT WE HAVE IN OUR IN
YOUR WORKS SINCE NOBODY COMES
BEEN GOING ON- FOR A COUPLE
YEARS THAT THAT HAS BEEN
BETTING- PORT IS AVAILABLE AND
I BELIEVE HAS BEEN TRANSMITTED
THE LEGISLATURE. PAST FEW
MONTHS- CERTAINLY- THAT IS
CAPTURED THERE BUT- WE CAN. WE
CAN- WE CAN GIVE YOU THOSE
NUMBERS AS SOON AS AS SOON AS
WE ARE BUT WE DO HAVE A NEW
PLACE TO CALL SPECIFIC REPORT
WHICH I CAN SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE- BONUS HEARING
CONFLICTING. YEAH I THINK PART
OF THE FRUSTRATION THAT WE'RE
ALL EXPERIENCING IS THAT.
HOMELESSNESS CONTINUES TO RISE
WE KEEP ADDING MORE MORE
DOLLARS BUT WERE NOT SEEN ANY
CHANGES- AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
SO I'M I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW WHAT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT
AND TRANSPARENCY PART LOOKS
FROM THE STATE. TO THESE FOUR
COUNTIES AND MAKING SURE THAT.
THE FUNDS THAT WE ARE
ALLOCATING ARE BEING USED- AND
TO BE HONEST NINETY DAYS
ACTUALLY THINGS LIKE QUITE.
LIKE A LONG TIME. TO RUSH
SOMEONE INTO. TO PUT SOMEONE
INTO A- A HOME. WHEN THERE'S SO
MANY. SO MANY PEOPLE ON THE
STREETS RIGHT NOW. SO YOU
MENTIONED FIVE THOUSAND- THAT
HAVE BEEN. PLACED IN NO PLACE
LIKE HOME AND EIGHT THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND PROP ONE.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU. I KNOW MR CHIU IS A HAS
SOME QUESTIONS AND HE'S ON-
FROM HIS OFFICE REMOTE IN HIS
OFFICE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU MEDICARE. THANK YOU MANAGER
CAN HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
GREAT THANK YOU LET ME LET ME
FIRST START BY GIVING CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT'S DUE AND I DO
WANT TO COMPLEMENT THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PROJECT HOME
KEY. WHEN IT COMES WHEN IT BUT
IT HAS COME TO THE SPEED OF
DEPLOYMENT AND OUT FAST. YOU
WERE ABLE TO MOVE ON THIS AS
WELL AS- BEING ABLE TO JUST
HOUSES AS MANY FOLKS AS YOU
WERE ABLE TO QUICKLY I THINK- I
WANTED ONE WITH KNOWLEDGE THAT
UP FRONT- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
CONCERNED THAT I THINK MANY OF
US HAVE IS HOW WE MAINTAIN THIS
PROGRAM IN THE MEDIAN AND SHORT
TERM SO I WANT TO ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IN THAT IN THAT AREA.
SO SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS- THE
STATE IS PROVIDING TWO YEARS OF
CAPITALIZE RESERVES AND THEN
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT LOCALS
ARE HANDLING THE REMAINDER OF
THAT FIVE YEARS- DO YOU HAVE
COST ESTIMATES OF WHAT IT WOULD
COST TO CAPITALIZE RESERVES FOR
THE TYPICAL LIFESPAN OF A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
UNIT WHICH IS FIFTY FIVE YEARS
OF WHAT THAT WOULD COST OR OR-
IF NOT FIFTY FIVE YEARS SOME
REAL PERIOD OF TIME LET'S SAY
TWENTY YEARS. OF WONDERING IF
YOU'VE DONE THAT ANALYSIS. IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION- SO IT'S A
DIFFICULT ONE TO ANSWER BECAUSE
IT DOES DEPEND ON THE PROJECT
FINANCING RIGHT SO TYPICALLY-
AND- AGAIN PLEASE SHARE CONCERN
THAT'S WHY WE ASKED FOR. IT TO
START WITH THE FIRST PART
QUESTION. CHIU CHU- D. THAT'S
WHY WE ASK PROVIDERS
IDENTIFICATION RIGHT WE WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THESE PROJECTS FOR
SUSTAINABLE ONE REAL. AND I WAS
HE THAT WAS BASED ON. YOU KNOW
THE ANALYSIS THAT AND THAT THAT
THE PREVIOUSLY LEARNED RIGHT-
SO I'LL HAVE GUNS WERE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IN. AND PROGRAMS
IT IS SO- TO YOUR QUESTION
QUITE OFTEN. A PROJECTS WILL BE
SEEKING OUT VOUCHERS TO HELP
SUBSIDIZE AS WELL THOSE MIGHT
BE AS PEOPLE WHO ARE
AFFECTIONATE DOCTORS OR THEY
MAY BE- OTHERS ABOUT YOURS FOR
VETERANS AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS SO PROJECTS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THOSE EITHER THROUGH
INDIVIDUAL TENANTS HAVING
VOUCHERS OR WHAT WE CALL
PROJECT BASING OF THOSE DOCTORS
MEANING THE- THE SUBSIDY IS
TIED TO THE- APARTMENT OR UNIT
RATHER THAN THE PERSON. THAT
CAN CHANGE THE DYNAMIC OF WHAT
MIGHT BE NECESSARY FROM AN
OPERATING SUBSIDY RIGHT BECAUSE
THE MORE INCOME COMING INTO THE
PROJECT THE LESS THAT- ABILITY.
IS NO PLACE LIKE HOME RIGHT
WHERE WE WILL CAPITALIZE OF
FRONTS- EIGHTY AN AMOUNT IS
TYPICALLY TIED TO THE UNIT. IT
CAN BE DRAWN DOWN FROM OVER THE
COURSE OF MANY MANY YEARS. THAT
AMOUNT OF COURSE LIKE I SAID
CAN DIFFER BASED ON THE
ANALYSIS OF WHAT OTHER. INCOMES
OR RESOURCES ARE COMING. AND TO
HOLD THE MOST COMMON MIGHT BE
DOCTORS SO. WHAT WE DID EVEN
WITHIN THE INITIAL HOME HE IS
THERE OR DIFFERENT RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO EACH PROJECT AND
SO THE WAY WE STRUCTURED YOU
KNOW LUCKILY WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. A INITIAL COUPLE THE
FEELING WE AS YOU MAY RECALL
ONLY HAD FIFTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND. UP TO SPREAD ACROSS ALL
ALL OF THOSE PROJECTS AND SO-
IT DOES VERY DEPENDING UPON
WHAT OTHER SOURCES OF INCOME
THEY'RE GOING TO BE OVER AGAIN
AND THE OTHER ASPECT THERE IS.
WHEN YOU HAVE SOME OF THESE
PROPERTIES. THAT ARE OPERATING
IN TERM HOUSING COMMUNITIES
CHOSE TO OPERATE THEM AS
INTERIM HOUSING FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE THEY HAD
A REAL NEED- FROM A SHELTER
BASED STANDPOINT WHEN
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING
TO COPE WITH NEED TO GET PEOPLE
IN THE SIX SPACES- THEY'RE
GOING TO BE OVER TIME
CONVERTING THERE'S NO PERMANENT
HOUSING IN WHICH CASE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE RECEIVING SOME
PROGRAMMING CAN EVEN OTHERS
RENTS ARE LOW- THAT DOES CHANGE
CHANGE THE DYNAMIC. AND SO IT
IS TRUE COMMITTEES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO MAKE SOME CHOICES. ARE
AROUND THEIR RESOURCES WHAT
LUCKILY THERE ARE NUMBER OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM.
LIKE MANY NATIVE SOURCES WITHIN
THAT RIGHT THEY USE THEIR-
PASSED SB TWO HOMELESSNESS FUND
OF THE U. THERE HE FINDS THERE
HAPPENS. THERE EMERGES SHELTER
GRANT FUNDS THE RISKY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT FUNDS.
THEIR PERMANENT HOUSING LOCAL
ALLOCATION PLAN FOR THE ONGOING
SOURCE THAT COMES FROM THE
SENATE. SENATE BILL TWO FROM
THAT SOURCE OF HOUSING SO THERE
ARE. A NUMBER OF SOURCES
AVAILABLE TO JURISDICTIONS.
THAT THEY TAPPED INTO. IT IS
ENTIRELY CORRECT THEY ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
SOME CHOICES HERE- IN AN
ONGOING WAY ABOUT HOW THEY
OPERATE THOSE ALTHOUGH. I WILL
SAY FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS FOR COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE DEALING WITH THIS. THAT IS
FAIRLY. THAT'S A KNOWN THING
QUITE TYPICAL WHEN THEIR-
ASSESSING HOW TO BEST USE THEIR
HOMELESSNESS FUNDS THEY'RE
OFTEN GOING TO CONTINUE.
OPERATIONS SERVICES. WITH THE
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDS OTHER.
OKAY SO I WHATEVER YOU SAYING
IS WE WANT TO SET THIS UP FOR
FIVE AND THEN IT SORT OF. GOOD
LUCK TO THE LOCALS TO FIGURE
THIS OUT- I GUESS WHAT I WORE
WHAT WHAT I WHAT I LIKE TO SAY
IS THERE MANY OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE. WHO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IN THE LAST FEW. WE
HAVE MADE SO ONE TIME AND
THAT'S AND HOMELESSNESS BUT WE
HAVE NOT WE VERY MUCH WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT AND AN INABILITY FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO RELY ON
GOING FUNDING. THERE AS YOU
KNOW A DISCUSSION AT THIS
MOMENT ABOUT HOW WE COULD
CREATE A PERMANENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE OF THE REALITY IS-
MAYBE WE HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
BETWEEN LOCALS AND THE STATE TO
PROP THIS UP FOR THE NEXT FEW
YEARS BUT LONG TERM WE DON'T
HAVE A PLAN. I'M WONDERING WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ON THE IDEA
OF BEING ABLE TO COMMIT LONGER
TERM ONGOING FUNDING- WHETHER
WOULD MAKE SENSE FOR US TO HAVE
A PERMANENT SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS. AND- JUST
ALSO JUST CONTEXTUALIZE THE
NUMBERS YOU KNOW THE NUMBERS
WITH PROJECT- RICKY IN HOMELESS
AND HOCKEY WERE REPRESSIVE FOR
THE SHORT TERM- BUT- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOUSANDS IN A
COUPLE INSTANCES TENS OF
THOUSANDS BUT WE'VE GOT OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOLKS.
SO WE ARE TAKING CARE OF YOU
KNOW- IT IS A PERCENTAGE OF THE
PROBLEM BUT BUT SAY 10% OF THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE A LOT MORE OF
THE CHALLENGE TO ADDRESS AND I
THINK THIS GETS AT THE
FRUSTRATION MANY OF US HAVE.
THAT WE ARE NOT. HAVING THE BIG
PICTURE CONVERSATION THAT WE
NEED TO BROWN ONGOING FUNDING
PERMANENT SOURCES OF FUNDING
AND HOW TO REALLY GRAPPLE WITH
THE. BIG PICTURE. YOUR THOUGHTS.
SORRY ABOUT THAT IT IT WELL
IT'S A DONE DEAL WAS JUMPING ON
AND OFF. I'M MORE IN TERMS OF
THAT WE NEED TO DO AS MUCH AS
WE CAN- I MEAN. VERY PLEASED AT
WORK AND HOME HE THAT I MEAN
YES THE SCOPE OF OUR PROBLEM IS
SIGNIFICANT BUT SIX THOUSAND
UNITS ONLINE SEARCH FOR PERIOD
IS. IS QUITE SIGNIFICANT I MEAN
I DON'T THINK WE I THINK THAT'S
WHAT I WANT TO DO MORE OF IT-
YOU KNOW I WILL SAY A COUPLE
THOUGHTS HERE. HAVING WORKED IN
THIS FIELD FOR QUITE A WHILE A
LONG TIME AND MAYBE I'M
EXPOSING THE DIRTY LITTLE
SECRET BUT- NEVER. IN THE
INITIAL FOR SUPPORT HOUSING
PROGRAMS THE STATE EMPLOYED IT
WE ACTUALLY BEEN REQUIRE-
OPERATING. RESERVES OR THE WAY
THAT WE ASK FOR HUNKY RIGHT
MAYBE THAT THEIR TERRIBLE
SECRET BUT IT WAS QUITE COMMON.
AND IS QUITE COMMON FOR SUPPORT
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO BE HAVING
TO FIGURE OUT THAT. EVERY
COUPLE YOU KNOW EVERY COUPLE
YEARS BECAUSE LOCAL COMMITMENTS
WORKING YOUR COMMENTS YOU'RE
GETTING WITH CARE. ARE
HAPPENING ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
RIGHT COUNTY CITIES. IN THE
CARE AREN'T WILLING HERE NOT
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO COMMIT
TEN TWENTY YEARS. RIGHT THAT'S
WHY NO PLACE LIKE HOME SO
SIGNIFICANT. IN THE COUNTIES
ASSEMBLY AGREEING TO TWENTY
YEARS. OF OPERATING SUPPORT AND
SERVICES. STILL TRIED TO BUILD
ON THAT- OBVIOUSLY COULD DO
MORE. I WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE I
THINK WITH GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES CAN DO. MORE BECAUSE
WE HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY IN.
THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHAT ONE BUT
WONDERFUL CERTAINLY MORE THESE
PRO. TO BE BY HAVE. HELP AND
THAT'S WHY WE- GET AS MUCH AS
WE COULD YOU KNOW WHAT. WITH
THE- RESOURCES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE THAT FOR THAT PER-
LET ME OUR DEPARTMENTS WERE.
HERE GOOD AND READY TO PARTNER
IF THERE IS A- DECISION TO
AWARD MORE RESOURCES AROUND.
STRAIGHT WE HAVE. A LOT OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE. RIGHT NOW
WE ARE DEPLOYING MORE EMERGENCY
RESOURCES OF COURSE- THE CASE
ACT AND THE SORTS OF THINGS
WHICH ARE. IN MOST CASES
FALLING DIRECTLY BACK DOWN TO
COMMUNITIES. AND OTHER SOURCES
CERTAINLY AVAILABLE TO DO
ONGOING- MEDIATE NEED AN
ONGOING- BUT I'LL JUST SIT HERE
HAVING YOU KNOW WE ARE GROWTH
THE PROGRAMS HAS BEEN.
SIGNIFICANT OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS WE ARE. DEPLOYING
THEM HOPING. THAT JUST IF YOU
ARE THAT THEY CAN MAKE AS MUCH
IMPACT AS POSSIBLE. BUT THE
PROPERTY A SKILL THE SKILL IS
SIGNIFICANT RIGHT I HEAR IT
FROM YOU GUYS- AND- FROM
EVERYBODY IT'S- I SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS ABOUT SEEING SO MANY
PEOPLE. ON THE STREETS THAT'S
WHY WE'RE IN THIS WORK THAT'S
WHY WE ARE TRYING TO DEPLOY THE
FUNDS IS. AFFECTED BY THIS
POSSIBLE AS WE ARE TRYING TO DO
MORE. SO YEAH MY THOUGHTS ARE.
HAPPY TO STAND READY TO DO MORE.
IF THERE ARE MORE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO. AND I WHAT I
WOULD SAY RESPONSE I PREACH YOU
SHARE. YOUR THE LITTLE C. WHICH
WE'VE ALL KNOWN. AS THE FACT OF
THE MATTER BECAUSE DIRTY LITTLE
SECRET WE WERE COMPLETELY
UNSUCCESSFUL IN THE PAST IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. NOW
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
SECRET OF HOW DO WE FUND
ONGOING HAVE OPERATED CITIES.
IT'S GOOD WE'RE FINALLY TALKING
ABOUT IT BUT WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE AN ANSWER TO IT AND YOUR
POINT- THE PROGRAMS WERE
TALKING ABOUT HAVE SALT 345% OF
THE PROBLEM. WE STILL HAVE
9295% OF THE PROBLEMS LEFT AND
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW
I'VE NO MISTRUSTED FOR. FOR
NUMBER OF YEARS AND I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY COMMITTED TO FIGURE
THIS OUT I THINK WHAT I WOULD
SUGGEST IS. I HEAR YOU SAYING
WE CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT MORE REVENUES BUT WE'RE
REALLY NOT HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT MORE
REVENUES WERE HERE AND ON THE
OTHER HAND. THERE'S NOT GONNA
BE DISCUSSION AROUND A
PERMANENT SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS- WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT ONGOING FUNDING IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IF WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO CREDIBLY TELL.
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE HAVE A
PLAN. TO ACTUALLY AND
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR LIFETIME OR
IN A GENERATION SO- I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONVERSATION I
JUST HOPE THAT WE WILL REALLY.
REALLY ENGAGE IN AND WHAT THIS
ALL MEANS- THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPORTANT. IN
THE SHORT TERM DURING CHRONIC
VIRUS BUT I THINK. UNLESS WE
REALLY STAND THEM UP WITH A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT. WE'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE A SHOT AT ENDING
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN OUR OUR
LIFETIMES. OF MILLION AND
MILLION WITH. ONE FINAL
QUESTION- S. MINISTRATION THING
ABOUT A LONG TERM. FOR PROJECT
HOME KEY. HOW WILL YOU HELP
EACH CITY REALLY MEASURE. THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM I NOTE
FROM THE L. A- NOW SAYS THAT
WHEN HE CAME TO. PROJECT ROOM
KEY. THAT PROJECTS EXPERIENCED
LOW OCCUPANCY RATES AMONG LEAST
UNITS AND- IT HAD A LOT OF
CHALLENGES AND JUST CURIOUS.
HOW WILL YOU MEASURE THE
SUCCESS OF THISPROGRAM IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS WHAT WHAT
METRICS SHOULD WE BE LOOKING
FOR THAT YOU'RE GOING TO FOCUS
ON. SURE SO NO WE- DEFINITELY
IT JUST TO BE CLEAR VERY
DIFFERENT PROGRAM I KNOW THEY
GET TIED TOGETHER QUITE OFTEN
IN OUR DIALOGUE BUT ON VERY
DIFFERENT KIND OF MECHANISM FOR
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE WE'RE
PROVIDING. THROUGH HOKEY YOU
KNOW PERMANENT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS RIGHT- THAT AS
OPPOSED TO TEMPORARY. SO JUST
AS WE WILL IT AS AS WE WOULD
FOR OTHER TYPES OF HOUSING
PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY SUPPORTER
HOUSING PROGRAMS. YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE OF COURSE
OCCUPANCY RATES AND TURNOVER-
YOU KNOW. I'M NOT CONCERNED.
FROM THE- REPORTS THEY BECAUSE
WITH SO MUCH DEMAND ABOUT THERE
BEING FULL OCCUPANCY OF ALL
THESE PROJECTS- YOU'RE LOOKING
AT- BUT THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
ONE OF THE METRIC STYLE I WOULD
I WOULD SUGGEST RIGHT AND I DO
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT I DID
MENTION IT A LITTLE BIT I DON'T
THINK WE DO A GOOD ENOUGH JOB.
TALKING ABOUT INVESTMENT AND
WITH THAT SHE WAS OVER A LONG
TERM. WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT THE
PER UNIT COST OF SOMETHING
WHETHER BE NEW CONSTRUCTION OR
SOMETHING EVEN MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE ABOUT ACQUISITION.
BUT WE DON'T. TAKE IN YOUR MIND
THE FACT THAT WE'RE SERVING
HOUSEHOLDS FOR FIFTY FIVE YEARS
IN MOST CASES WITH THE SUPPORT.
SO THAT'S LIKE MANY MANY MANY
HOUSEHOLDS OVER THAT TIME. THAT
GOES TO YOUR POINT AND THE
POINT OF OTHERS AROUND MAKING
SURE THESE ARE FIFTEEN. THE WAY
WE DO THAT- I WOULD POSIT IS BY
CAPITALIZING OPERATING SUBSIDY
RESEARCHERS. AT THE AT THE
OUTSET- THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN BUILDING INTO ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROGRAMS IN
RECENT YEARS. AND HAPPY THAT
WE'VE- BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT- I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS
YOU CAN. PROVIDE THAT
SUSTAINABILITY AND THAT
CERTAINTY. OBJECT LEVEL- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO THAT CERTAINLY
HELP KEEP ANY ANY SUPPORTER
HOUSING KIND OF APPROACH I
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT INCLUDES
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO YOU'RE
NOT ONLY FINANCING THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION OR TICKETS TO THE
ACQUISITION WHICH ARE ALSO
CAPITALIZING AND A ONE TIME
TIME UP FRONT ITS OPERATING
RESERVE THAT CAN BE DRAWN FROM
OVERTIME SO I THINK THAT'S A
BEST PRACTICE THAT WE WOULD
LIKE. SO AGAIN I HEAR THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS. THAT YOU
SHOULD THE THAT YOU SHOULD GET
CREDIT FOR THE FACT THAT WE
ARE. MAKING AN INVESTMENT FOR
FIFTY FIVE YEARS AND YET WE
ONLY HAVE A PLAN TO PAY FOR THE
FIRST. FIVE SPRITE SO. THAT
AGAIN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE LONG TERM PLAN IS AND I
DON'T SEE IT YET AND I THINK
MANY OF US. ARE EAGER TO ENGAGE
IN THAT CONVERSATION OF AGAIN
ONGOING FUNDING PERMANENT
SOURCE OF FUNDING FUNDING THAT
IS ADEQUATE TO MEET THE NEED-
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- AT
THIS MOMENT SCRATCHING 5210% OF
THAT. OKAY I'LL BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU- THE NUMBER IT'S-
I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW. HOW THE
PROCESS CAN BE COMPLICATED
THERE ARE RESOURCES OF COURSE
AVAILABLE TO DO THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT. HOW WE LOST SUPPORT OF
HOUSING PROJECTS HAVE BECOME
OFFLINE IF THEY'RE BUILT TWENTY
YEARS AGO YOU KNOW THE ANSWER I
THINK IT BY ACROSS WHAT'S NOW.
RIGHT WE HAVE AS COMMUNITIES
AS- THROUGH THE VARIOUS
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AT THE
LOCAL STATE FEDERAL LEVEL-
MAINTAIN THOSE PROPERTIES THERE
ARE. RESOURCES OF COURSE
THROUGH A REHABILITATION TO TAX
CREDITS THAT OFF AND ON YOU
KNOW FIFTEEN YEARS INTO THE
PROJECT OR THINGS LIKE THAT SO.
I WOULD EXPECT WE WOULD SEE
MANY OF THESE PROPERTIES AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES- BUT I THINK YOU
MAKE A GREAT POINT WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THE POOR BOY THAT
WE'RE. CREATING- GROWING IT
OVER TO AND WE'RE NOT LOSING.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO DEAL
PRESERVATION WHICH SHALL I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GET
YOU HELP THAT PART OF THE ISSUE
HERE IT'S- IT'S- THE LONG TERM
OPERATIONS ARE ABOUT
PRESERVING. WHAT WE HAVE
INVESTED IN. AND CERTAINLY. WE
SHARE THAT GOAL. WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO AS MUCH THAT.
IT HAPPENED THANK YOU PUBLIC
PART OF THE CONVERSATION A
MANAGER BACK TO YOU. THANKS
THANK YOU OR SOMEONE AND THINK
YOU MR ON. FOR THE DISCUSSION I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM.
OUR COLLEAGUES MY COLLEAGUES IS
A DESIRE TO WANT TO FIGURE OUT
A MORE LONG TERM SOLUTION. TO
THE FUNDING ISSUE THE UPPER.
CURRENTLY THE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES FOR A TWO TO THREE
YEARS SINCE NIGHT- IT'S NOT A
LONG TERM WHEN. AND SO WE WANT
TO WE WANT TO FIGURE OUT A NEW
MODEL THAT WORKS A IN AN EFFORT
TO REALLY PROTECT. THE HOME KEY
INVESTMENTS AND WHAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY LOOK LIKE IN THE
FUTURE AS WE- ARE TRYING TO
PROVIDE MARGINAL FUNDING. US
HAVE A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
ARE- HOMEWORK SO WE HAVE A
APRIL FIRST REPORT THE DATA
SHOULD BE- PROVIDED IN TERMS
OF- DIVIDED INTO ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY SEATS SO THAT WE KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON NOR THE FUNDING
IS BEING INVESTED- IN ADDITION
TO. GETTING MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE FOR COUNTIES LA SANTA
CLARA SAN DIEGO IN SAN
FRANCISCO AS TO. WHAT THEIR
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN AND WHERE
THOSE FUNDS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED. NOW IN ADDITION TO
MORE INFORMATION ON THE TWO
PROJECTS RELATED TO- SERVICING
YOUTH AND ALL CENTRO IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND YOU
MENTIONED TWENTY ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS- THAT HAD. NOT ALL BUT
SOME. FUNDS DEDICATED TO
HOMELESS YOUTH AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING THAT
INFORMATION FROM YOU IN A
TIMELY MANNER SO THAT WE CAN.
CONTINUE DOING THE WORK
NECESSARY TO HOUSE ON HOUSE
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALL YOUR EFFORTS AND
FOR BEING ON THIS PANEL LET'S
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO- WE HAVE A MISS
SEAGER- MISS CRUZ AND MISS
MORALIS THIS ISSUE IS RELATED
TO INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE. GRANT
PROGRAM LET'S BEGIN. MISSY
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS JENNIFER SPEAKER- I AM
DE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR STATE FUNDED
PROGRAMS. EACH CITY IS
REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM. AT THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
WAS CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN TO PROVIDE GAP FINANCING
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
SUPPORT HIGHER DENSITY
AFFORDABLE AND MIXED INCOME
HOUSING IN LOCATIONS DESIGNATED
AND FELL. THIS REQUEST INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
CURRENT YOUR RESOURCES AS AN
EARLY ACTION ECONOMIC STIMULUS
FUNDING AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TARGETED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
REDUCE REMEDIATION OF
BROWNFIELD SITES FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. ADDITIONALLY WERE
REQUESTING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO AUTHORIZE THAT THE
GRANTS FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
PREPARATION BE OFFERED ON AN
OVER THE COUNTER BASIS. WITH A
SPECIFIC DEFINITION OF
QUALIFYING INFILL AREAS AND
PROJECTS FOR SMALL
JURISDICTIONS AND WHICH WE ARE
DEFINING AS COUNTIES WITH A
POPULATION OF UNDER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND. ALBANY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. LET'S HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DANA CRUZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH IS
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS REQUEST
WILL NEARLY DOUBLE THE FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AS WELL AS
MAKING IT AVAILABLE FOR BOTH
TRADITIONAL- INFO AWARDS AS
WELL AS SITE REMEDIATION I
WOULD THINK AND CAN HELP BUILD
UP MORE HOUSING. THANK YOU.
WHEN I WAS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I APOLOGIZE
I'M GOING TO KEEP MY CAMERA OFF
AND HOPE IT STABILIZES MY
INTERNET CONNECTION. I'M
COMMENT ON THIS PROPOSAL FIRST
RELATED TO THE EARLY ACTION
REQUEST YOUR AGAIN ASK ABOUT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S KINDLY
EARLY ACTION AS WE ARE NEARING
THE END OF. OF THE BUDGET YEAR
AND- WHAT ARE THE BENEFITS OF
ADDITIONAL ACTION THIS TIME.
THE COMMITTEE THAT THERE IS A
PROPOSAL WITHIN THE TOP
DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL FOR THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND RELATED TO
INVESTIGATING AND REMEDIATING
FRANKLY BROWNFIELD AS A MATTER
IF IT'S OF THE OVERLAP IN THE-
PURPOSES OF THESE PROVISIONS
ATHLETE MAGICIAN TO SPEAK TO
HOW THESE PROGRAMS WORK
TOGETHER. TO ADDRESS WHAT WOULD
BE ONE OF THE PRIORITY WOULD BE
FORWARD. FOR THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
MISTER COOPER MANAGER THANK
YOU. HOW MANY BROWNFIELD SITES
WITH THE TO A FIFTY MILLION
EARLY ACTION FUND. WELL WE
DON'T HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF
EXACTLY HOW MANY SITES BASED ON
AND HISTORICAL FUNDING UNDER
THE PROGRAM WE ESTIMATE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE-
ADDITIONAL HAS SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL HOUSING
UNITS COULD BE FUNDED. AS OTHER
LIST OF SITES RUBIO PLAQUE FOR
THE FUNDING. AND WE HAVE A THE
NUMBER THAT WENT OUT INTO THAT
FOR THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
GENERAL FUND- AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WAS SIGNIFICANTLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED SO WE DO HAVE
KIND OF A BACKLOG OF PROJECTS
THAT WE KNOW ARE READY TO.
APPLY FOR FUNDING AND
ANTICIPATE SOME OF THAT NOVEL
WITHOUT THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL SITES THAT HAVE COME
ONLINE. AND CAN YOU TELL ME
WHERE THESE SITES ARE
CONCENTRATED AT. I KEEP PROGRAM
FUNDS PROJECTS STATEWIDE- WE
HAVE OLD IN LARGE URBAN. AREAS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY
AREA THE CENTRAL VALLEY- AS
WELL AS SMALLER PROJECTS AND
SOME OF THE MORE WHAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER MORE RURAL COUNTIES SO
IT REALLY IS A STATEWIDE-
FUNDING SOURCE THAT'S UTILIZED.
IN THE L. L. RAISES QUESTIONS
OF WHETHER THE REQUEST IS TIME
SENSITIVE CAN YOU RESPOND TO
THAT PLEASE. I GUESS I WOULD
FOR ME BE TO DENY AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TAKE THE FIRST. STEP AT
THAT QUESTION. SURE SURE HAPPY
TO DINNER CRUISE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN TERMS OF THE TIMING
OF THIS. OF THIS COMES- AFTER
SINCERE VERSION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN INVESTMENT OF
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THREE. SO
GIVEN THE COMPETITIVENESS IN
OVERSEAS CHRISTIAN OF THIS
PROGRAM- THE NEED FOR GIVING-
FUNDING- BASICALLY SOONEST. AS
POSSIBLE FOR- INTO
INFRASTRUCTURE WE SEE IS VERY
IMPORTANT- AND THAT HAPPENED TO
YOU- I REFERRED BACK TO EIGHTY
ANYTHING ELSE ACT. I KNOW I
WOULD JUST ADD TO THAT THINKING
I WOULD JUST ADD TO THAT- BASED
ON THE NUMBERS WE WERE ALMOST
AND- I HAD A PERCENT
OVERSUBSCRIBED. IN THE EFFORT
THAT WE ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND LATE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
SO WE ANTICIPATE THOSE
PROJECTS- BUT I'LL BE MOVING
FORWARD. UNDER THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I
I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON A
QUESTION RELATED TO YOUR
QUESTIONS MISTER COOPER AND THE
OVER SUBSCRIPTION OF THE
PROGRAM IF IT HAS WHY WOULD WE
CHANGE THE FOCUS TO BROWN FILLS
OF THERE IS STILL A NEED FOR
THE CORE. I. I. G. PROGRAM. SO
CURRENTLY THAT HISTORIC THE
HISTORICAL PROGRAM. HAS
PROVIDED SOME FUNDING FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL REMEDIATION BUT
THE PROGRAM CAPS. THE USE OF
PROGRAM FUNDS FOR THAT PURPOSE
THAT ABOUT. 20% OF THE TOTAL
MAXIMUM AWARD. SO YOU CAN'T
REALLY GET TO. THE REQUIRED
REMEDIATION FOR SOME OF THESE
AND MORE DIFFICULT TO DEVELOP.
SITE SAID THIS. THIS FUNDING
FOR THE BROWNFIELDS BUT REALLY
FOCUSED IN ON THOSE SITES THAT
ARE MORE DIFFICULT TO DEVELOP.
BUT YET HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR. AND COULD YOU SEE MORE
HOUSING AND THEN THE- THE
GENERAL PROGRAM WITH FOCUS ON
MAYBE THOSE SITES THAT ARE
LITTLE MORE. READY TO GO AND
CAN KIND OF- ME THROUGH THE
PIPELINE MORE QUICKLY. MISTER
LUCKY YEAH THIS REAL QUICKLY
THIS IS PROBABLY- ANSWERED
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND A TO A SIMPLE-QUESTION THAT'S BEEN KIND OF
TOUCHED ON WHAT WHAT STEPS ARE
BEING TAKEN TO ENSURE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE I. R. G.
FUNDS TO SMALLER CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO MEET THE TERMS OF
THE PROGRAM. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION AS A MEMBER
LACKEY- SO IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THERE'S A GROUP. OF CRUEL
DISTRIBUTION OF IRAQI FUNDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- THIS
REQUEST ACTUALLY INCLUDES
TRAILER BILL THAT TRIES TO
MIRROR THE LANGUAGE TO ALLOW A-
THE POT- SET ASIDE FOR SMALL
JURISDICTIONS THAT THEY ALSO
HAVE A CHANCE OF GETTING OF
WORKS- AGAIN THAT'S PART OF THE
IDEA. OF AN APPLICATION FUSION
WILL KEEP ALSO KEEPING IN MIND
THAT ARE CURRENTLY I BELIEVE IN
THE REGULATIONS FOR I. G. THEY
ALSO TAKE IN CONSIDERATION OF
THE LOCATION. AND THE NEEDS OF
THE- THE- OUT. OF PROJECTS IN
APPLICANTS. I WOULD JUST ADD TO
THAT AND NOTE THAT THE NO FAT-
PROVIDES TARGETING FOR VARIOUS
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS- SO WHILE
THERE IS KIND OF A SET ASIDE
FOR THE SMALLER. AND
JURISDICTIONS THERE'S ALSO A
REGIONAL TARGETS FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY AREA AT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AS WELL TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GETTING KIND
OF THAT BROAD BASED
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDS. AS A
AS A FOLLOW UP TO THAT. HOW
MUCH WILL BE SET ASIDE FOR
BROWNFIELDS AND SPONSORS TO A
SMALL JURISDICTIONS. SO WE
ANTICIPATE- TYING IT TO THE
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS KIND OF
STATEWIDE THAT ACTUALLY MEET
THAT DEFINITION OF THE COUNTY
WITH LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND POPULATION SO
PROPORTIONALLY WE'RE LOOKING AT
PROBABLY AROUND 15% OF FUNDS.
15% DIET AND MESSIER. CAN YOU
PROVIDE THIS COMMITTEE WTH A
REPORT. ON WHERE THOSE- BUT
WHERE THE GRANT PROGRAM HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER IT'S KIND
OF IT'S A STATEWIDE PROGRAM BUT
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE- THESE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO. ANDIF SO HOW QUICKLY
CAN YOU PROVIDE THAT. I AM I
DON'T HAVE THE DATA AVAILABLE-
TODAY UNFORTUNATELY BUT- I.
WORK TO TRY AND PULL THAT DATA
THAT BEFORE THE END OF THE DAY
OR AND POTENTIALLY BEFORE THE
END OF THE HEARING. GREAT THAT
WOULD BE I THINK THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO KNOW AND-
TRUST- BEING. HAVE SOMETHING
TANGIBLE FOR US TO SEE AND BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE WORK. THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WITH YOUR
FORWARD. I'M SORRY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COMMUTER CAME OUT OF- IF
I COULD JUST ASK ONE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ON THAT- I THINK I
MIGHT HEARD THE ANSWER BUT-
HAVE YOU PROVIDED A BREAKDOWN
OF YOUR TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ALLOCATION. AND I'M WONDERING
IF YOU COULD TELL US AGAIN HOW
MANY HOUSING UNITS DID WE GET
OUT OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN.
BUDGET ALLOCATION. ASSEMBLY
TWEEN THE LARGE JURISDICTIONS
IN THE SMALL JUISDICTIONS WE
MADE AWARDS TOTALING ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION- AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THAT WILL- RESULT IN. JUST OVER
SIXTY SEVEN HUNDRED UNITS OF
WHICH ABOUT SIXTY THREE HUNDRED
OF THOSE WOULD BE- AFFORDABLE
TO LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
SIXTY THREE SO I IT'S HARD TO
DO THE BACK THE ENVELOPE. YES
BUT THAT'S FIFTY TO SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT. THAT
HOW IT'S PLAYING OUT. OKAY THAT
SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT HOW DOES IT
COMPARE WITH PAST
INFRASTRUCTURE. GRANT PROGRAMS.
I AM I DON'T KNOW WHAT ARE KIND
OF PER UNIT COST WAS FOR- THE
IG PROGRAM FUNDED UNDER ADAM
FORTY SIX BUT WE CAN LOOK INTO
THAT AS WELL AND PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEASURE. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU MESSIER AND
EVERYONE FOR- THIS ISSUE NUMBER
TWO- AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING SOME MORE INFORMATION-
TO THE REPORT STATEWIDE AS WELL
AS THE COMPARISON PER THE PER
UNIT COST THAT WOULD BE
ACTUALLY REALLY GREAT TO HAVE
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE HOUSING LAW ASSISTANCE.
WE HAVE- MISS KIRBY MR CRUZ AND
MISS MORALIS. LET'S BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THIS
IS MEGAN COULD BE I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING
POLICY AT EACH CITY AND SO IN
TERMS OF THE HOUSING LAWS THE
PROGRAM THIS IS THAT REQUEST
WERE MAKING TO SUPPORT OUR-
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING LAWS
AND RANGING FROM HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW KNOWN AT LA LA AND
HOUSING CAN ABILITY ACT AND
SEVERAL OTHERS AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE BASICALLY THERE TO- I.
HOW SIX UNDERSTAND THEIR
OBLIGATION- AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE MEETING THEM IN THE
INTERESTS AND GREATER HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND- MEETING OF OUR
HOUSING BUBBLE. THANK YOU MR
KIRBY MISTER CHRISTMAS BROTHERS.
DANA CRUZ DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AT NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THANK
YOU. THE LEGISLATIVE ACT THIS
YEAR THE COMMITTEE IS WELL
AWARE OF THE STATE'S HOUSING
SHORTAGES IN THIS WILL HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP THE STATE YOU
NEED ITS HOUSING GOALS I'M IN
THE AGENDA THAT THE STOCK
MARKET. IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE RAISED FOR
CONSIDERATION REALLY FOCUS ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MAJOR
QUESTION OUR MIND IS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD PRIORITIZE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
VERSUS THE ENFORCEMENT
COMPONENTS- THAT IS ALSO A
PIECE OF THIS PROPOSAL. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE IN YOUR QUESTION
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU SO
INTO OF THIS HEY TO GIVE A
LITTLE CONTACT- IF YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE A NUMBER OF
STRATEGIES TO PROMOTE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW AND
ENCOURAGE HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND WE HAVE A REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM- WE HAVE
PLANNING GRANT HEALTHCARE
SECTION COMPLY FROM THE START.
AND WE ALSO HOSTS NUMEROUS
MEMOS AND RESOURCES ON OUR
WEBSITE HELP MAKE THESE COMPLEX
LIVES EASIER TO UNDERSTAND AND
COMPLY WITH- AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
ABOUT EVERY TEN YEARS WE GET TO
DO A DEEP DIVE WITH EVERY
JURISDICTION DURING THE HOUSING
ELEMENT PROP THAT- TO REVIEW
THEIR HOUSING PLAN AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE PLANNING FOR.
REMOVING BARRIERS AND
ENCOURAGING THEIR DEVELOPMENT
HAPPEN IN THEIR IN THEIR
JURISDICTION AND MANY OF A LOT
OF HAVE BEEN STRENGTHENED IN
RECENT YEARS- AND SO THAT THAT
WE KNOW THAT A LOT AND BURKE
FOR JURISDICTIONS TO CATCH UP
WITH- AND CERTAINLY THE WORK
THEY WERE DOING CAN'T PREVENT
EVERY AND ALL COMPLIANCE ISSUE
FROM FROM HAPPENING- SO
CURRENTLY WE TYPICALLY RECEIVE
REQUEST EITHER. FROM
JURISDICTIONS THERE- ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT IMPLEMENTING
THE LAW OR REQUEST AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP ADVOCATES ARE
DEVELOPERS THAT MIGHT BE SEEN
POTENTIAL HOUSING LAWS BY LEECH
AND- SO WE ALWAYS START CURRENT
TECHNICAL OF THE TEMPERATURE-
WE TRY TO SPEAK RESOLUTION THAT
WAY 99% OF THE TIME AND- THAT
THAT- OF THAT VIABLE PATH-BUT-
SHOULD NOT BE WE CAN ISSUE A
NOTICE OF VIOLATION AND ENGAGE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL- AND THE
PROPOSAL REALLY COMES OUT OF
OUR LESSONS LEARNED FROM THAT
WORK THAT. WOULD LIKE TO BE
DOING MORE PROACTIVE- WORK TO
PREVENT VIOLATIONS UP FRONT I
AM OFTEN COMPLAINTS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY COMING TO OUT
THEMSELVES- VERY LATE IN THE
PROCESS- WE ALSO WANT TO
AMPLIFY THE TECHNICAL THINGS WE
DO NOW THAT WE'RE WE'RE
CHANGING THAT THE COURSE OF THE
EVENT FOR MORE THAN JUST ONE
INCIDENT AND THAT TIME- AND I'M
ALSO REALIZING THAT THIS WORK
IS INCREDIBLY NEW ON. HIGH
LEVEL TIME. CONSUMING- AND WHEN
WE REALLY- DA WANT TO LOSE THAT
THING I FOUGHT FOR- AND THERE.
THERE IS MORE DEMAND- I'M THEN
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO KEEP KEEP UP
WITH. AND BUT IT IN EVERY STEP
OF THE PROCESS. I WE SEE A IS.
I TYPE OF THE- IS THE BIG WE
DON'T EVER. BERMAN AND FOR.
THAT WE ASSUME THAT EVERY WANTS
COMPLY. AND WITH THE LAW AND IF
IT. IT'S JUST A LOT THAT- TO
KEEP WITH AND THAT APPROACHES
GIVE AS PROOF- A COUPLE BLACK
THE- BACK OF. OUR PRIORITIZE A
WHEN CHANGE. THANK YOU FOR THE
WILL BE. A HDD A REGULAR TO
PROVIDE CLARITY TO THE PROGRAM
AND HOW THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT WORK FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU AND SO THAT IN TERMS
OF REGULATIONS THAT'S NOT
ENVISIONED AT THIS TIME- THIS
IS- WE HAVE A SET OF HOUSING
LAWS THAT WE ARE GIVEN AT THE
READY HUMOR BURKE NUMBER FOR
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS. ANY
GENERAL AROUND AND WE DO SPELL
OUT ON OUR WEBSITE THAT THE
PROCESS- OF THAT. I. T. A.
APPROACH FIRST. AND LOTS OF
NOTED THAT JURISDICTION- SHOULD
THERE BE ANY ISSUES OPPORTUNITY
FOR MEETINGS AT THAT TRACK-
BEFORE ANY AG INVOLVEMENT IS IN
PLACE BUT A LOT OF THAT KIND-
IS JUST BUILDING OUT STATUTES
THAT GIVE. GIVE A FAIR AMOUNT
OF CLARITY AROUND- AROUND THE
PROCESS OF ENGAGING THE AG. I'M
ON HAVE BEEN LOCKED. HOW IT HE
CAN ENGAGE THE AG ON HELPING.
GOT IT OKAY THANK YOU IT SEEMS
LIKE WE TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
FOLLOW UP WITH THAT THEN IF.
THE REGULATIONS ARE CURRENTLY
IN PLACE. SAT CORRECT. YES NO
NO REGULATIONS ARE CURRENTLY IN
PLACE THERE- DOES THAT
LEGISLATION IS FAIRLY CLEAR AND
PROCESS HERE BUT- BUT IF YOU
HAVE CONCERNS YOU BUDGET BACK
AND- WHERE WILL HAVE A TICKET
STYLE. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
LUCKY YEAH I JUST HAVE A REAL
QUICK QUESTION HERE IT HAVING
COME FROM A LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT
IT'S NOT A GOOD FEELING WHEN
THE STATE SENDS ENFORCEMENT
PEOPLE AND TO OVERSEE YOUR
PLANNING PROCESS IN YOUR DAILY
WORK. I JUST WONDER IS THERE
ANYTHING TO JUSTIFY WHAT WHAT
APPEARS TO BE MISTRUST. I'M AYE
I HOPE IT IS IT DOESN'T COME
ACROSS AS MISTRUST- BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT. I DON'T THINK
SO- WHERE WE HAVE- A LOT OF OUR
REPORT BECAUSE AT THE MOMENT
HAS BEEN- ON THE FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN PLANNING
GRANT- WHICH WE'VE NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE. I'M GOING INTO
A HOUSING ELEMENT CYCLE BEFORE-
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
GIVEN HOW MUCH THE BAR HAS BEEN
RAISED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
OVER TIME. AND FELT THAT THAT
THE FRAME THAT WE START FROM-
BUT WE DO ALSO GET LOTS OF
COMPLAINTS FROM- FROM
DEVELOPERS WHO ARE HITTING A
WALL GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS.
BUT EVEN WHEN THAT OCCURS WE
DON'T START FROM PLACING A
STRAP. ON THERE'S ALWAYS
MEDICATION AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND- BUT YOU WANT TO THE
SITUATION- AND IT IS VERY OFTEN
A LOT. AND YOU KNOW WE DO TRY
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COMING FROM AND OUR
OUR GOAL IS REALLY TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THEIR THEIR
OBLIGATION- THEY THEY HAVE A
LOT OF POWER IN THE SITUATION
TO MAKE DECISIONS OVER THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT- BUT THERE ARE
CERTAIN PLACES WHERE. THE
BURDE IS ON THEM QUE TO
JUSTIFY SAYING NO TO OUT TO AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
FOR EXAMPLE TO WONDER FINAL A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION WILL. THESE
H. S. C. D. PEOPLE BE OUT
WANDERING CITY PLANNING
COMMITTEES AND DAILY. WORK IN
THE PLANNING OFFICES AND COULD
YOU ME AND IF THE QUESTION A
LITTLE BETTER. YEAH OR ARE THEY
GOING TO BE GOING TO. THE CITY
PLANNING COMMITTEE MEETINGS
WHICH ARE REGULARLY EVERY
MONTH. ARE THESE HUD OFFICIALS
GOING TO BE THERE TO MONITOR
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE. BECAUSE
THAT THAT KIND OF. SET FOR
LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE SORT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND ALSO. JUST
THE DAILY WORK OF THE PLANNING
OFFICE IS THIS GOING TO BE KIND
OF A- PERMANENT PLACEMENT OF
SOMEBODY THERE. I WOULD
ENVISION- THAT KIND OF AND
RESOURCE DEPLOYMENT- I DO HINK
THAT WE- ARE INTERESTED IN IN-
AS AS AS OUR COLLECTIVE WORK
BUILDS IN IDENTIFYING AND
ANALYZING POTENTIAL CAUSES
BEYOND BEHIND THEM LOW HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND THE PLACES WHERE
WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN A COMPLAINT
BUT WE'RE WE'RE SEEING AND-
THAT REALLY WHAT THE TROUBLE
MEETING A HOUSING GOAL WE MIGHT
WANT TO I'M TRYING TO IDENTIFY
AND ANALYZE POTENTIAL COGNIZANT
THAT. THAT MIGHT AND COVERS
SOME ISSUES AND NON COMPLIANCE
BUT I MIGHT OFFEND COVER AND
POLICY ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THROUGH OTHER
CHANNELS SO AND I DON'T I DON'T
THINK IT AND- I DIDN'T GET THAT
CERTAINLY AT MY ROOM MY VISION
OF RESOURCE DEPLOYMENT WOULD
NOT BE STARTING FROM AND
SITTING IN. ON EVERY PLANNING
COMMITTEE MEETING. RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR THAT MATTER. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR ONE TEN OF ELEVEN
HERE. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER. TO
YOU MIGHT IF I JUMP IN WITH A
QUESTION. GO AHEAD- I'D LIKE TO
I'D LIKE TO JUST I GUESS
PRESENTED DIFFERENT-
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS COMMITTEE I
WAS VERY GLAD TO SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKE THIS
PROPOSAL IN THIS AREA- I THINK
THERE ARE MANY CITIES THAT ARE.
ABIDING BY OUR HOUSING LAWS IN
THIS AREA BUT THEY- IT'S NOT AN
ACCIDENT THAT CALIFORNIA IS
THREE AND A HALF MILLION UNITS
BEHIND WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND THERE ARE MANY
DOCUMENTED INSTANCES OF
VIOLATIONS BY DIFFERENT CITIES.
FOR NON COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW WITH THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT WITH DENSITY
BONUS LAW WITH ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAW AND- AND I
FOR ONE OF VERY MUCH SUPPORT-
THIS SUPPORT AND I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE LAWS
ARE FOLLOWED BY ALL CITIES AND
IT SHOULD JUST BE SOME CITIES-
THE ONE QUESTION I HAVE FOR
FOLLOW UP FOR. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS- IT'S ONE
THING TO FOLLOW- HOUSING LAWS
AROUND PRODUCTION BUT AS WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT WITH AN
EARLIER ITEM SO MANY CITIES ARE
REALLY STRUGGLING WHEN IT COMES
TO HOMELESSNESS AND ADDRESSING-
WHETHER WE'RE BUILDING THE
NAVIGATION CENTERS AND SHELTERS
INTO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. AND I DID HAVE A
CHANCE TO TAKE A QUICK LOOK AT
THIS BUT I DON'T REALLY HAVE A
SENSE THAT THERE IS MUCH. THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL RATE CD
CAN LOOK AT WHEN IT COMES TO
REQUIRING JURISDICTIONS TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE TYPES
OF SHELTERS THAT ARE NECESSARY
FOR OUR HOMELESS POPULATIONS
COULD YOU. SHED A LITTLE I KNOW
AND I WOULD I'D LOVE TO RESPOND
TO THAT. YEAH AND THE QUIET
PART. AND THAT'S GOOD QUESTION.
YEAH THAT- THAT THAT BAY AREAS
OF ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY THAT
EIGHTY SEVENTY TO PROVIDE A
TASTY BE INCLUDED ALL HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW- BUT ALSO HAVING
HAD ABILITY ACT AND LAND USE
DISCRIMINATION. I THINK AND I
MENTIONED IT ONCE BEFORE I
THINK A LOT OF CASES INVOLVED.
AS LOOKING AT THAT- THE WHOLE
SET OF HOUSING LAWS. AND BUT I
THINK HOMELESSNESS OFTEN FALLS
INTO ONE OF THOSE THREE
CATEGORIES- SO UNDER HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW THERE ARE A LOT OF
OBLIGATION JURISDICTION HAVE TO
BE DOING IN TERMS THAT. ARE
MAKING IT EASIER TO BUILD
HOUSING PARTICULARLY AND FOR
HOME WITHIN THAT THAT CAN AND
HELP ALLEVIATE OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS- AND IN PROVIDING-
EMERGENCY SHELTER- BY RIGHT AND
OTHER OTHER THINGS INTEL. AND
UNDER HOUSING ELEMENT LAW THAT
WE HAVE THAT A LOT AT A LOT
AND- PURVIEW THERE. AND AS WELL
AS UNDER HOUSING CAN ABILITY
ACT AND EVERYTHING THAT THE BIG
PLACE WHERE WE SEE A LOT OF THE
AMOUNT IS AND THE DESIRE TO- TO
PAY NOW AND JUST A REMINDER
THAT WE HAVE AN ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT AS PROVIDE A LOT OF
PROTECTION. AND IF HOUSING IS
GOING TO BE AFFORDABLE AND
AVAILABLE TO. AND ADD TO LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND- HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THAT. WELL I
I'M I'M REALLY GLAD TO HEAR
THAT IN AGAIN IS WHY IT'S A PO
FOR THEIR TO BE. AND FOR OF THE
LAWS IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR THESE
LAWS O JUST BE ON THE BOOKS
BUT- IF CITIES I MEAN WE KNOW.
ARE ALL I THINK MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN LOCAL OFFICIALS AND IT'S
OFTEN WHEN YOUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE SAYING NO TO A PROJECT-
IT'S EASIER LOCAL OFFICIAL TO
TURN A BLIND EYE. AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO
JUST REMIND EVERYONE OF THE
OBLIGATION WE ALL HAVE TO
FOLLOW- THESE HOUSING ELEMENT
LAWS AND THEN THE OTHER THING
I'LL SAY IS. TYPICALLY THE WAY
THAT- SAY THE HOUSING ELEMENT
THAT THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT IS ENFORCED AS BY SOMEONE
WHO WANTS TO BUILD THIS
HOUSING. WHICH PUTS THEM IN A
VERY AWKWARD SITUATION VIS A
VIS A CITY OUR PLANNING
DEPARTMENT OR CENTER
NEIGHBORHOODS OR A LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL AND TO HAVE. A TO HAVE
A STABLE. THE NEW GENERAL- ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE IF-
IF LAWS ARE BEING VIOLATED
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE SO I'M
JUST GONNA CHIME IN AND- AND
PROVIDE- YOU KNOW REALLY THAT
THAT COUNTERBALANCE TO WHY I
THINK THIS IS SUPPORT.
ACTIVISTS A MANAGER. THANK YOU
MISTER Q. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR ONE TIME ALLOCATION
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE-
MISTER- SUGGS MR CHRISTMAS
MARLYS LET'S BEGIN. MICEX.
MEMBERS OF THE MIDDLEMAN TWENTY
FIVE HIGH- JUST SOUND REALLY
FAR AWAY. LET'S START OVER IF I
CAN HAVE YOU COME FROM ONE TO
FIVE PLEASE COME WILL TEST YOUR
MIKE. NO NOT NOT WORKING IT'S-
WE CAN'T HEAR YOU AT ALL LET'S
SOUND VERY FAR AWAY CAN WE
INCREASE OUR VOLUME ON HER
COMPUTER. METHODS CAN I HAVE
YOU CAN AGAIN FROM ONE TO FIVE.
ONE FOUR FIVE NO NOT NOT
WORKING I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE A- I HAD SAID TO HER IF
YOU COULD JUST SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO YOUR COMPUTER. USING A
COMPUTER AUDIO OR LAPTOP AUDIO.
ZERO WE GET A IDEA TECH EARLIER
NEVER WORKS FINE- IS THIS
FEDERAL- YES IF YOU CAN JUST
PROJECT A LITTLE BIT MORE THAT
BE GREAT. BUT I AM AT I MEAN
THAT'S WHAT EXPECT. AND THE
BRANCH OF OUR ASSET MANAGEMENT
AND COMPLIANCE AT THE NO YOU
DON'T YOU SOUND- YOU SOUND VERY
LIKE. DAR WITHOUT A WORD
CHARBEL. ONE OKAY- WANT ONE
MOMENT ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YEAH
OKAY ARE YOU LET ME ASK THE
QUESTION ARE YOU ON YOUR PHONE
AND ON VIDEO WITH YOUR LAPTOP.
JUST ON PHONE. OKAY LET'S TRY
THAT AGAIN ATTILA IT SEEMS TO
BE WORKING LET'S LET'S START
OVER GO AHEAD. IT MAY COUNT
FIVE AGAIN. LOOKSLIKE YOU'RE
FINE SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE FINE
THAT'S ANTENNAE. NO WORRIES
OKAY. SO AGAIN MY NAME IS LINDA
SUGGS FRANCE YOU FOR ASSET
MANAGEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
BRANCH EIGHT C. D. M. AC IS
REQUESTING A GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFICIENCIES
AT. OUR OFFICE OF MIGRANT
SERVICES HOUSING SENSORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S. AN
EIGHT CITY ADMINISTERS OFFICE
IMMIGRANT SERVICES PROGRAM THE
ALMOST PROGRAM WHICH OPERATES
TWENTY FOUR MIGRANTS CENTERS
WITH- ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE HOUSING
UNITS AND PROVIDES HOUSING
RELATED SERVICES TO MORE THAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND MIGRANTS
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
EACH YEAR. HISTORICALLY
RESOURCES FOR REPAIRS
MAINTENANCE HAVE BEEN FROM ONE
TIME FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AND
THE CENTER OPERATED BY JUST
CONSIST OF STATE GENERAL FUND
SUBSIDY AND RENTAL INCOME BUT
SAID NEITHER HAVE BEEN
INCREASED AND OVER A DOZEN
YEARS AND ARE NOT SUFFICIENT.
FUNDS THESE CRITICAL REPAIRS
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
MANY OF THE- MESSENGERS ARE NOW
OLD AND THERE'S SIGNIFICANT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND RE
HAVE NEEDS THAT CREATE A HEALTH
AND SAFETY CONCERNS FOR THE
TENANTS RESIDING THAT ARE
CENTERS- THAT THESE REPAIRS
CONTINUED TO GO AND- ADDRESS.
THE CENTERS WERE FURTHER
DETERIORATE AND MAY RESULT IN
AN CENTER CLOSURES AND THE
DISPLACEMENT OF. MIGRANT
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE HAS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT A CAN- CAN I SAY THAT
I JUST REALLY ALSO APPRECIATE
YOU PROVIDING B. INFORMATION ON
THE COUNTIES THAT ARE BEING
SERVICE THROUGH THE ALL- MASS
MIGRANT FAMILY HOUSING CENTER
SANTA CLARA SAN JOAQUIN KERN
MERCED SANTA CRUZ YOLO
STANISLAUS AND GOES ON AND ON.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DATA
LET'S HEAR- FROM MR CHRIS IN
MISS MORALIS. CRUZ DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS THANK YOU. MISS
MORALIS. LMAO WELL THE PROPOSAL
I FINANCIAL PROJECTS. FULLER
ONLY COVER A PORTION OF THE
BILL AND I'M SORRY THAT IT TOOK
FOR ME IN FACT COMING BACK ON.
YOU QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE-
WILL A SPECIFIC PROJECT AND
WHAT OPPORTUNITY THERE WILL BE
TO BACK THE LEGISLATURE TIERNEY
AND MARKET OUTLOOK BUT THE
OUTSTANDING. I WOULDN'T BE HERE
AND IN ADDITION WE ALSO HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LONG TERM PLAN
IS TO ENSURE THAT THE BACK OF
BUT IT'S FULLY ADDRESSED. AND
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES TO
PREVENT. A GROWTH IN. IN MAY
ISSUES- YOUR CENTERS THANK YOU.
OKAY I AM SO YES YOU'RE CORRECT
WE DID IDENTIFY AN ESTIMATED
FIFTEEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS INCLUDED THAT AS AN
ATTACHMENT TO THIS REQUEST-
NOTING THAT THESE ARE YOU KNOW
THE MOST RECENT ESTIMATES FOR
THE MOST KRYPTONIANS AMBIENCE
INSPIRED. HIS MOST CRITICAL
LIFE SAFETY PROJECTS- LIKE
SEWER WASTE READABILITY
PROJECTS WHICH AND POTENTIAL
CUT AFFECT THE HEALTH RESIDENTS
AND ALSO SOME OF COSTA PROJECTS
FIRST WHICH THEY WE BE ON MY TO
GET WHAT AN OPERATING OR IS
FUND. SO WE BUILT AT CAN ROUTE
REPAIRS CITING- OTHER THAT WE'D
BE LOOKING TO TAKE CARE OF
WOULD BE- ACT EDA- REMEDIATION
PROJECTS. AS WELL AS- ANY OTHER
URGENT NEEDS THAT TEND TO POP
UP AS AS THINGS TEND TO- BUT
THE- MASS PROGRAM SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE STORM EARLIER THIS
WINTER BLEW OFF TO COUPLE THE
ROUTES THAT ONE OF OUR MIKE AND
CENTERS AND SIX AND- SO OF A
SUDDEN THOUGHT. THAT RIGHT IT'S
NOT GONNA BE HIGHER ON THAT
PURSUE LAST- AS FAR AS YOU KNOW
HOW WE WOULD PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
ENDS REPORT BACK ON THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
YOU EIGHT ZERO DEGREES TO
PROVIDE- IN REPORTS. DETAILING
WHICH PROJECTS- ARE UNDER
CONTRACT HAVE BEEN COMPLETED-
AND THE AMOUNTS OF FUNDS
REMAINING ENCUMBERED EXPEND
THAT. I'M OUT OF THIS. THE SAM
CLANS. I IN TURN OF A SEEN I'M
GOING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG AND PREVENTING THE
ACCUMULATION OF SYSTEM OF
BACKLOG AND THAT'S A REALLY
INTERESTING QUESTION NUMBER
STILL HONESTLY THINKING THAT
THROUGH. I MEAN AB YOU KNOW
CURRENTLY AS I MENTIONED.
BEFORE IT C. RECEIVES AN ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION OF FIVE POINT SIX
NINE MILLION DOLLARS AND JOYFUL
FUND IN GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
PROGRAM AND- THAT SUBSIDY IS
SUPPLEMENTED WITH RENTAL
REVENUES- FOR THE PROJECTS BUT
SINCE BOTH HAVE BEEN STAGNANT
OVER AND MANY YEARS AND WITH-
WITH- YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM
FURTHER EXACERBATED WITH NEW
LEGISLATION TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHICH ALLOWS INSPIRED CENTERS
TO STAY OPEN FOR A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME UP TO TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE DAYS. KERN
COUNTY YEAR INSTEAD OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS PER
CALENDAR YEAR THE WEAR AND TEAR
AND THE CENTERS AS FOR THE
CONTRIBUTED TO INCREASED
pNEEDS SO WHAT WE RE LOOKING AT
DOING IN THE FUTURE- EXPLORE
OTHER FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES-
YOU KNOW. PERHAPS AT SB TWO
WHICH PROVIDES A DEDICATED
ONGOING REVENUE SOURCE FOR
HOUSING. I INCLUDING THE EXAM
FOR SENATE AGRICULTURE WERE
BROUGHT A HOUSING AND RENTAL
AND SET ASIDE. LOOK AT THE
POSSIBILITY PERHAPS USING SOME
OF THAT WAS TO ASSIST WITH THE
M. DEPARTMENTS BACKLOG. AND SAM
WE WILL ALSO REFER. A RINSING.
AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE OF
THE RIGHT NOW I'M- JUST EVEN IF
YOU WERE RENTS ARE OUT RENTS
RANGE FROM TWELVE TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS A DAY AT MOST THE
SENSORS WHICH- ENDS UP BEING
AROUND FOR IN A FIFTY DOLLARS A
MONTH. AND THAT'S INCLUSIVE OF
UTILITIES SO GRINS INCREASES
YOU KNOW WOULD HAVE TO BE- IT
WOULD TAKE US AWHILE TO GET
RENTS UP TO. A LEVEL TO WHERE
THEY WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL IN
ADDRESSING. AT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SIX AM. AND AT THE
REPAIR MEANS. SO- YOU KNOW I
CAN SAVE. AC IS CURRENTLY
REVIEWING OUR REVENUE BUDGETS
INVOLVED IN ONGOING PLAN. TO
JUST AS LONG TERM DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS- AND ANY
REQUESTS FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- WOULD BE MADE
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. THANK YOU MISS SUGGS-
JUST A FOLLOW UP. QUESTION TO
THAT SO YOU ARE REQUESTING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE NEEDS BUT WHAT IS THE
TOTAL NEED TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS-
EVERYTHING THAT'S NEEDED TO THE
TWENTY FOUR MARGARET CENTERS.
THAT AMOUNTS OPERATE SAY I
HEARD YOU SAID THAT THERE'S
CURRENTLY A PLAN OR SOME KIND
OF- WAY THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT BY WHEN WILL
YOU KNOW. SO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE HIRED A CONSULTANT TO GO TO
PHYSICAL NEEDS ASSESSMENT AT
ALL TWENTY FOUR CENTERS AND-
BASED ON THAT INFORMATION.
MA'AM WE'VE COME UP WITH THIS
LIST THE NEED- ACCORDING TO
THOSE REPORTS THERE WERE- PUTS
ME TEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OF PROJECTS THAT. HAS
ALREADY LAPSED AND THE SEVERITY
OF THESE REPAIRS CONTINUES TO
INCREASE- I MEAN AND THE OTHER
THINGS YOU AS YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE ENFORCED USE LIMITED
PROGRAM FUNDS SECOND ACTS
PATCHWORK I'M FEELING SYSTEMS
WELL THESE UNDERLYING PROBLEMS
ARE NOT BEING RESOLVED- SO. THE
PROBLEM KEEPS MOUNTING
OVERTIME- IN THE AGGREGATE I
BELIEVE THE PNA IS IDENTIFIED
ROUGHLY SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF CRITICAL REPAIRS AND
MAINTENANCE NEEDS THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED WITHIN. A FIVE
YEAR TIME FRAME AND THEN IT
ALSO PRODUCES SCHEDULED BY
RECOMMENDED SCHEDULE AS AM I AM
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- EXPENSES
OVER THE NEXT YOU KNOW AT
FIFTEEN YEARS SO WE BE TAKING A
LOOK AT THE INFORMATION AND
THOSE. PNA REPORTS TAKING A
LOOK AT OUR ARE PROJECTED
REVENUES AND TRYING TO COME UP
WITH A PLAN AND A SYSTEM OF ON
GOING REGULAR MAINTENANCE. GOT
IT OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT. IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE CAN MOVE ON TO-
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE FOR THE
INFORMATION MICEX. ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE IS RELATED TO HOUSING ON
EXCESS PLANTS WE HAVE MISSED
HER COULD BE MISTER CHRISTMAS
MORALES MISTER COULD BE PLEASE-
THESE COMMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND AGAIN IT'S MAKING HER
COULD BE THAT THE ACTOR FOR
HOUSING POLICY FROM ATV AND-
DAY EXCEPT BY PROGRAM HAS BEEN
AND GOING VIA THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER FOR SOME TIME NOW AND
DECIDED TRAILER BILL AMENDMENTS
ARE ENGAGED ARE- EASIEST ON OUR
LESSONS LEARNED FROM OPERATING
THAT PROGRAM AND IN ADDING IN A
LITTLE FLEXIBILITY THAT WE CAN
CALL UP AND RUN THE PROGRAM.
MORE EFFICIENTLY AFFECT AND
EFFECTIVELY. MR CHRIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON DINNER CRUISE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO KNOW THAT THIS
TRAILER BILL IS REALLY- CAN
HELP KEEP THE MOMENTUM GOING ON
BUILDING UP THE HOUSING STOCK
UNDERSTOOD ACCESS LANDS WITH
THE INTENT TO MAXIMIZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I THINK YOU
HAVE ANSWERED QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MR MARLES. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT ON THE- I THINK YOU.
OKAY I ACTUALLY HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS HERE- MISTER COULD
BEAT THIS EXPENSE LINES PROGRAM
ACCESS LANDS PROGRAM WAS
CREATED THROUGH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER WISE OR NEED TO CODIFY
THIS PROGRAM NOW. WHERE THERE
IS EXISTING STATUTE- THAT THAT
THE COURT THIS PROGRAM AND SAID
THERE THAT COMPLEMENT THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER- AND THE- THIS
THIS PARTICULAR- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND I APOLOGIZE THAT
MY NOTES FOR A SECOND AND THIS
THIS PARTICULAR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PUBLIC VIEW- THREE
PARTICULAR THING. AND ADDING
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT- WHEN
THAT'S NECESSARY FOR THAT BUT
THAT WILL DELIVERY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IT MAKES
THEM AND CHANGES THAT WE THINK
WILL END UP WITH ALLOWING US TO
HAVE A GREATER AFFORDABILITY
LEVEL IN THE PROGRAM- AND THEN-
ALLOWING PHASE DEVELOPMENT-
WHICH WE'VE BEGUN TO FEAR
SOMETIMES NECESSARY FOR HER-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
YEAH. AND THEY SAID THEY'VE
BEEN THIS IS CHANGING LANGUAGE
THAT EXISTS NOW THAT IN.
COMPLEMENT TO THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
WANT TO PASS IT OVER TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OTHER
ANY. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. MR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. YEP I'M
GOOD OKAY GREAT OKAY WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE CAN MOVE ON
TO- ISSUE NUMBER SIX THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISS KIRBY LEADS THE
CONTINUE THIS THESE ARE ISSUE
NUMBER SIX IS RELATED TO OTHER
HDD BUDGET PROPOSALS MR- SEGER
MISTER ON STATE AND MR CRUISE
AND MISS MORALIS LET'S BEGIN.
MESSINGER. IN THE FIRST ROUND
HERE TO SUMMARIZE- JENNIFER CAN
BE HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT MAY ARISE- THERE ARE TWO
PROPOSALS IN THIS ITEM THE
FIRST IS BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO EXTEND LIQUIDATION DATE FOR
THE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM OF TWENTY NINETEEN. ON
A CASE BY CASE BASIS. THIRTY A
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TIME FOR
GRANTEES IMPACTED BY CODE
NINETEEN RELATED DELAYS TO
COMPLETE CONSTRUCTION OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS PROJECT
RELATED- TO INSPECTING FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND THE
SECOND IS A REQUEST FOR TWO
MILLION NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND GENERAL FUND
ELEVEN POINT FIVE POSITIONS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. ONE
MILLION SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND NINE
POSITIONS IN. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND ONE POSITION IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
ON GOING TO IMPLEMENT HOUSING
LAWS PASSED. THE TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. JENNIFER
HAPPY AFTER QUESTION YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THE OF
FINANCE PLEASE. THE DINNER
CRUISE THE OF FINANCE THAT
WOULD JUST LIKE TO KNOW THE- I
PORT OF THIS. IT'S REALLY
CONTINUE TO MEASURE THE WHOLE
MAXIMIZE THE INVESTMENT IN THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BUDGET
OTHERWISE IT COULD RESULT IN
OUR VERSION OF FUNDS AND
THEREFORE- PROJECT POTENTIALLY
FALLING THROUGH AND THEN
REDUCING. OTHER POTENTIAL
HOUSING STOCK AND IN REGARDS TO
THE EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR
LEGISLATIVE WORKLOADS PROVIDES
RESOURCES TO HELP YOU SEE THE
STREAMLINED- AS REQUIRED BY LAW
THERE HOUSING PROGRAMS UNDER
DELIVER- HOUSING FINANCING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK LOL.
YOUR THE- IF YOU FROM OUR
RELATED TO THE IRAQI LIQUIDATE
X. IT'S MOSTLY ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE DATA
MENTION BY THE ADMINISTRATION
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE OVERALL
EFFECT ON CLIENT PROJECTS AND
PUSH THAT OUT IT WOULD MEAN
ABOUT THE CAPACITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TAKE ON PROJECTS WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
WORKLOAD THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
OKAY TO ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
OUR PRODUCTS. NO SANE MAN JUST
ONE QUESTION FOR ME AS. FOR THE
LIQUID ACTION THE LIQUIDATION
PERIOD EXTENSIONS DOES H. C. D.
HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY
PROJECTS WOULD NEED TO BE
REVIEWED ON A CASE BY CASE.
BASIS YEAH WE'VE- REACHED OUT
TO THE AWARDEES AT THOSE FANS
WE HAD ABOUT SIXTY ONE AWARDEES
AND TOTAL AND IT APPEARS THAT
ABOUT THIRTEEN OF THOSE SIXTY
ONE HAVE INDICATED THAT THEY
MAY. HAVE A NEED TO REQUEST AN
EXTENSION IT'S REALLY A MIX OF
BOTH LARGE JURISDICTIONS AND
SMALL JURISDICTIONS AND
IMPACTS- VARIOUS AREAS OF THE
STATE. GOT IT THANK YOU FOR
THAT IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL. YES I'M HERE I ALSO
HAVE INFORMATION ON THE AYE AYE
G. ITEM THAT YOU REQUESTED
EARLIER IF YOU'D LIKE ME TO
PROVIDE THAT DATA AT THIS POINT
WHERE WE CAN SEND IT OVER. I'M
SEPARATE STATE. ACTUALLY THAT
BE GREAT LET'S GO BACK TO WHAT-
WHAT ISSUE IS THAT- I BELIEVE
ISSUE TO. YOU ARE CORRECT ISSUE.
TWO THERE WAS ONE QUESTION ON
THE COMPARISON BETWEEN THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND PROP ONE
SEED PER UNIT INVESTMENT AND-
THE CALCULATION WAS CORRECT IT
WAS JUST ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
BUT ACTUALLY ABOUT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PER UNIT FOR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FUNDING. AND
THEN FOR PROP ONE SEE IT WAS-
ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND PER
UNIT- AND PROP ONE C. WAS
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SO- I
THINK IT'S KIND OF A AT A
REASONABLE- INCREASE IN THE
EXPENSES- BASED ON THE TIME
FRAME IN WHICH THOSE AWARDS
WERE MADE. AND TO YOUR QUESTION
ON THE REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION OF
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FUNDS
JUST ONE NOTE THAT WE DID MAKE
ALL FUNDS AVAILABLE TO THE
SMALL JURISDICTIONS SO WHILE
ONLY APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THE
FUNDS FOR THE LARGE
JURISDICTIONS- WERE MADE WE DID
ALLOCATE- ALL OF THE SMALL
JURISDICTION FUNDS WHICH
REPRESENTED ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT. OF TOTAL FUNDS- FOR
THE BREAKDOWN OF THE LARGE
JURISDICTIONS WE HAD ABOUT 45%
OF THOSE AWARDS COACH YOU-
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
APPROXIMATELY 53% OF THOSE
AWARDS TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND 2% TO CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
AND FOR THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
AREA WE WERE UNDER SUBSCRIBED
TO THE- THAT 2% REPRESENTS- ALL
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS THAT WERE
FUNDED. THERE WERE A COUPLE
JURISDICTIONS THAT CAME IN
UNDER THE SMALL JURISDICTION
POTS WHICH WERE LOCATED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND AREA. BUT
ONLY LIKE ONE OR TWO. EXCELLENT
AT YOU FOR THAT UPDATE AND IF I
MAY ASK CAN YOU PLEASE SEND
THAT OVER TO THE BUDGET STAFF
SO THAT WE CAN I WOULDN'T WANT
TO GET THOSE NUMBERS CONFUSED.
SO IF YOU CAN SEND THAT OVER
THAT BE REALLY HELPFUL THANK
YOU CAN APPRECIATE YOU AND YOUR
TEAM FOR GETTING THAT
INFORMATION SO QUICKLY. PROBLEM
OKAY I THINK WE CAN MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCIAL COUNCILS THIS IS A
OVERVIEW OF THE HTF H. CFCS
PROGRAMS I WILL START WITH THE
WE HAVE OUR PANELISTS TODAY
INCLUDE MS SUTTON- MISTER HILL
AND MISS MORALIS LET'S BEGIN
MISS SUDDEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
NO YOU SOUND VERY FAR AWAY. IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ONE TO FIVE A
LITTLE LOUDER WE CAN ADJUST
YOUR MIKE. I THINK. I CAN GET
WELL I. NOT HAVING YOU WEALTHY
MY FAITH. AGAIN CAMERA ARE YOU
ARE YOU. ON THE YOU SOME MUCH
MUCH BETTER I WOULD ASK YOU YOU
CAN PLEASE PROJECT YOUR VOICE
BECAUSE IT MAY BE YOUR ROOM IT
SOUNDS A LITTLE AT COOLEY. SO
OKAY YEAH THANK YOU LET'S BEGIN.
EVEN IF YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE
HEARING ME THE FUNNY NOW OKAY-
BUT GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ALEX AND I'M GOING TO
DEFINITELY SECRETARY FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES THAT HOUSING
AGENCY I'M IN MY ROLE I DIRECT
THE EFFORTS OF THE HOMELESS FOR
NEEDING IN FINANCING COUNCIL I
WAS JUST READING COORDINATED
ENTITY OR HOME OF THE POLICY
AND AN ADMINISTRATOR AT OVER.
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN SPENDING WHICH WE ALLOCATE
TELL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CONTINUE
IN THE CARES ACTIVITIES AND
COUNTIES SO GRATEFUL TO BE HERE
AT THIS SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN UP TO I'M
HERE OVER THE LAST YEAR. AND HE
WILL NOW WE REALLY DO SERVICE
THE INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS I WILL PROVIDE
YOUR SHIP COORDINATION AND
GUIDANCE THAT TO REALLY
STRENGTHEN AN ONLINE ONLY THINK
MANY TRAFFIC ACROSS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT HI WE ARE CREATED AS
YOUR IDENTIFIED THE TWENTY
SEVENTH FLOOR IN PART TO
OVERSEE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
HOUSING FIRST POLICIES ACROSS
ALL STATE FUNDED PURPOSE
PROGRAMS. WE BELIEVE YOU
BELIEVE HCFC THAT'S PREVENTING
IT FROM ENDING HOMELESS I THINK
CALIFORNIA REALLY REQUIRES THE
MAIN THING THAT WE'VE OUTLINED
IN IN OUR UPCOMING ACTION
SANDWICHES INCREASE LEADERSHIP
FROM THE STATE I WRITE AYE
FINANCE WRITING BOTH SHORT AND
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS REALLY
COUPLE ACTION ORIENTED
COORDINATION ALIGNMENT ACROSS
AGENCIES PROGRAM. AND SUMMER
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PARTNERS AT. THE FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL. I THIRTY
DISHES YOU ACTUALLY. AND I'M
WITH STATE OR- THE ALSO IN
MINUTES THREE CREATE. WHICH I
LOVE A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
HERE IN JUST A MINUTE. BUT THE
ACTUAL PLAN THE PAST MONEY I.
HAD DEVELOPED HARPER EVER.
STATEWIDE ACT PLAN THAT EVEN
FAST FIRST WILL PURSUE A VISION
THE ACCOUNT ON THE DAY WORK.
AND HOMELESSNESS- ACTUAL PLAN
BETTER FIVE MAJOR MAJOR ACT
HEARING. I'M TALKING ABOUT.
CALTRAIN PERMANENT HOUSING
PROVIDE AND SYSTEMS. AND UNDER
EACH ABOUT ACTION AREAS THERE
ARE. OF BUT I NEARLY ACT. THAT
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE COMMITTED TO A COMP. WHAT
IT FRAME AND PERFORMANCE MY
CHANGE HOLDING OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE YOU ARE WORK MOVING.
WITH EACH YEAR HE'S GOT. CALL
SO A GREAT NEW I ACTUALLY WE TO
BE VOTED ON AT THIS MONTH FROM
MEETING ON TWENTY. THE DISTANCE
WEEKS. OUT OF THE OTHER. MY
FRESHMAN GETTING THAT. INITIAL
EDITION TO THAT STATE RIGHT NOW
PLAN AND WE- BY DEVELOPED A
REALLY I REALLY. PART OF OUR
STATE MY COURTNEY WORK WHICH IS
THE OF THE DAY AND A GREAT
SYSTEM OR H. D. I. AND WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THAT AT ALL.
OF H. GROUNDBREAKING. EIGHT
MOST OF BECAUSE IT WILL HAVE
OUR TO MAKE A THAT FORMER OUT
THE THAT'S THE- A OUR STATE.
APPROACH TO AND HOMELESS- BUT
WILL ALSO TAKE OUR WORK THE
STATE. HERE WE WILL YOU SEE IF
YOU. THE EACH THE ACT THE THIRD
PART DATA COMPACT BUILDING. AND
OVERLY APPROVAL THE DATA THE
QUALITY OF THE THAT WERE
COLLECTING. ALL THE PROMOTE.
AND J. STAND UP I'M ACROSS THE-
AND- WHAT WE'RE ALL HERE FOR
IMPROVE LOCAL. TO ANY. FIVE
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR BY. PROGRAM ALLOCATED TO
EACH OF THE STATE CONTINUES
THAT CAROLINE IN THE- LARGEST
FAITH. I'M WE ALSO ADMINISTER
THAT HOME WITH HAVING A-
PREVENTION PROGRAM OUT OF CAP.
WHICH IS A NEW. PROGRAM
TOTALING NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE IN TWO ROUNDS.
I'M TEACHER TO TAKE YOUR SEATS
COUNTY AND THIRTEEN MARKET
STUDY. BASED YES THEY RECENTLY
PUBLISHED A SUMMARY REPORT- OF
ALL OF THE IN REPORTS COLLECTED
FROM YOU CAN HAVE CREATE HEAT.
WHICH IS AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE. JUST A COUPLE KEEPING
THEY WANNA CALL OUT IN TERMS OF
DATA. I'M THAT THAT REPORT
HIGHLIGHT THOUGH OVER THE
COURSE OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
YEARS I HAVE GREAT HE'S ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE SOARED OVER
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE. I'M
SPENDING TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
ALLOCATIONS. ARE I NEARLY 25%
OF THOSE SURVEYED IDENTIFIED
ITS PRODUCT ONLY. ABOUT 9% WERE
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH. ABOUT 5%
FOR VETERANS. AND ALMOST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE WITHIN
THAT GROUP. AND I DID INTO
PERMANENT. HOUSING I THINK. THE
DAY ALSO ENTERED ALL THE DOES
THE FIRST FIVE MY- ROUND ONE.
AND GAVE THE THAT SHORT TERM
FRAME. BACKGROUND HE'S ABOUT
SIR NEARLY HAS PEOPLE. OBLIGATE
IF I'M HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
MILLION IN A- THE ONE DOLLARS.
MOST OF THOSE EXPENDITURES 92%
HAPPENED OUR NEVER CENTERS- ARE
WORKING WITH EACH OTHER AND- WE
EXPECT YOU TO CALL- I. THINK HE
THOUGHT THAT WE SEEING HAVE
DIFFERENT FROM YOU CAN HAVE 1%
THOSE ARE IN- ARE I GUESS IT
KIND OF THE HOME P THE THAT
YOU YEAH. IF OR INCREASE FROM
OVERSEEING HE AND ABOUT
INTEREST- ARE ON I CAN BE YOU
ABOUT. SO A LOT OF THE THERE-
ALL OF THE ON. IRAQ THEY IN THE
IN. BUT I ALSO NEEDED FOR TO
CALL OUT THE MORE FUN. PIECES
OF DATA THAT WE ARE A REAL
CROWDED H. YEAH. ADAM WHICH
THAT'S WHAT YOU OTHER THAT
AROUND KEEPING. HE AND TAKE
REALLY CONCRETE- IN THE PURSUIT
OF A EQUITY WITHIN THEIR-
RESPONSE SYSTEM. THAT WE ARE
SEEING THAT MANY GREAT HE ENTER
INTO I THINK. THEY HAVE TO
REMAIN DIFFERENT IMPACT. I'M
MANY ARE COUNTRY ENTERING
AMPLIFIER THE VOICE OF BLACK
AND DID YOU JUST SEE OF COLOR.
AND THOSE WHO LIVING OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THEIR AND THEIR
MAKING PROCESS BE I REALLY
MAKING POP CHANGES BETTER.
DIFFERENT IMPACT ME. SO I'M
HARDLY EVER OFFICE AND VERY
QUALITY DATA THAT WERE BY. IN
FEEL IT IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF
SOLVING PROBLEM. WITH THAT I
OTHER OTHER BOARD AT THE END.
COMMENTS RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS. COMMITTEE WELL
KNOWS THE SCALE OF THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S SIGNIFICANT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAPPENS YOU
INTEREST. IN INCREASING THE
STATE'S ROLE IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS THE STATE ACT VERY
QUICKLY TO ESTABLISH NEW
PROGRAMS AND EXPAND EXISTING
PROGRAMS USING WHAT KIND
RESOURCES. DURING THE PAST TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASED RISK. TO
THE HOMELESS POPULATION DURING
THIS TIME. AND WHEN THE
GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET OR THE CA TO
HOME AND THE AFFORDABILITY. BY
PROPOSED AND TO SIX RESOURCES A
ONE TIME BASIS. IN THE PAST THE
BILL TIME TO RESOURCE TO MAKE
IT DIFFICULT TO ADDRESS. THE
ONGOING CHALLENGE RELATED
HOMELESSNESS AND HOW FOR. I'M
ALSO SEVEN IF YOU THINK THAT
THERE IS ROOM TO PROVIDE A
CLEAR SHOULD A LONG TERM STE WE-
THAT THE COUNCIL WORKING THAT
THREE. THE PLANET THAT THE
CRIED. ON. IT WILL DRAW. LOOK
FORWARD TO COULD. TO ENGAGE IN
THIS. MEN OF BUDGET MR TANG WAS
IN THE ROOM BUT HE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO STEP OUT
TO TAKE A CALL BUT HE DID ASK
THAT I ASK A QUESTION ON HIS-
THEY HAVE BEHALF. SO FOR- FOR
THE HAP. ROUND ONE IT LOOKS
LIKE HOW NEEDS ARE TAKING
LONGER TO GET THEIR DOLLARS OUT
RELATED TO FIGURE TWENTY. DO
YOU KNOW OF ANY BARRIERS THAT
COUNTIES ARE FACING DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT COUNTIES WILL
GET THEIR DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR
BY THE STATUTORY DEADLINE. YES
I DO BELIEVE THAT WOULD THAT
WERE WORKING ACTUALLY. CAN'T
INCREASES AND ON BOTH. WOOD
COUNTY CITY THERE VIA THE AND
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW KEEP
WITH ALLOCATED COMPARED TO HOW
HOW HAPPENS AND BAND- IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT SORT OF THE
SPENDING DATE HER FOR HALF WE
ACTUALLY THINK THAT THE FUNDS
WILL LIKELY BE IF THEY SAY THAT
AT THE CURRENT RATE THAT THEY
WILL ACTUALLY BE BACK WELL IN
ADVANCE OF THAT FIVE YEAR MARK.
AND WE CAN BE THINKING IF I
CAN'T LAUGH AND LEARN AND MAKE
SURE THE FUNDING HAPPENS MORE
QUICKLY OUT OF THE GYM TODAY
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY PRETTY
PRETTY SURPRISED AND IMPRESSED
WITH THE WAY THAT I COULD HAVE
GOTTEN HER FOR HALF A STARK.
YEAH ALONG WITH THE COMMUNITY
IT. YEAH EACH. AND A CERTAIN
ASKED YOU. A LITTLE. TO YOUR
MIKE. BECAUSE YOUR YOU ARE
FADING AWAY. AT THE END OF YOUR
OF YOUR SENTENCES. SO- CAN I
THINK I MAY HAVE MISSED IT BUT
THE YOU MENTION WHERE THE
BARRIERS TO USING THIS TYPE OF
FUNDING- AND WHAT ARE THE BEST
PRACTICES FOR BOTH PEOPLE AND
HELP IN TERMS OF THE
BARRIERS I WILL SAY CAN BE
WE'VE HEARD CONTINUALLY. THAT
FLEXIBILITY AROUND BOTH OF
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN REALLY
CRITICAL PARTICULARLY THIS YEAR
GIVING SOME VERY UNEXPECTED
NEED. I CAN I CAN GO YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT THAT SEEING. THAT
THE ACTUAL THERE ARE VERY FEW
VERY GOOD FOR THE PROGRAMMING
AND- REALLY VALUABLE AS PART OF
LIFESAVING I'M REASON THAT
SHOULD HAPPEN CREDIT CALL I
THINK THE ONE THING WE HAVE
BEEN HEARING ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING SOME TECHNICAL THE
BOND RIGHT NOW. IS JUST AROUND
CAPACITY BUILDING AND STAFFING-
THAT THERE HAD BEEN I'M JUST A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
COMING INTO THAT IN A COMMUNITY
THAT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN
PARTICULAR BUT ALSO WITH EIGHT
AS YOU ALL KNOW HOW. IT CAN
HELPING FOLKS THINK THROUGH I'M
JUST AFTER THE FACT AND
ACTUALLY BUILD THAT CAPACITY
FOR THIS KIND OF INCREASE IN
RECURSOS THAT HAPPENS ON THE
NETWORK REPEATING I CLOSE I AM.
RIGHT TO CATCH THAT LAST NIGHT
I YOU MENTIONED PRACTICE I'M
SORRY I MISSED AND CAN USE THE
YOU. KIND OF. I'M TO A LITTLE
AT THE END CAN YOU THAT LAW
SENTENCE. I'M WE'RE PROVIDING
HAVE BEEN OF THE AROUND HALF.
HE AND EVEN MENTIONED- BACK
PRACTICES MIGHT BE K. LOG IN
HERE ME OKAY. CALL YEAH YOU
KNOW I'D LET FOR A OF AND HAVE
YOU CALL IN BECAUSE YOUR YOUR
VOTE HE SAID TO IN AND OUT AND
SO GETTING OF WHAT YOU'RE-
PHILIP POTS FROM HOME- WELL YOU.
TECHNOLOGY. THE.
I DIDN'T. BOB
GOOD LUCK WITH. OKAY. YEAH
PROBABLY LOOKING. FOR I WOULD
HAVE A RESTRAINING ISSUE THAT
THE BETTER NOW. YEAH YEAH LAST
YEAR FOR A FEW MINUTES I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU CAN HEAR ME. I MEAN
CAN YOU JUST CONTINUE SPEAKING
AND WE CAN GO WHERE ARE YOU
CALLING IN OR IF IT'S YOUR LAST
NAME. AND I THINK I'M HAVING.
OF MY INNER ISSUES HOLIDAY
ABOUT THAT BUT I WAS I WAS GET
A DIVE INTO REAL QUICKLY AND
I'M SOME OF THE BEST PRACTICES
THAT WE NEED AND BEING ABLE I'M
FROM THE PROGRAM. QUICKLY MAKE
HER HOPEFULLY THE INTERNET HOLD
FOR ME. I WE HAVE THINKING I
WOULD SAY SOME REALLY EXCITING
FACT PARTICULARLY AROUND. SOME
OF THAT THE PARTNERSHIP IN
COORDINATION EFFORTS- WE'VE
BEEN THINKING I DON'T. FROM
CITY THE AND FROM FROM
CONVENIENCE CARE REALLY
THINKING THREE STRATEGICALLY
WHICH PIECES OF THE PUZZLE ARE
ARE BEST SERVED FOR EACH OF
THEM IS EVERYTHING FIGURATIONS
WHERE I THINK MIGHT BITE. OUT
OF THE NAVIGATION CENTER INSIDE
OF THE OPERATION BACK AND SEE
IF HE WILL TAKE ON THE ACTUAL
ONGOING OPERATION COSTS. I'M
REALLY THINKING THROUGH WHERE
EVERYONE'S SKILLS AND
CAPACITIES ARE PERSISTENT GREAT
I'M IN A JURISDICTIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS WE'RE ALSO SEEING
IT'S BETTER PARTNERSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP IN THESE COMMUNITIES
FROM FROM SOME OF OUR GREAT
HEAT. PARTNERING WITH PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES- LOCAL.
LOCAL CALIBRATION SEE THINGS BY
FAX IT REALLY THINK VALUABLE
AFTER. AND ENCOURAGE THAT TO
BEGIN- AND ALL JUST MAKE WE ARE
SEEING. SOME REALLY X. WORK AND.
NOT SURE IF YOU CAN HEAR ME YOU
TO CALL IN. WE CAN YOU FINE.
OKAY SORRY EVERYTHING. I THINK
IT CAST OUT OF A CALLING IT TO
START THAT SO I'M AND WE JUST A
MENTION ON IN THE HOMELESS
THANK SEEN THEM EXCITING- JUST
DEEPER BACK HOME INTO OF HOW
SERVICE AND THEN ENTER THAT ARE
PASSED DO YOU THINK THINKING OF
THE WHOLE OF ENTERED THEY NEED.
I REALLY UNDER THAT THAT THE
SERVICES NEED TO POPULOUS GIVEN
THAT THE U. BUT IF I FOR BOTH
OF THESE CONSTRAINTS ARE THINGS
THE RIGHT WORKING AND I WE'LL
WE'RE TRYING TO HI. THANK FOR
THAT I THINK BE R. WOULD BE
REALLY GREAT TACK GET THE FROM
YOU. AND ROY INTO OF SOME. THAT
BEEN SUCCESSFUL. SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO RE IN THE WHEEL.
I WE THINK OF NEW PER. AND
WHERE FUNDING. THIS LOCALS WERE
ALLOWED TO USE SOME OF THEIR HE
BEEN HAVE DOLLARS FOR PROJECT
ROOM KATE. AS PROJECT ROOM KEY
IS REIMBURSED WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE REIMBURSEMENT IS THERE A
REQUIREMENT THE LOCALS HAVE TO
PUT THESE DOLLARS BACK INTO HE
PERHAPS. HEY MATE MIGHT HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. INTO THAT QUESTION I
KNOW THEY'VE BEEN LOOKING. I
KRYSTLE COMPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
BROADLY SPEAKING WE HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING- LOCALS TO USE HE
GONNA HAPPEN MONIES FOR
PURPOSES THAT ARE NOT BEING
PERSONABLE. UNDER FEMA SO THAT
WAY WE'RE USING. OUR BEST
UTILIZING OUR RESOURCES NOT
SORT OF DOUBLING UP SO TO SPEAK
SO WE ARE ENCOURAGING THE USE.
EVEN HAPPENS FOR. NON FEMA
REIMBURSABLE PURPOSES BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT LOCALS MAYBE
USING SOME EVEN HAPPEN MONEY
FOR SOMETHING A REIMBURSABLE
PURPOSE I DO RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENTS. THEN WE ARE
ENCOURAGING THEM TO GO AHEAD
AND TO RE USE THAT MONEY FOR
THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH WAS
INITIALLY GIVEN WHICH WAS FOR
SERVING THE HOMELESSNESS
SUPPORT. FOR THOSE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS MISTER
LUCKY TO HAVE A QUESTION COMING
TO OKAY. YEAH I'M ONE OF THE
FOCUS ISSUES THAT I HAVE- DEEP
CONCERNS OVER AS FAR AS AS
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION OR THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE DRUG
ADDICTIVE OF FOLKS THAT I THINK
MAKE UP A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
THE PERCENTAGE OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION AND I WAS NOT ABLE
TO. SEE ANY PROBE. PROGRAMMATIC
INTERVENTIONS ALONG THOSE
FRONTS WITH THESE FUNDS IN MY
MISSING SOMETHING. CAN YOU TELL
ME ARE THERE ANY PROGRAMMATIC
INTERVENTIONS THAT ADDRESS
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS OR THESE
ADDICTIVE- CIRCUMSTANCES. YEAH
I THOUGHT THAT THE FUNDING FOR
BOTH KEEPING HALF ARE NATURALLY
QUITE FLEXIBLE THEY HAVE A RAID
AVAILABLE USE THAT COMMUNITIES
EXPECT A FUNDING ARE GIVEN
THEIR LOCAL NEEDS AND SO WE ARE
TRACKING THINGS I WILL MENTION
THAT THAT THAT THE RATES OF
PEOPLE BEING SERVED THAT ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. ON THE
DEFINITION OF CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS OFTEN INVOLVES HAVING
A DISABLING CONDITION OF BEING
HOMELESS FOR AT LEAST A YEAR SO
IS THAT THE FOLKS WE'RE SEEING
IN THAT POPULATION I'M OFTEN
MIGHT BE SOME OF THAT THAT THE
FOLKS YOU'RE REFERRING YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT THAT THAT
THE FUNDING IS INTENTIONALLY
QUITE FLEXIBLE AND SO WE ARE
SUPPORTING COMMUNITIES AND. ANY
ERA. WHAT ARE I APPRECIATE THE
OF. I'M I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT THE K. PIECE. AS TO
GETTING SOME KIND OF. THAT
THEIR- DIRECTED BY. TO FOR THE
FOR PROBLEMS AND YOU TALKED. OF
SOME NUMBERS OF PEOPLE BEING
HELPED BY THIS FUNDING. I
WONDER WHAT QUALIFIES AS HELP
AND HOW LONG AND SUSTAINED-
THESE IMPROVE CONDITIONS ARE.
SO IT REALLY VARIES AS WE KNOW
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE OUR HOMES FOR
VERY DIFFERENT REASONS ANY GARY
VERY DIFFERENT INTERVENTIONS TO
BE I THINK WE AND TABLE YOU
READ OUT SO THAT THE RANGE CAN
BE EVERYTHING FROM PREVENTION
DOLLARS WHICH CAN BE. VERY
SHORT TERM ASSISTANCE A
PERMANENT PART OF HAPPENING FOR
THE WE ARE ENCOURAGING
COMMUNITIES SURELY
INDIVIDUALIZED THAT THE LEVEL
OF INTENSITY IN SERVICES THAT
THAT. I'M PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THEIR COMMUNITY
ARE ARE ARE NEEDING INSTEAD OF
THE RANGE CAN BE QUITE QUITE
DRAMATIC- BASED ON THE BALLOT
FROM AND MAKE ME SO I WILL JUST
MENTION IN TERMS OF- WITH THAT
KIND OF INTERVENTION YOU'RE
SEEING THAT THE NUMBERS IN THE
ANNUAL REPORT. AROUND CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS- I'M JUST PULLING
HIM UP HERE REAL QUICKLY JUST
ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE-
IN HEAT WHO ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS I'VE BEEN CERTIFIED
THIS PROGRAM. I NEVER REPORTED
SEEING I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER
IN FRONT OF ME ABOUT HOW MANY
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE PART
OF THE THIRTEEN THOUSAND MORE
PERMANENTLY I DID A DIFFERENT
HOUSING BUT SERVICES CAN BE
EVERYTHING FROM STREET OUR
REGION I CAN'T MINUTES.
SERVICES THESE ARE QUITE A FEW
COMMUNITIES DOING SANITATION
STATIONS ARE NOT RECORDED THIS
YEAR CHIU BUILDING ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY FOR EMERGENCY SHELTERS
ALL THE WAY UP TO PERMANENT THE
FACT. REMAINS A PART OF HOUSING.
THE THANK YOU THAT I THINK A
YOU KNOW HOW THE DATA READY TO
SHARE WITH VERY. IN TERMS OF
WHAT WHAT THAT ACTUALLY LOOKS
LIKE CAN YOU PROVIDE US IN
WRITING CAN YOU PROVIDE TO THE
BUDGET STAFF THE NUMBER THAT
YOU JUST SPOKE ABOUT. YEAH
THEY'RE ALL IN OUR ANNUAL
REPORT WERE HAPPY TO GET BACK
TO YOU. GREAT THANK YOU. MISS
OUT OF HERE IT IS FALL UPON ON
MY COLLEAGUES SELECTEES. ISSUES
WITH THAT YOU GOT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND HAVE BEEN HELPED AND
HE HE SAID. THAT'S IN VARIOUS
STAGES CORRECT. SIXTY SIX SEVEN
HAVE BEEN INSURED FOR DINNER A
STATUS ON THAT 660-001-6000
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THAT
PORTION OF A CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS AS FAR AS HELP. CAN
YOU QUANTIFY WHAT THAT WE SEE
THERE HELPED. WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN EXACTLY. BUT THE RANGE
WILL BE WILL BE ABLE VERY SO IT
WILL BE EVERYTHING FROM STREET
OUTRAGE TO SHELTER THE FIRM. SO
AVERAGE COULD BE AN OUTREACH
WORKER TALKING TO THEM AND
NOTHING. CHANGING THEIR
WHATEVER THEIR OUTCOME REALLY
LIVING ON THE STREETS STILL
CORRECT. WELL ESPECIALLY WITH
IN REGARDS TO COPE WITH THIS
YEAR WE ACTUALLY THOUGHT OF
OUTRAGE AND PROVIDING I CAN GET
ACCESSORISED REALLY CRITICAL
LIFESAVING WORK THIS YEAR I'M
SO THAT DOES KEEP THEM SAFE AND
THE METHOD AND I THINK WE CAN
REALLY MINDFUL ENCOURAGING.
COMMUNITIES TO USE THE FUNDING
AND THAT WAY I WE YOU KNOW WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IT CAN TAKE
MULTIPLE POINTS OF CONTACT FOR
SOMEBODY THAT IS THAT IF I'M
SHOPPING TO. TAKE TRUST AND
COMMODORES AND SO OFTEN THAT IS
AN IMMEDIATE- CONNECTION AND
THINK THAT OKAY KEEP GOING BACK
OUT TO DO THAT REGION BILL
BACKTRACK BEFORE SOMEONE IS
WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT AYE
SHELTER. THE PROBLEM IS WE
SPENT OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AT THIS TWO BILLION DOLLARS ON
HOMELESSNESS WE REALLY HAVEN'T
HAD IMPACT ON THAT NEVER HEARD
ANYBODY FROM THE FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. TALK ABOUT
FEES CHRONICALLY. THE HOMELESS
FOR. THE FOR MIDDLE ILLNESS
SUBSTANCE. AND THESE FOLKS ARE
THAT- QUALIFY UNDER FIFTY ONE
FIFTY. BECAUSE NOT A DANGER
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. BUT THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE NO ONE EVER
MENTIONED THAT ABOUT ME A
PROGRAMMER WEEK. WE TAKE
CONSERVATIVE THESE FOLKS AND
GET OFF THE STREETS. AND GIVE
THEM. SHELTER SOME MILLS
CLEANED UP. AND THEN IF ANY
MEDICATION BECAUSE SOME FOLKS
WITH A- MONSTER MEDICATED
THEY'RE ABLE TO GET YOU KNOW.
IT'S WITH THE CHIEF SOMEONE OF
NORMAL. IN IN IN IN MY SEVEN
YEARS HERE NO ONE'S EVER TALKED
ABOUT THAT. WE'RE STILL
THROWING MONEY AT THIS PROBLEM
AND THAT DOESN'T HELP BECAUSE
SOME THAT THAT THAT SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL THEY CAN'T MAKE
THAT DECISION. YOU CAN HAVE
YOUR- NOT YOU THAT REACH
WORKERS TALK TO MORE YOU WANT.
BUT EVEN TODAY IF THEY CAN'T
MAKE DECISION FOR HIMSELF.
THEMSELVES AT WHAT TIME DOES
THE STATE STEP IN. AND BE THE
ADULTS THE ROOM TO MAKE THAT
DECISION I'VE NEVER HEARD FROM
ANYONE FROM ANYONE IS
ORGANIZATIONS HERE TODAY SAYING
THAT. IT IS HIGH TIME WITH A
CONVERSATION WITH THAT. BECAUSE
OTHERWISE IT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE
WHEN PEOPLE COMPLAIN ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS. YOU KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF HOMELESSNESS HOMELESS
FOLKS. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT ARE CHRONICALLY.
HOMELESS THAT ARE MENTALLY ILL
AND THAT HAVE SUFFERED ABUSE
PROBLEMS. SO HOW DO WE
RECONCILE THAT ONCE AND FOR ALL.
WHAT I WOULD SAY THE NUMBER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND THAT HAVE
BEEN PERMANENTLY HOW A PORTION
OF THOSE WHICH I CAN GET BACK
TO YOU ON WORK CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS AND WITH PERMANENTLY
HOUSED. AND WE DO BELIEVE
MAKING AN IMPACT ON THAT I
THINK YOU ALL WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME
OF THE LESSONS LEARNED THAT
WORKING FOR GATHERING FROM THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM I WOULD
SAY THAT WE'RE SEEING. MORE
CONCERN AROUND AND PEOPLE THAT
ARE LEGALLY HOMELESS COMING
INTO THE SYSTEM- BUT BUT WE'RE
SEEING SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
PERMANENT HOUSING EFFORTS SO
THAT THESE ARE NOT POSTED ARE
STAGNANT AND ON AN ONGOING AS
HOMELESS BUT THAT ARE COMING
INTO THE SYSTEM- AND ANNUALLY
YOUR HOUSING. I'M AT QUITE A
FEW FOLKS. IN THE CITY IT'S NOT
A PROBLEM AND DELETE WE ARE
FIGHTING UPSTREAM IS LAW IN THE
SIXTEEN THOUSAND THAT WERE
HELD. WHAT IS THE FOLLOW UP ON
THAT ARE STILL BEING HOUSE
ASSEMBLY REVERT BACK. TO
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE I KNOW
PORTION OF THEM. HAVE THAT. BUT
OBVIOUSLY WITH GROUPS GETTING
STAY MONEY. THEY'VE BEEN PUT IN.
STATE OR LOCAL HOUSING FOR
SHOULD BE SHOULD BE RELATIVELY
SIMPLE TO GET THOSE NUMBERS HOW
MANY FOLKS HAVE HAVE LEFT THAT
HOUSING AND GONE BACK TO THE
STREETS. IN MY IN MY SWING THAT
WRONG. NOT ONLY THAT WE DO NOT
PORTION OF FOLKS DEFAULT
FALLBACK INTO HOMELESSNESS I'M
NOT THAT IS SOMETHING YOU TRACK
CLOSELY ARE H. I. F. SYSTEM
WHICH I MENTIONED IN MY INITIAL
REMARKS WILL BE ABLE TO ALLOW
AFFECT OKAY YEAH EXACTLY YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND- I'M YOU KNOW
RETURNS HOMELESSNESS. AS WE
COLLECTIVELY WE DO EXPECT- THAT
THERE ARE THERE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY OUR NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT WILL FALL BACK INTO
HOMELESSNESS. I AM BACK BUT WE
DON'T WE DON'T HAVE THAT RIGHT
NOW WE USUALLY TRACK EXPENSE
INCREMENTS. AND FROM EVERYTHING
AROUND FOR TWO YEARS YEAH I'M
VERY KEEN THAT I IMAGINE HAVE
BEEN ALREADY ADMITTED INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING. I HAVE MORE
THAN SIX MONTHS AND NOT
PERMANENT. I WOULD BE ABLE TO
TRACK IT BACK BUT IT IS DATA
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
BE ABLE WAY ABLE TRACK
IDENTIFIED THREE. SO YOU WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT DATA THEN.
NOW YES YEAH YEAH YEAH BEABLE
TO A THE NUMBER. OKAY HOW SOON
WE SEE THAT DATA THAN. THE ONLY
THING THAT GRAYSON SYSTEM GO
LIVE AT THE END OF THE MONTH-
WE WITH THEIR MANY TO ABOUT AND
THAT THAT'S THE FIRST ROUND WE
WON'T THAT DATA THE FIRST ROUND.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WILL IT
WILL BE AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO US KNOW HOW MANY
FOLKS LEAVING AT SOME POINT IN
DOING THAT NOW LIVE HERE FROM
YOUR AGENCY AT SOME POINT. TO
TALK ABOUT THOSE FOLKS THAT CAN
MAKE THAT DECISION COMMUNITY IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO COME IN. ARE
NOT ABLE TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
IT'S A MOOT POINT. BECAUSE WE
CAN'T FOR SOMEONE TO KILL AND-
THE- HEALTH. CORRECT WE ARE
HOUSING BIRTHDATE WE CANNOT
REQUIRE HELLO OKAY SO WHAT WE
GONNA DO FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
CAN MAKE THAT DECISION WHAT
WHAT IS YOUR GAME PLAN- YOU
GUYS HAVE ANYTHING RIGHT NOW
FOR MY- MY COLLEAGUES POINTED
SAID MR ON THAT POINT RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE. MORE FOLKS EAGER TO
COME INDOORS THEY HAVE ACCESS
AND AVAILABILITY FOR AND SO I
THINK THAT WE ARE REALLY
FOCUSING ON. YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF- OF
UNITS AND BANDS AND SERVICES WE
CAN PROVIDE BECAUSE THERE ARE
PLENTY OF FOLKS. WHO ARE
EAGERLY AWAITING SUPPORT THAT
WE CANNOT CURRENTLY ACCESS TO.
I MISS THE I THINK. THE
CONVERSATION THE PART MISSING
AND THE RESPONSE IS THAT YES
THERE ARE. LOTS OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE CAPABLE THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE THAT YOU ARE HELPING
HOWEVER. THERE IS A LARGE
POPULATION OF MENTALLY. THE
FOLKS THAT ARE HAVE A MENTAL
DISABILITY MENTAL DISABILITY
THAT DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
MAKE A DECISION FOR THEMSELVES
HOW ARE WE HELPING THEM AND
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN FOR THAT THAT
PARTICULAR POPULATION AND THE
THING IS THE COMMITMENT
DECISION. A OVER IS CALLED A
FAMILIAR WARM CLOTHES I'M NOT
GONNA BE HALF NAKED HAVE MY
SHOES OFF. I'M A TRYING GET
FOOD I'M NOT DIG INTO TRASH
CANS I MEAN. IT'S TO ME IT'S A
THESE FOLKS THAT ARE SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL- HIGHER NEED. AND
MORE SIGNIFICANTLY THAN THE
OTHER ONE SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
ISSUE. AN ERROR I GUESS THERE
THE MORE DIRE STATE. I THINK
PRETTY WITH A COMMENT ON THIS.
RIGHT YES NO MATTER COMING ON
THIS ISSUE YES MISS THOMPSON GO
AHEAD THANK YOU BRING IT UP TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THERE ARE TWO PROPOSALS MOVING
THROUGH A DIFFERENT SUB
COMMITTEE THEY DO ADDRESS
BEHAVIOR OF BEHAVIORAL NEEDS.
PLEASE THERE'S THE KALANK. AND
THEN THERE'S THEY- DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
PROPOSAL THAT I BRIEFLY
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME. AND IT WILL BE USED
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE COMMUNITY
IF YOU WANT SPECIFICS OF THE ON
THOSE PROPOSALS I CAN'T TAKE
THAT BACK TO MY HOPE AND HEART
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
KILEY. DIRECTIVES BATH- THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL BUT ACTIVE
RENEWED PRIORITIZE THESE THINGS
SO. I DON'T THINK MANAGER
MANAGER IF I COULD JUST MAKE IT
IT'S MORE COMMON THAN IT IS A
QUESTION. THE FRUSTRATION THAT
YOU'RE HEARING FROM MY
COLLEAGUE AND I WERE BOTH HAVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE OF
MANY MANY YEARS. AND RIGHT NOW
THAT THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
AVENUE OF PROTECTION THAT MANY
OF THESE. PEOPLE GET CAUGHT IN
AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT-
ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY AND THE
CUSTODY IS THE ANSWER FOR
PROTECTION AND IS NOT THE
ANSWER. AND THERE'S A HIGH
SENSE OF FRUSTRATION. THAT THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS LEFT AS THE
AS THE CARE GIVERS FOR PEOPLE
THAT HAVE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
ARE BEYOND OUR ABILITY TO FIX.
AND THAT IS THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT IS TO. BE A SUPPORT
NETWORK AND- PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE. AND WE KEEP
FUNNELING A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF MONEY BECAUSE WE'RE GOOD AT
THAT. BUT WE'RE NOT GOOD AT IS
PROVIDING THE SERVICE IN THE
SUPPORT THAT THESE PEOPLE
DESERVE. AND THAT'S IF YOU HEAR
FRUSTRATION FROM MY COLONIZED
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN IT WE'VE
LIVED IT. AND SO IT'S VERY VERY
REAL TO US. AND SO. WE'RE JUST
ASKING. FOR MAYBE SOME
CATEGORIZATION. ON WHAT HELP
MEANS AND IS IT REALLY HELP OR
IS IT JUST. YOU KNOW AND I
BILLION OBLIGATION BECAUSE WERE
FUNDED TO DO SO THERE IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE. AND SO WE'RE JUST
REALLY TRYING TO PROVIDE THE
HELP THESE PEOPLE DESERVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER LUCKY TO HAVE A RESPONSE
TO THAT. I WOULD I WOULD. SAY
THAT I THINK THAT- TO- BRITNEY
POINT THAT THAT IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET DOES
ACTUALLY HE GOT A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THE PUZZLE
THAT WOULD. WOULD PROVIDE
RECIPE I THINK THAT IN SOME OF
THESE ADDITIONAL SERVICES THAT
WERE AT WORK I THINK RIGHT NOW
AND I THINK THEY HAVE INTEREST
YOU I'M I WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
THERE'S FURTHER DISCUSSION.
ABOUT THANK YOU I WOULD ALSO
ADD- IF I HEARD MISS THOMPSON
CORRECTLY IT'S THE ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
IS ALSO IN THE SAME LINE. OF
THE ONE OF WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST AND WHAT THE STATE HAS
DONE IN THE PAST OF ONE TIME
FUNDING ALLOCATION FOR RELATED
TO HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS HE
NEEDS TO BE A PARALLEL. LINE IN
TERMS OF HOW WE DEAL WITH-
ISSUES REGARDING MENTAL HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
WELL AT THE SAME TIME
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES OF
HOUSING AND FUNDING FOR THAT.
ADDITIONAL QUESTION HOW WILL
THE H. CFCS- ACTION PLAN DO.
THE COORDINATION WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. THE WHOLE PLANET BEEN
DONE AND BRING. BY THE THANK
MEMBERS- THE DIFFERENT. AND
WHILE I COUNT MEMBERS TO THE
LOCAL. IN SOUTH YOU'LL SEE AN
ACTUAL PLAN ITSELF- INTERACTIVE
ABOUT OUR WEBSITE RIGHT NOW AND
AS- DIFFERENT LEVELS OF THE
ACTIVITIES FROM ALL THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS SO DID
NOT. WORKING YES THE STAFF ARE
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR WE WILL BE
TRACKING A FOR NEEDING IF IT'S
LOCATING THAT WORK. BUT MUCH OF
THAT WORK IS ACTUALLY BEING
DONE BY DEPARTMENT. SO IT'S-
VERY ACTIVE PARTICIPATION- FROM
ALL ALL COUNCIL MEMBERS. THAT
REPRESENT. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STILL A COMMON ARE
GREAT OF. IF YOU COME IS JUST
THIS TO FIRST OF ALL I WILL TO
CONCUR IN THE COMMON OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ABOUT HOW- OUR
CITIES BUT PARTICULAR THE STATE
DOESN'T HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
WAY TO ADDRESS THE INCREDIBLE
TRAGEDIES ON OUR STREETS
INVOLVING INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES WE
HAVE SOME PARTIAL SOLUTIONS ON
THE HOUSING FRONT WE- HAVE AS
YOU ALLUDED TO SOME ELEMENTS OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WHEN IT
COMES TO HEALTH CARE- BUT THE
REALITY IS OUR- OUR LAWS ARE
NOT EQUIPPED OR CONSERVATORSHIP
LAWS OR OTHERS. TO ADDRESS THE-
THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
FRANKLY THE FOLKS ARE DYING ON
OUR STREETS- BECAUSE OF THE
RULES WE HAVE IN PLACE AND SO.
I CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO ECHO-
OUR DESIRE TO RECEIVE FROM THE
MINISTRATION IF YOU FEEL LIKE
THERE IS IN THIS BUDGET SORT OF
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
THAT WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT AND HELP BUILD A NOT
BECAUSE- THAT'S AN ONGOING
FRUSTRATION OPTICALLY FOR MY
CITY AS WELL AS I THINK EVERY
CITY IN OUR IN OUR STATE. AND I
DO ALSO WANT TO ECHO SOMETHING
THAT OUR OUR CHAIRMAN SAID
WHICH IS- HIP HOP OUR OUR OUR
ONE TIME PROGRAMS- BUT WE KNOW
THAT THESE ARE LONG TERM
ONGOING CRISES THAT WILL NOT A
GET DRESSED IF WE SOLVE IT OR
WE TRY TO SOLVE IT IN A- IN A
PERMANENT WAY AT THIS MOMENT
WE'RE ALL HEARING FROM OUR
CITIES. THAT THE ONE TIME
FUNDING IS GREAT BUT THEY CAN'T
COUNT ON PERMANENT FUNDING AND
IF THE ONE TIME FUNDING GOES
AWAY THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN A
WORLD OF HURT SO I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE AGAIN THE POINT I
MADE EARLIER JUST SOMETHING I
CAN IMAGINE- THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL WOULD AGREE WITH. ABOUT
THE NEED FOR AN ONGOING FUNDING
STREAM FOR THESE SERVICES AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO- A COUPLE
QUESTIONS I HAVE- I ONE THING
THAT REALLY JUMPED OUT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WAS THAT HE
HAS SERVED IF I DID THE MATH
CORRECTLY- FOURTEEN TIMES THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE.
PASSED AND I ASSUME THAT HAS
SOME AND TO DO WITH THE-
PROGRAM. OF THE FACT THAT IT'S
NEWER- COULD YOU TALK ABOUT WHY
THE DISCREPANCY IS SO
SIGNIFICANT SO HE PRESERVED
OVER. SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND FOLKS
HAPPENS ONLY SERVE FORTY SIX
HUNDRED FOLKS. SO JUST HELP US
UNDERSTAND THAT AND ALSO. I
KNOW CAP WAS SUPPOSED TO FOCUS
ON REGIONAL COORDINATION. COULD
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN THAT WORK
ONE OF THE BEST PRACTICES. TO
FACILITATE THAT REGIONAL
COORDINATION WORK WHICH WE KNOW
IS SO IMPORTANT TO GRAPPLE WITH
THIS. YEAH ABSOLUTELY I THINK
THE DIFFERENCE YOU'RE SEEING
AND HE COULDN'T HAPPEN FIRST
TERM IN IN ALMOST ENTIRELY YOU
TO WHEN THEY- WERE RELEASED
FROM HOSPITAL. HE HAD OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF AND IN TERMS OF
I DOLLARS AND THEY HATE IT IF
BROWN'S SO. WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IN HAPPENED ABOUT FIVE MONTHS
OF THE SERVICE THE CITY I'M
OVERSEEING AND KEEP IT OVER TWO
YEARS. EIGHT SO THERE'S A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
IN TIME AT THAT I MEAN. AND SO
I THINK WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
PRETTY HEARTENED BY HOW QUICKLY
HAVE GOTTEN OFF THE GROUND AND
OKAY STARTED SERVING PEOPLE SO.
I THINK I'M- A I'M- TO STAY
TUNED FOR APPRECIATING REPORT I
THINK WE'RE PRETTY CONFIDENT
WILL BE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS FROM. I'M NOT FUNDING
STREAM- IN TERMS OF A PARTY
NATION AND BEST PRACTICES. NO I
THINK WE HAVE DONE A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT HEFCE PARTICULARLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT I
THINK HAVE BEEN REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. I'M IN IN
RELATION ARE FUNDING BUT ALSO
OTHER FUNDING. EIGHT I'M GONNA
TELL PUBLIC MEETINGS THROUGH
REGIONAL PARTNER NATION INTO
ONE BEING- EARLIER THIS SUMMER
I BELIEVE IT WAS IN JULY. WE
PUT OUT A STRATEGIC SPENDING
GUIDE TO REALLY THINK ROOM WITH
A DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE RECEIVING
I HAVE ASKED THAT. SEPARATED
THOSE FUNDING- STREAMS AND WANT
TO USE THAT ONE SO REALLY BRING.
CITY THE RECEIPT BECAUSE OF OUR
FINDING AT ALL YEAH- AS WELL AS
THE STP FUNDING AS WELL AS
COUNTY THAT RECEIVED BOTH YES
ASK. FROM WITHIN. AND HE AND
HALF OUT AND AS WELL AS THE IF
HE'S EVER GETTING DIRECT
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND. A COUPLE. YOU
KNOW A COUPLE A FAMILY THING
THAT THE NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES
ACTUALLY WERE CITIES ARE OUR
MOST I'M- TRYING TO ACTUALLY BE
THE ONES TO PURCHASE-
ADDITIONAL. ADDED TO NAVIGATION
CENTERS ARE EMERGENCY SHELTER
AFFECTS YOUR FEET ARE MORE
FACTS TENTATIVELY DO THAT THE
OPERATIONS OF THE FINDINGS ARE
USING- I THINK HE HE- HE FUNDS
TO PURCHASE THE PROPERTY BACK
AND HAVING TO SEE I SEE YOU
THERE. I'M ACTUALLY KEEPING
ONGOING THREE THINK THAT
HANDFUL OF THAT KIND OF WORK.
AND BUT I THINK WE'RE REALLY
HEARTENED BY AND WOULD STAY IN
THE PAST PRACTICE. IN ADDITION
THE DIFFERENT FUNDING ENTITIES
THAT WE START I THINK WE'VE
ALSO SEEN SOME REALLY GREAT
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH- SOME
OF THE USED PROVIDERS THAT THAT
ARE ARE OUT THERE ARE PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES. AND EVEN
OUR CALTRANS BUT THERE IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE IN OAKLAND THAT
OF A LOCAL LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
WITH CALTRANS THAT APARTMENT
NUMBER OF UNSHELTERED FOLKS IN
INTO THAT- BY A LOCAL SHELTER
THERE SO. REALLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK HAPPENING
THIS FUNDING SELF. OF THE LINE
COULD BE. THE GREAT. PROJECT
THAT. I HAD ONE SO OF QUESTIONS
DATA. AND AS YOU KNOW IT'S WE
DISCUSS A YEARS AGO I HAD A
BILL. THAT WOULD CREATE THE
DATA WHERE AND I TO SEND AN I'M
AS X. AS I THINK YOU ARE. A HOW
CLOSE YOUR TO LAUNCH IN THIS
DAY. WAREHOUSE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE MORE FROM WE HAVE THE
BETTER WE CAN WE CAN ACHIEVE-
SORT OF TWO FOR QUESTION TO
WHAT OU'RE DOING WITH THAT
DATA. ONE IS- YOU KNOW THE IDEA
FOR THIS IS FOR STATE AGENCIES
TO TAKE THIS LOCAL DATA AND
THEN USE IT TO BETTER TARGET.
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AT
THE STATE LEVEL WONDERING IF
THAT NEXT STEP IS GOING TO
HAPPEN SORT OF WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE THE STATE
WHEN IT COMES TO STATE
PROGRAMS. THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS- THERE'S BEEN AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION ABOUT. THE
NEED FOR A GAPS AND NEEDS
ANALYSIS AND BY THAT I MEAN.
IT'S ONE THING TO KNOW WHAT
LOCALS ARE DOING CURRENTLY ON
HOMELESSNESS AND HOPEFULLY ALSO
KNOW WHAT THE NEED IS. AND WE
NEED TO DO THE ANALYSIS OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND WHAT WE NEED. TO BE
ABLE TO TALLY UP HOW MUCH MORE
THE STATE NEEDS TO INVEST IN
THIS AREA. AND IT'S NOT CLEAR
TO ME AT ALL THAT THAT THAT THE
STATEWIDE DATA WAREHOUSE WILL
BE ABLE TO GET US THAT
INFORMATION SO WONDERING. ON
THOSE TWO QUESTIONS SORT OF ONE
THE IMPACT ON THE INFORMATION
ON STATE PROGRAMS AND TO. HOW
CAN WE REALLY GET AT THAT
NUMBER IF I'M IF I'M LOOKING
FOR THE NUMBER OF HOW MUCH THE
STATE NEEDS TO INVEST IN
HOMELESSNESS. IN THE COMING
YEARS TO END HOMELESSNESS. IS
THIS DATA GOING TO GET US THAT
INFORMATION. YEAH GREAT GREAT
QUESTION SO I CAN WHAT WILL.
THAT IS THAT IS ONE AT THE END
OF THE MONTH IT'S JUST WHAT
WE'RE GOING. SORT OF THE
BEGINNING OF WHAT EACH DAY I
CAN ACTUALLY PROVIDE- WE REALLY
SEE IT AS- AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE INFORM OUR
POLICY MAKING AND RESOURCES TO
TERMINATION I'M GOING REALLY
INTO THE FUTURE. SO THAT ONE
WILL BE SORT OF SHOWING THE
FIRST AND WE'RE CALLING A BETA
LAUNCH AT THE END OF THE MONTH.
WILL HAVE A HANDFUL OF
DASHBOARDS REALLY DIVING INTO
THE CHARACTERISTICS OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
THINKING ABOUT THAT CROFTERS
FICTIONAL OVERLAP- IN BEING
BETWEEN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
THAT STATE. SEEM AS A SIMPLE
OUT THERE GOING TO BE A LOT
THEY ARE JUST THE FIRST ONE BUT
THERE'S A LOT MORE THAN WE NOW
WE CAN ANALYZE AND LOOKING TO.
ANSWER QUESTIONS GROUND SO.
WE'RE EXPECTING SORT OF ON
GOING AFTER THIS BUNCH IS THAT
THEY'LL BE QUARTERLY ACT
ANYTHING OR REALLY ANY
QUESTIONS. ANSWERED RESEARCH
STANDPOINT JUST BECAUSE OF HOW
HARD PASSED THE SYSTEM WILL BE-
SO WHAT WE ARE TALKING MORE
ABOUT THAT WITH. YOU ALL. HERE
IN A COUPLE WEEKS WHEN WE DO WE
DO A PREVIEW OF THE SYSTEM
EVERYBODY. BUT WE'LL JUST SAY
THAT WHAT WE SEE ONE THING IS
JUST THE BEGINNING AND THERE'S
A LOT MORE THAT WE YOU KNOW WE
CAN. A LOT OF YEAH. I'M INTO
YOUR QUITE THINKING MAYBE
MENTIONING. YOU KNOW SORT OF
WHAT WE'RE CALLING. TO THIS OF.
IS LOOKING AT MATCHING.
HOMELESSNESS DATA WITH OTHER
LOCAL. YOU FOR TAKING UP. STATE
LAW. I'M I WOULD BE FOR WE'VE
BEEN. LASER FOCUSED DEFEATING
DISPERSE PHASE THAT. AND WE
KNOW THAT THAT THAT THAT
INTERNET. STEP IN A REALLY
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY. THERE
BUT I THINK RIGHT NOW OUR REAL
GOOD THINGS ABOUT THIS AND GET.
IS PRETTY PRETTY SIGNIFICAN
LET'S LOOK. ROW BUT I KNOW THAT.
I'M BUT IT'S SORT OF OUR
PRIMARY. STEP BE YEAH FIRST
HE'S GOING. TO RIGHT NOW THAT
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THE- AND-
SYSTEM IS REALLY. ADAM IT IS
TRACKING. THAT THE NUMBER OF
ACROSS THIS. I HAVE ACCESS.
THROUGH THE- SERVICES. STATE IT
DOESN'T HAVE THAT. AND SENSE OF.
TO IT'S MUCH. ABOUT WHAT THE IN.
SERVICES ARE BE. WE NEED I
DON'T THINK. THE WALLS THINGS
AS A AS A HOMES DATA GEEK WOULD
LOVE FOR MY STAFF AND I TO BE
INVITED TO THE BRIEFINGS THAT
YOU DO AS YOU ROLL THIS OUT
BECAUSE WHAT WE WILL HAVE A LOT
OF THOUGHTS WILL WANT TO
REALIZE THAT DATA- AND THEN TO
OUR COLLEAGUES WHAT I WILL SAY
IS YOU KNOW WE ARE ALL
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATED THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE HAVE
ALREADY SPENT BUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. PART OF THE
FRUSTRATION IS NOT JUST ABOUT
HOW THOSE DOLLARS ARE SPENT BUT
IS THE REALITY THAT WE ARE JUST
MAKING A DENT IN A VERY LARGE
PROBLEM- SO YOU KNOW FOR
TALKING ABOUT- ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF THOUSANDS OF FOLKS
WERE HOMELESS WHEN WE HAVE OVER
A HUNDRED. THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IT'S A MATTER SCALE AND- I
THINK WE HAVE TO DO A
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF.
REALLY WHAT'S IT GONNA TAKE IF
WE ARE GOING TO ACTUALLY AND
HOMELESSNESS. SERVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS WHAT IS THE LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT WE NEED- JUST SO WE
CANHAVE. APPROPRIATE
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE PUBLIC AND
FOR CONSTITUENTS AND FOR
OURSELVES OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO DO. AND I SUSPECT
THAT THAT NUMBER IS QUITE LARGE
BUT WE'VE NEVER REALLY TALLIED
IT UP ACROSS THE STATE AND SO.
I THINK AND HOPE THAT THIS YEAR
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD. WITH
SOME SORT OF AT LEAST HIGH
LEVEL GAPS A NEEDS ANALYSIS TO
REALLY GET THAT I THINK
THAT'LL- PROBABLY FRAME THE
CONVERSATION WHAT WE NEED TO
DO- AND LOOK FORWARD TO AT TEND
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS DURING
THIS BUDGET. PROCESS AND WITH
THAT MEASURE BUT DO YOU THANKS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER TO
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH AND LET ME JUST SAY-
MISS THAT INTO YOU INTO YOUR
COLLEAGUES. AT THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO I KNOW
THAT IT ISA TOUGH JOB
ESPECIALLY AMID COBIT AND S. AS
I KNOW YOU WORK AND WORK AND IT
SEEMS LIKE. WE'RE NOT MOVING
THE NEEDLE ON IT BUT THAT'S
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE SO MUCH
NEED BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU- AND APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
EFFORTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING SOME OF THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION- AS WELL. LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT-
THIS IS RELATED TO TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION- COMMITTEE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS WILL
BEGIN WITH MASS- NANCY ARE
HOMELESS AND I WANNA WELCOME IS
ROBUST TO OUR COMMITTEE SHE WAS
RECENTLY APPOINTED AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF C. T. C.
A. C. AND WE WANTED TO GIVE HER
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE
HERSELF AND THEN. A FOLLOW UP
WITH HER DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR ANY ADDITIONAL-
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS AT
BEFORE WE GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICE ANALYST OFFICE MISS
ROBLESS. GREAT THANK YOU. IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE AND IT'S NICE
TO MEET YOU ALL. I JUST WANTED
TO INTRODUCE. AND I AM A
RECOVERING BANKER I SPENT
THIRTY YEARS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IN THE BANKING INDUSTRY
AND STARTED MY STATE CAREER AT
CP CFA IN THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE. AFTER THAT I WENT TO A
CASE THAT THE TRACTOR'S OFFICE
FOR A WHILE AND THEN- WAS THE
ACTING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF I
THINK. I WAS AT I THINK FOR
ABOUT SIX YEARS AND I'VE NOW
COME BACK TO THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE AND I AM AT. A PRETTY
BRAND NEW EMPLOYEE TO THE
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE. AND THAT
IT'S VERY NICE TO MEET YOU ALL.
THANK YOU. THANKS MISTER SET UP.
AND THEN WE'LL GO THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AS WELL AS
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. GOOD AFTERNOON- I JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE SOME
BACKGROUND REAL QUICK ON THE
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE. ARE WE
ARE THE ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- IT
WAS ORIGINALLY PUT IN PLACE TO
ENCOURAGE PRIVATE INVESTMENT
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS. AND THERE ARE TWO
TYPES OF FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS AND ONE OF
WHICH IS A 4% TAX CREDIT WHICH-
ARE REQUIRED TO BE CARED WITH
TAX EXEMPT BONDS. IN THE
ALLOCATING AGENCY FOR THAT IS
SET LACK WHICH IS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
ALLOCATION TO MANY- THROUGH
THAT YOU KNOW IN IN YEARS PAST
THE BONDS WERE NOT COMPETITIVE-
HOWEVER. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE ON ONE AUTHORIZED.
ATTY CAC TO OUR ALLOCATE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION AND STATE TAX
CREDITS TO THESE PROJECTS ARE
SPECIFIC 24% SPECIFIC TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION- TO TEST FOR- UNIT
PRODUCTION AND FULL UTILIZATION
OF THE BOND CAP. AND IN IN
REVIEWING IT IT LOOKS LIKE WE
DID THAT- I WANT TO PROVIDE
SOME DATA. OF HIS NAME. 4%
PROJECTS NEW CONSTRUCTION UNITS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE DID ABOUT
SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED NEW
CONSTRUCTION 4% UNITS- THAT WAS
ABOUT SIXTY ONE PROJECTS. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WE DID ABOUT
FORTY NINE HUNDRED. WHICH IS
ABOUT SIXTY PROJECTS IN IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE DID A TOTAL.
THIRTEEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT TOTAL UNITS.
THAT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
THREE PROJECTS. IN OF THOSE
THIRTEEN UNITS I WOULD SAY FIVE
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
WERE SPECIFICALLY TIED TO ABOUT
SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT JUST
BELOW SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED
UNITS. SO IT ESSENTIALLY
DOUBLED THE VOLUME OF NEW
CONSTRUCTION UNITS ON THE 4%
HELLO LET LOOKS LIKE A SUCCESS-
BASED ON THAT STATISTIC- IN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHTY
THREE CAME OUT AND IT REQUIRE
T. K. I CAN SELECT TO ADOPT
REGULATION CHANGES TO A LOT
ALIGN THE COMMITTEES WITH THE
GOAL TO INCREASE PRODUCTION.
AND CONTAIN COSTS AND ADOPT THE
SCORING SYSTEM THAT MAXIMIZE
THE USE OF THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
AND THREW I WANT TO SAY TEN
MEETINGS BUT AT LEAST TEN
PUBLIC MEETINGS WITH THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. REGULATION
CHANGES WERE ULTIMATELY ADOPTED
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THEY
INCORPORATED A LOT OF THE GOALS
THAT WERE OUTLINED IN EIGHTY
EIGHTY THREE SPECIFIC TO-
PROXIMITY TO AMENITIES AND JOBS
AND PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
LOCATIONS OF DEVELOPMENT.
DELIVERY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO LOW EXTREMELY LOW AND VERY
LOW INCOME HOUSING- AND
INCENTIVES TO PRESERVE PROVIDE
PROVIDE A DENSITY INCREASES.
AND THEN JUST EFFICIENT USE OF
THE- RESOURCE CENTER AND ALL OF
THAT WAS BUILT INTO THE
REGULATIONS- SO WE DID BUT
STATE IN FEBRUARY WE RECEIVED.
A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED TWENTY TO
COMPLICATIONS ON A 4% SIDE. AND
IT LOOKS LIKE WE WILL PROBABLY
GONNA BE ABOUT TWO TO TWO AND A
HALF. TIMES OVERSUBSCRIBED
BASED ON YOU KNOW BASED ON. THE
AMOUNT THAT WE'VE MADE
AVAILABLE IN THE FIRST ROUND SO-
THE REGULAR CHECK CHANGES
ULTIMATELY. ARE WHAT THE GOAL
IS TO SPREAD THE BONDS OUT.
HOUSE PROGRAMS IN THE VARIOUS
REGIONS AND AGAIN SPRIGGAN
PRODUCTION AND- LOWER THE COSTS.
SO IF I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU MISTER SETTLER TO
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
DINNER CRUISE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE.
LMAO RIGHT ONE BILLION IN AND
DOLLARS AND LOW INCOME HAPPENED
CREDIT OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
OF THE LEGISLATURE CONTEMPLATES
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM WE JUST ADJUST
THE LEGISLATURE. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT A COPY BY FUNDS- HAVE OR
BEEN AUTHORIZED I'M NOT ONLY
THE NUMBER OF UNITS BUT ALSO
EXAMPLE- HOW THESE THINGS HAVE
BEEN DISTRIBUTED WHERE THOSE
UNITS ARE LOCATED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND WHERE HAVE BEEN
THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR IMPROVEMENT
FOR THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THAT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE DO THAT I HAVE A FEW
OF MY OWN. WHAT IS A GEOGRAPHIC
BREAKDOWN OF TAX CREDITS AND
BONDS IN THE LAST ROUND- THE
LAST ROUND. WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THAT- YOU KNOW THERE'S A COUPLE
OF REGIONS THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED IN THE SAID LACK OF
REGULATIONS ON DECEMBER- AND
THESE ARE GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS
WITHIN. A NEW CONSTRUCTION. SET
ASIDE- NOW GRANTED THESE WERE
ESTABLISHED- REGULATIONS WERE
ESTABLISHED FOR OUR FUTURE SO
THE INFORMATION I'M PROVIDING
TO YOU WAS PRIOR TO THESE
REGULATIONS BEING ADOPTED- BUT
I CAN GIVE YOU BASED ON THOSE
REGIONS. I'D SAY APPROXIMATELY.
3637% OF THEM WERE LOCATED IN
THE L. A. COUNTY. ABOUT SIX AND
I'M LOOKING AT BONDS AND TAX
CREDITS SEPARATELY BUT ROUGHLY
VERY CLOSE UP PERCENTAGES
LICENSE- COASTAL GENERALS ABOUT
7% L. MAKE IN 37% THE BAY AREA
WAS ABOUT 46% THE INLAND REGION
WITH ABOUT 3% AND THEN THE
NORTHERN REGION WAS ABOUT SIX
AND A HALF PERCENT. BUT AGAIN
THE WORK BASED OFF OF- FIGURES
THAT PRECEDED THE REGULATION
ADOPTION SO NOW WE WON'T KNOW.
THE RESULTS OF THE REGULATIONS-
UNTIL A LITTLE BIT FURTHER-
PROBABLY IN THE NEXT YEAR OR
TWO. THANK YOU AND CAN YOU ALSO
PROVIDE US A BREAK DOWN OF THE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT RECEIVED
AWARDS IN THE LAST ROUND.
INCOME LEVELS OF THE UNITS AND
THE LOCATION OF THE
DEVELOPMENTS. YEAH THE
LOCATIONS- INCLUDED ABOUT
SIXTEEN COUNTY. OUR RANGING
FROM ALAMEDA TO BE YOU WHEN
CONTRA COSTA I DON'T KNOW HOW
SPECIFIC- I HAVE KIND OF
CONSOLIDATED DATA- THE INCOME
LEVELS RANGE FROM 20% ALL THE
WAY TO EIGHTY PERCENT. I THINK
MOST OF THE TWENTY AND 30%
UNITS- RESIDED IN LA- BAY AREA.
AND WE AT ABOUT NINE OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE WORKING OUT
OF THE FORTY EIGHT PROJECTS
THAT HAD UNITS RESTRICTED ALL
THE WAY UP 280% OF AREA MEDIAN
INCOME- BUT I'D SAY HALF OF
THEM. WERE SPECIFICALLY- THEY
WOULD QUALIFY UNDER WHAT WE
HAVE CHARACTERIZED AS ELI FEEL
LIKE- SET ASIDE AND- SO TWENTY
FOUR OF THE FORTY EIGHT WOULD
HAVE QUALIFIED UNDER THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO EMAIL THAT
INFORMATION TO BUDGET STUFF.
YES ABSOLUTELY GREAT THANK YOU
IN ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTING- OF
MR TO DID YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT
REQUIREMENTS. I DO THANK YOU-
MISTER ZERO UP THANK YOU FOR
DISCUSSING THE GEOGRAPHIC
BREAKDOWN OF TAX CREDITS UP I
WANT TO TALK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT- THE SAID LAG. UPSET LACK
ALLOCATION SCORING SYSTEM WITH
REGARDS TO THE BAY AREA- I
SUSPECT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS
BUT YOU KNOW OF THE TWENTY
PROJECTS IN THE BAY THAT
COMPETED FOR. BONDS IN ROUND
ONE ONLY THREE RECEIVED AN
AWARD NONE OF THE MAJOR CITIES
OF SAN FRANCISCO CENTERS THERE
OAKLAND THAT'S 11% OF BEAR
PROJECTS THAT WILL BE FUNDED
WHICH IS ONE OF THE LOWEST
RATES COMPARED TO OTHER
REGIONS. AS YOU HAVE PROBABLY
HEARD- THERE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES
THAT- OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE
AROUND THE CIRCLE TIEBREAKER-
THAT- FOCUSES ON COST
EFFICIENCY AND DOESN'T REFLECT
THE FACT THAT IN HIGH COST
CITIES IN THE BAY AREA. IN
REGIONS LIKE THE BAY AREA
WHERE- WHERE- YOU CAN ACTUALLY
FUND PRODUCTION ANDIN CITIES
WHERE THEY ARE NEAR JOBS AND
TRANSIT HUBS- WE THINK THAT-
THERE ARE PROJECTS ARE BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
WANT TO GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT DISCUSSION AND- WHAT WE
CAN DO TO WORK ON THAT MOVING
FORWARD. YEAH I MEAN- I THINK
YOU KNOW I MENTIONED THAT WE
WENT THROUGH TEN PUBLIC.
MEETINGS TO DISCUSS THE
REGULATIONS INCLUDING THE
TIEBREAKER- A LOT OF THE FOCUS
WAS AGAIN YOU KNOW TO CONFORM
WITH WHAT EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE
REQUIRED WHICH WAS COST
CONTAINMENT WAS A HUGE THING-
AND ANOTHER THING WAS.
SPREADING THE RESOURCES AND
WHEN YOU MENTION THE TIE
BREAKER. WHAT TYPE RECOGNITION
INCLUDES A FACTOR THAT- YOU
KNOW LOWER REQUEST- ARE AT A
HIGHER VANTAGE. IN ADDITION
UNIT PRODUCTION IS ALSO IN
THERE AND I THINK WE ARE. THE
POLICY OBVIOUSLY DISCUSSION
WITH THE REGULATIONS WHAT'S
WHAT'S TAKING PLACE. AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT IT AND- OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T KNOW THE RESULTS UNTIL
YOU KNOW THE APPLICATIONS ARE
SUBMITTED AND- SO RIGHT NOW THE
ROUND THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING.
OBVIOUSLY THE APPLICATIONS WERE
SUBMITTED. AND THEY'RE STILL
REVIEW. SO WE WON'T KNOW THE
FINAL RESULT- UNTIL THEY DO
WARDS REMAIN. WE ARE AWARE OF
THAT AND WE ARE LOOKING AT IT-
WE ARE ALSO REVIEWING THE BASIS
LIMITS- THAT'S ALSO BEING
INCLUDED IN THE TIE BREAKER-
BUT WE ARE OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
BE EQUITABLE TO ALL PARTIES
AND- WE ALSO HAD WORKING
GROUP'S WHICH INCLUDED. WORLD
IN URBAN AREAS- BOTH-
NONPROFITS AND FOR PROFITS. IN
THE WORD- PART OF THE PROCESS
AND WE MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE PROCESS
THAT I DURING THIS WHOLE
REGULATION CHANGE- YEAH THE
ENTIRE PROCESS WE WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT. AND I THINK WE
WERE BY TAKING THESE TO PUBLIC
MEETINGS. AND YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES THE OUTCOMES- WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT GO BACK AND LOOK AT.
RE REVIEW THE REGULATIONS AND-
SEE IF THEY- PUT OUT WHAT WE-
THE POLICIES THAT WE
ENVISIONED. WHEN THEY WERE PUT
IN PLACE. SO YOU KNOW I THINK
WHAT ELSE AND RESPONSE I AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW I AM. THE ONE
LEGISLATOR IN THE LEAD THE ONE
LEGISLATOR THE LEGISLATURE OF
THE PAST SIX YEARS THAT HAS-REALLY CHAMPIONED- THE
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO INVEST IN
THE PORTLAND TAX CREDIT- I
INTRODUCED. A BILL TO DO THAT
EVERY YEAR FIRST. BOB IGER
RESEARCH AND- AND SO I
APPRECIATE AYE I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LEVEL THAT
WE'RE AT- BUT I DON'T THINK ANY
OF US IN THE BAY ANTICIPATED-
THAT THIS WOULD MEAN VERY
LITTLE FUNDING COMING TO OUR
REGION WHICH HAS BEEN GROUND
ZERO FOR. THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND SO- I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT THE REGULATORY
PROCESS I HEARD A LOT OF
CRITICISMS OF THAT REGULATORY
PROCESS I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THAT. AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK- I'M I'M HEARING YOU'RE
WILLING TO HAVE AN ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS- THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
FRUSTRATION. AMONG THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY
AND IN THE BAY AREA AROUND THIS
AND- I HOPE TO NOT HAVE TO
INTRODUCE BILL TO MOVE THIS
CONVERSATION. IN A MORE SERIOUS
HUESO I'D REALLY HOPE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS- WE CAN
GET TO A BETTER SPOT ON THIS
BECAUSE I THINK AT THIS POINT-
THE BAY AREA WE FEEL LIKE
WE'RE- WE'RE PENALIZED- FOR THE
FACT THAT. WE ARE SUCH A HIGH
COST REASON AND BECAUSE WE'RE
HIGH COST REGION WE'RE TRYING
TO INVEST IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT WE'RE NOT GETTING
OUR FAIR SHARE OF RESOURCES
FROM THE STATE ON THAT SO I
JUST WANT TO STATE THAT-
SHIFTING TO A SECOND TOPIC- AND
THIS. GETS TO SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE COLLEAGUES OUR
DISCUSSION FOR AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. WE KNOW THAT
HOUSING PROJECTS. THAT REQUIRE
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH.
ILLNESSES ARE MORE EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD AND STAFF. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE KINDS OF
PROJECTS YOU'RE AWARDING DON'T
REALLY ALIGN WITH THE MORE
EXPENSIVE- PROJECTS THAT THAT
REQUIRE- THAT THE TYPES OF. OF
CARE AND SERVICES FOR- THESE
CHRONICALLY CHALLENGED
INDIVIDUALS AGAIN BECAUSE OF
THE COST FACTOR THAT YOU'RE
GOING AFTER I. WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COMMENT ON THAT YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT- SOMETHING
I THINK WE ALSO MAY HAVE TO
CONSIDER- WELL I WOULD. THE YOU
KNOW WE DO WHO ARE A PART OF
THE REGULATION. THAT ONE OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT WAS ADOPTED
WAS ESTABLISHING. RULES AND SET
ASIDES AND- OF THOSE POLLS THAT
INCLUDED. HOMELESS PROJECTS
AND- HE ALIVE BE ALIVE
PROJECTS. I THINK PROJECTS THAT
FIT. SOME OF THE DESCRIPTION
YOU HAD STATED. IN I THINK. AND
I DON'T HAVE THE PROJECTS BUT
BEFORE ME RIGHT NOW BUT-
OBVIOUSLY I THINK THE GOAL OF
THOSE. SET ASIDES WERE TO
TACKLE THOSE TYPE OF PROJECTS-
LOWER LOWER INCOME. AND
HOMELESS POPULATIONS WHICH- AND
ARE YOU STATING THAT YOU KNOW
BASED ON. YOUR. ARE YOU STAYING
SPECIFICALLY THE BAY AREA. WELL
I CAN. TO THIS IS A BROAD
STATEWIDE CONVERSATION EVEN
WITHIN THOSE PROJECTS IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT DEAL I PROJECTS.
OR OR OR AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS. THERE'S
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOUSING
THAT ADDRESS FOLKS WITH CHRONIC
HOMELESS UP CHRONIC MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. THAT HOUSING IS
MORE EXPENSIVE UNDER YOUR
CURRENT REGULATORY FORMULAS YOU
PRIORITIZE THE PER UNIT COST SO
IT DOESN'T FACTOR IN A KNIFE TO
ALLOW FOR THOSE PROJECTS TO
WIN- TOOK TO WIN IN YOUR
PROCESS SO AGAIN RAISING THE
IMPACT OF THE COST EFFICIENCY I
GET. WE ALL WANT TO SEE COST
EFFICIENCIES BUT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN THERE ARE POLICY
REASONS WHY THE PER UNIT COST
IF WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF A- OF A PERSON
WITH SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH.
ILLNESSES IT'LL JUST BE MORE
EXPENSIVE AND SO AGAIN TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND HOW YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT BALANCING THOSE
POLICY IMPERATIVES. YEAH AN AND
WE ARE HAVING DISCUSSIONS AND
WE ARE LOOKING AT IT AND SEEING
WHAT THE POLICY OUTCOMES ARE-
YOU KNOW WE WILL YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE LOOKING AT IT
AND- WELL WE WILL ADDRESS IT AS
SOON AND- WHEN WE DO THIS COULD
I COULD I GET AN UPDATE AND
MAYBE IN IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS
COULD YOUR OFFICE. GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON. MY PERSPECTIVE ON
THE BAY AREA AS WELL AS- ON HOW
WE'RE ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE
MORE CHRONICALLY- THE SET THESE
CHRONIC. BECAUSE UP OKAY- WORD
AND DISCUSSIONS WILL GET BACK
TO YOU AND I REALLY WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE CYCLE WE'RE GOING
TO APPROVE ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION WE HAVE SOME GOOD
ANSWERS ON THIS. OKAY AND ONE
FINAL QUESTION HAS THERE BEEN
DISCUSSION ABOUT GIVING TO CAC
THE AUTHORITY TO DEPLOY THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND STATE CREDITS WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS YEAR IN EITHER THE
4% OR THE 9% FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS IN YEARS WHEN TAX
EXEMPT BONDS ARE COMPETITIVE- I
THINK I'VE I'VE HEARD. I'VE
HEARD DISCUSSION ON THAT AND I
THINK- THE THOUGHT PROCESS
BEHIND THAT WAS THAT. D. IN THE
CREDITS IF THE CREDITS IF
THERE'S ENOUGH PROJECTS TO
FULLY UTILIZE THE FEDERAL
CREDIT ON THE 4% SITE- AND THE
BONDS- BECAUSE THAT WAS THE
WHOLE ISSUE RIGHT. OF THE-
BOBCAT WAS NOT BEING USED-
ASSUMING THAT I THINK-
PROVIDING AUTHORITY TO THE
HOUSING AGENCY COULD BE COULD
BE A- HOPSIN- HOWEVER YOU KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THERE IS
A SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF STATE
CREDITS MADE AVAILABLE 29%
PROJECTS AND- IT WOULD
ESTABLISH PROBABLY BIGGER POTS
I GUESS. FOR THE 9% PROJECTS IF
THOSE WERE MADE AVAILABLE BUT I
WOULD HAVE. TO PROBABLY BE DONE
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
WHICH. AND FOR COLLEAGUES YOU
KNOW STATE LAW PROHIBITS THE
USE OF 4% STATE TAX CREDITS-
WITH 9% CREDITS- AND I THINK
THE IDEA THAT GIVING TO CAP THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW THE STATE
TAX RATE IS TO BE PAIRED. WITH
9% COULD HELP BETTER LEVERAGE
THESE CREDIT SO- AGAIN WHY
DON'T LET'S YOU KNOW WHAT I
WANT WHAT I THINK WHAT I'D
SUGGEST IS IF MY OFFICE IF WE
COULD HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
YOU. AND YOUR OFFICE ON ON
THESE THREE ISSUES IN THE
COMING WEEKS- BEFORE- WE HAVE
TO MAKE SOME FINAL BUDGET VOTES
ON THIS- I'D APPRECIATE THAT.
YES OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
THANKS MANAGER THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT TWO I WOULD
ALSO JUST ADD- MISTER CO I
THINK- THE COMMON SIDE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN FRANCISCO
RELATED TO THE BAY AREA IS A
REALLY A SHARED SENTIMENT IN
TERMS OF GETTING INFORMATION
THAT'S RELATABLE TO THE
DISTRICTS THAT WE REPRESENT. SO
IF THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT
YOU CAN PROVIDE DATA AS THEY
REQUESTED TO OTHER FOLKS THAT
HAVE BEEN PART OF THE HEARING
FOR TODAY THAT'S- MORE
RELATABLE IN TERMS OF REGIONS
AND SPECIFICALLY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS WHERE THE WHERE THE
FUNDS ARE GOING TO THAT WOULD
BE VERY HELPFUL FOR US TO
DETERMINE WHERE- MORE FUNDING
IS NEEDED AS WELL AS- A
RESOURCES- THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR- ACROSS THE STATE
AND FOR THE MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY SO. IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO DO WE
WOULD ALSO JUST BE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE AND BE ABLE TO SEE
THE DATA AND IN A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY BENEFITS OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE NEED SENT
TO LOOK GREAT THANK YOU NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE WE CAN MOVE ON
AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR BEING A PART OF
THAT AND AGAIN MISS ROBLESS-
WELCOME TO US OF FOR. HE YOU'RE
WELCOME LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE DEPARTMENT
AFFAIR DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ISSUE
NUMBER NINE IS RELATED TO
HOUSING EQUITY AND OUTREACH AND
ENFORCEMENT WE'LL START WITH MR
MILLER. WITHOUT OBJECTION YOU
HEAR ME WELL WE CAN HEAR YOU
YES PLEASE CONTINUE. AFTER
MADAM CHAIRMAN DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MIKE MILLER
ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES. BERMAN
A FAIR PLAYING AND HOUSING. OUR
FIRST REQUEST ADDRESSES THE
DEPARTMENTS HOUSING EQUITY
REACHED ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
GIVE YOU TO REQUEST TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING.
ANY POSITIONS TO EXPAND THE
DEPARTMENT'S MULTILINGUAL
EDUCATION TRAINING EFFORTS. TO
REDUCE DISCRIMINATION IN
HOUSING EMPLOYMENT. BUT WITH
THEIR HOUSING TESTING PROGRAM
AND ATTENDED ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITY. STUDY HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION AMID COVERED
NINETEEN. EVERYBODY THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND OTHER AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. WITH FINAL
EXPERTISE ON LANDLORD TENANT
ISSUES ALL OF WHICH WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN AND THEN
MAKE. IT HAS THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY AND HELP
KEEP CALIFORNIANS HOUSED. AND
EMPLOYED IN THE LONG TERM. THE
LEGISLATURE PREVIOUSLY A THREE
DOLLAR APPROPRIATE TO FEET
NINETY. DEFINE MULTIPLE LIMITED
POSITION WHICH IS CHRIS AND
WORK. WITH MUCH SIX. AND WE
WILL YOUR AND HELP TO CARRY OUT
FORWARD. JOINING ME TODAY IS
VERY WEAK TEACHES CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE ANY. OU MAY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT SAID CONTINUE WITH THE
OF FINE. AND THE L. A. DATE
INCREASE DEPARTMENT UPON IN
ADDITIONAL CALL. THANK YOU. LOL
I AM HERE NO ON THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU I REMEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEN I ALSO HAVE NO
CA ARE FOR THE PART ISSUE. YOU
MUST MILLER YOU GO OFF THE HOOK
FREE QUICKLY SO WE ARE.
APPRECIATIVE THANK YOU. THE OUR
SECOND PROPOSAL AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO INTO THE PROPOSED SORRY
ISSUE NUMBER TEN WORK RESOURCES
GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY SOURCE WEEK
ADDRESS WORKLOAD. IMPLEMENT
BILLS THAT WERE ENACTED TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY IF YOU REQUEST
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND THREE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS CHEN FUND INTO
TWO TO THREE IN OUR GOING. AND
TWENTY FOUR TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES YOU CAN THE- HELLO
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT PROTECTS FOR
SMALL SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
INITIATED HIGH PROGRAM PURSUANT
TO EIGHTEEN SIX SEVEN. AND OF
COURSE HEALTH DEEP PAY I
INCREASE ARCHIE AND FIRST TO
COLLECT SECURE AND ANALYZED HE
DID A RISK PERSON TO ASK NINE
SEVENTY. AND AGAIN JACQUI CHEAP
VERY WEAK I AM HAPPY ANSWER.
THANK YOU WILL GO WITH. OUR
OFFICE A THE PERMANENT. PLACED
MR CHRIS. INCREASE DEPARTMENT
OF FINE THANK YOU I WHICH IS
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS REQUEST
PROVIDES IMPORTANT TO WITH.
IMPLEMENTING THE PAY FAMILY
EXPAND AS WELL AS PAY DAY AS A
BY. A COLLECTION AND THAT WOULD
BE OF HELPFUL GIVE THE FACT
THIS COULD BE TO ANY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AN THE REQUEST IS TO
BY THE RECORD THANK. HELLO
MORELLA LEO WE HAVE NO ON THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT SENIOR I ALSO HAVE KNOWN
COM ARE. SO JUST FOLLOW UP WITH
MY OWN COMMENT MISTER MILLER
OFF THE HOOK. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD WITH ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN RELATED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCING ISSUE
ELEVEN IS THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BACK FILL. MISTER HILL- CRYSTAL
PARTNER FINANCE- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
PROVIDE TEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO- SAN
MATEO COUNTY INTO THE CITY IS
LOCATED THERE IN. TO ENSURE
THEIR- FULLY BACK FILLED FOR
THE ON VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUE THEY LOST AS A RESULT
OF THE ON. THE VEHICLE LICENSE
FEE RATE GOING 2% TO ZERO POINT
65% TYPICALLY THE WAY THESE
BACK. TO WORKERS THAT- MONEY
THAT THE LITTLE PAN EDGE
REVENUE. FUNDS WERE TO THEM TO
BACK FOR BUILDER YOU'LL LICENSE
BE REVENUE LOSSES. AND A MONIES
THE THEN PARKING RATE TO READER
FROM. K. THROUGH TWELVE. TO THE
CITY'S INTO THE CAL. BUT IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY ATTORNEY UNIX A-
WHERE THERE'S NO ENOUGH BY IN
THERE GIVE. IT ROBONAUT MEANT
THOUGHT UNTIL THREE AM THE. AND
ALSO THE SCHOOL. WASN'T THE
STRIP I'M SYNDICATE I'M SORRY.
IT WILL BE DIFFERENT FROM THEM
TO SEE WHAT EVERYONE THOUGHT
ONE ONE MOMENT WANT MISTER.
FOUND LIKE A AUCTIONEER FOR A
MINUTE OF WE LOST YOU FOR LIKE
OF MAYBE ABOUT A OR SO WHEN
YOU'RE- OKAY. BRIEFLY FROM
STALL AGAIN WE'RE PROPOSED TO
POINT ONE MILLION- TO RE-
SAMITY COUNTY AND THE CITY IS
LOCATED THERE IN. FOR THE ON
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUE- MONIES THAT THEY- BUT
OTHERWISE- BE ABLETO MAKE UP
TO REIMBURSE THEMSELVES FOR
FROM THE EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION BROWN AND FROM
REDIRECTING PROPERTY TAX FROM
THE- SCHOOLS I'M- HAPPY TO-
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL DETAILS OF
MEMBERS MAY. L. OFFICE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR HELL
I'M ASKING TO TURN OFF YOUR
CAMERA AS A THEME LIKE YOU'RE
IS TRYING TO UP THE VIDEO. SO
THAT WE DON'T LOSE YOU- FOR ANY
FOR. FURTHER COMMENTS OF LET'S
GO WITH THIS ONE ALL THIS WITH
L. A. L. YEAH I MEAN WE HAVE NO
COMMENT ON THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE I DON'T
HAVE ANY EITHER WE CAN MOVE
THANK YOU MISTER HILL WE CAN
MOVE ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE. THIS IS RELATED TO
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES-
FUNDED FUNDED AND SUSPENDED
MANDATES WE CAN BEGIN WITH.
MISPERTON THOMPSON. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRITNEY THOMPSON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MANDATE
FUNDING IS ADJUSTED EVERY YEAR
BASED ON ACTUAL CLAIMS THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TO FINE AND
SUSPEND THE SAME MANDATES AS
LAST YEAR WITH THE ADDITION OF
ONE NEW MANDATE THAT WAS
RECENTLY FOUND TO BE
REIMBURSABLE. THIS ISFIVE
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR THE EACE OFFICER
TRAINING IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
CRISIS INTERVENTION MANDATE.
THIS MANDATE REQUIRES FIELD
TRAINING OFFICERS TO TAKE EIGHT
HOUR TRAINING COURSE ON CRISIS
INTERVENTION IN BEHAVIOR
HEALTH. SO IN TOTAL FORTY SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION IS PROPOSED
FOR THE FIVE. FOR THE FUNDED
MANDATES OF WHICH FORTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION THE GENERAL
FUND. EBITDA TAKING WHAT. THANK
YOU FOR THAT TO THE MEMBERS
ACTUALLY LET'S GO TO THE OHIO
PLEASE. THE ALEJO OUR OFFICE IS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORT ON
YOU CAN BE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
WHETHER SHOULD BE FUNDED REPEAL
SYSTEM AND THAT I'M AFTER OF
THE NEW TALKS TRAINING MANDATE
WHICH RECOMMEND FUNDING IT DOES
FOR. ON OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LOW
LOCAL TO IMPLEMENT I RECENTLY
OPERATES LET'S TO PROVIDE TO BE
DOCTORS TO AFFECTIVELY UNITED
AND RESPOND IN THIS WAY
INDIVIDUAL WITH HEALTH ISSUES
INTELLECTUAL DISORDERS OR
SOMETHING USE TO ESCALATE THAT.
FROM HAPPENING AGAIN QUESTION
THANK YOU. THANK FOR THAT MISS
MORAL- ANY OF COMMENTS ARE FROM
THE COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT
FIFTEEN NON I WANT TO THANK YOU
BOTH FOR THAT AND WE CAN
CONTINUE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTEEN AS WE FINALIZE AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING THIS IS
RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE ISSUE THIRTEEN
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE.
BUDGET PROPOSALS MR MCARTHUR
PLACE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MARCUS MACARTHUR AND
THE CHIEF DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
OF THE DEPARTMENT REAL ESTATE
AND I WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
MOST RECENT BTP. REQUEST
PURPOSE CLEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND I'M GOING FROM
THE REALISTIC FUN. THIS FUNDING
WOULD BE FOR ONE TERMINATE
SENIOR ACCOUNTING OFFICER
POSITION AND ONE TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM ACCOUNTING OFFICER
POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
ACCOUNTING ACTIVITIES AND OUR
PHYSICAL OFFICE- THIS CONCLUDES
MY REMARKS ON THIS TOPIC I'LL
BE HAPPY TO. ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
WILL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. CAN'T FIND A PERMANENT
FINANCE NO DISAPPOINTMENTS.
THANK YOU LOL. SORT OF BORED
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DID NOT RAISE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE UP
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HELLO
WELCOME BACK TO TWELVE YEAH
OKAY IF THE LIMIT MAKE A QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR MINUTES-
BRITNEY TOM OF FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE WE MAY HAVE TO
COME BACK TO YOU IN JUST A
MOMENT WHEN WE'RE DONE WITH
ISSUE THIRTEEN. A SURE THING
MISTER COOPER. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THIS THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE- THIS
QUESTIONS ON THE CALL ON THE
WORKLOAD B. C. P. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE ARE
VACANCIES IN THIS UNIT WHEN THE
CALL WORKLOAD DECREASED BY
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND BUT- THE
WAIT TIME INCREASED BY ONE
MINUTE HOW MANY VACANCIES
VACANCIES OR THEIR WHAT IS THE
CURRENT NUMBER OF VACANCIES. IF
THESE VACANCIES ARE FILLED HOW
LONG WILL THE WAIT TIME BE.
MADAM CHAIR I TOOK IT IN TWO
SEPARATE PARTS BECAUSE WE HAD
TO REQUEST I CAN JUST FINISH
HAVE TAKEN PART IN THAT. THAT
MAY ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. RIGHT
OKAY SO ON THE SECOND PART OF
OUR BTP REQUESTED APARTMENT IS
REQUESTING. FOUR HUNDRED
FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
FUNDING. FROM THE REAL ESTATE
FUND. AND WE'RE REQUESTING
SPECIFICALLY FIVE. PROGRAM
TECHNICIAN TO SUPPORT THE
LICENSING PROGRAM. INFORMATION
SINCE SECTION. JUST FOR YOUR
INFORMATION THE DEPARTMENT HAS
TAKEN VARIOUS STEPS. TO
MITIGATE ANY ADDITIONAL
INCREASES IN CALI TIMES. SUCH
AS UPDATES TO OUR LICENSING
FAQS WE'VE REDIRECTED LICENSING
STAFF TO ANSWER CALLS. WE'VE
ALSO ESTABLISHED A SEPARATE
EMAIL ACCOUNT. TO BOTH RECEIVE.
AND REPLY TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GENERAL PUBLIC- THE REQUESTED
STAFF WILL PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
STAFFING NECESSARY TO HELP
MANAGE. THE HIGH CALDWELL CALL
VOLUMES. AND ACCEPT THE CALL
WAIT TIMES THAT. ARE MORE
LICENSING PROGRAM. THANK YOU IN
HOW THE DEPARTMENT EXPLORED
OTHER WAYS OF REDUCING THE CALL
WORKLOADS SUCH AS UPDATING
PERHAPS YOUR FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS. TO REFLECT THE MOST
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON. OF COURSE
SO AGAIN WE'VE WE'VE UPDATED
CENTER UPDATED OUR FAQS- TO THE
SCOPING PERIOD WE'VE READ
DIRECTED LIKE HITTING STAFF TO
HELP GET THE CALLS WHEN THE
CALL- BACKLOG GETS TOO HIGH.
WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISHED A
SEPARATE EMAIL ACCOUNTS THAT
ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO ANOTHER
AVENUE TO GET THE QUESTION THE
RATS. GET THEIR QUESTIONS
ANSWERED BY DEARIE TAP SO
WE'VE- ATTEMPTED TO. MITIGATE
AS MUCH AS WE CAN BY ALLOWING
THE PUBLIC TO GET THAT QUESTION
ANSWERED- OTHER WAYS BESIDES
SITTING ON THE PHONE AND
WAITING FOR SOMEONE TO ANSWER.
THANK YOU AND I AM LET ME
APOLOGIZE IF YOU ANSWERED THIS-
DID YOU TELL ME WHAT IS THE
CURRENT. NUMBER WHAT ARE THE
CURRENT NUMBER OF VACANCIES. I
CAN DO MOMENT MICHAEL JEFF-
PLEASE GIVE. PRESENT LICENSING
MANAGER ON THE LINE HE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO ANSWER CALL. OKAY
QUESTIONABLE. THAT IS MADAM
CHAIR YES WE CAN YOU GOING. A
END IN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I JUST WANT YOU KNOW HOW OF J.
FOR. TWENTY ONE AND WE HAVE
FIVE VACANT POSITIONS AND THE
LICENSING PROGRAM THREE OF
WHICH WERE WITHIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND CURRENTLY
WE HAVE TO BE CONCEDES IN THE
ABOUT SECTION AS OF TODAY.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU FOR THAT.
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS I THINK WE ARE. DONE
WITH THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING A
PART OF THE PANEL ON THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE.
MISTER COOPER. THE THANK YOU
FOR INDULGING JEWEL I PER I WAS
DOING SOMETHING ELSE- FOR
NUMBER FOR CAN PROVIDE MORE
FROM ON THIS ACTUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS SUSPENDED MANDATE. I
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
READY READILY AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW OTHER THAN THE COST OF
THAT'S PROVIDED IN THE GENDER.
BUT I CAN GET THAT INFORMATION
AND GET BACK TO YOUR STAFF WHAT
SPECIFICALLY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
KNOW ABOUT THE MANDATE. WHAT IS
BEING SUSPENDED CORRECT IS NOT
BEING FUNDED. CORRECT BUT THESE
ARE THE SAME SUSPENDED MANDATES
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET OR THIS YEAR'S
CURRENT TWENTY FOUR BUDGET AND
THE REASON I ASK THAT IS IN IN
SACRAMENTO WERE SEEN BEGINNING
ARE MORE THAN OUR SHARE OF A-
SOCIALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS
LOCATED HERE ONE GOAL. ANOTHER
ONE SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WHAT WAS
DISTURBING IS NEITHER ONE IS
INDIVIDUALS- AT WERE RIGOROUSLY
COMMITTEE FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THEY HAVE NO- CONNECTION
THIS COUNTY WHATSOEVER. SO THAT
THAT'S THAT'S THE REASON I ASK
THAT. OKAY I CAN GET THE
DETAILS OF THAT MANDATE
INCLUDING THE YEAR THAT IT WAS
DECIDED TO BE SUSPENDED GET
THEIR TO YOUR STAFF OKAY THANK
YOU. BUT MANAGER. YEP THANK YOU
MISTER COOK MISTER COOPER. AND
HER THANK YOU WITH MISS
THOMPSON FOR REJOINING AYE
FINANCE THAT A PRE- THAT THE
INTO AS WELL AS INFORMATION TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE ARE DONE
WITH OUR ISSUES WE ARE NOW
GOING TO HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE.
IN THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM THAT
WISH TO SPEAK THEY MEAN OUR
HAND AND ALLOW TO A PRO MICHAEL-
I WOULD ASK THAT THE- RESPECT
FOR THE COLDEST. IN NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE YOU'LL HAVE ONE
MAY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
LET'S OPERATOR LET'S BE. THANK
YOU FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE TWO ZERO. AND EFFORT
pPUBLIC COMMENT WILL COME FROM
NINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS ZACH
WE WANNA PUBLIC AFFAIRS OF THE
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER A
MEMBER OF THE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION. I SPEAK TODAY
TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE AN ONGOING SOCIAL
PLASTIC THE HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS IF YOU'RE BUDGET. FOR
TOO LONG CALIFORNIA'S ATTEMPTED
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IS ONE
TIME FUNDING IT PIECEMEAL
PROGRAMS SOME OF WHICH I
PROJECT COUNTY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THE REASON STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT ON
HOMELESSNESS MADE IT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THAT THIS APPROACH HAS
WORKED WE NEED PERMANENT
ONGOING SOLUTIONS. AB SEVENTY
ONE INCLUDES STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS TOLD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR MEETING OUTCOMES IN LINE
WITH THEIR NEEDS AND GAPS
SOUTHEAST AND DOESN'T RAISE
TAXES ON SMALL BUSINESSES OR
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIA. WITH
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ON HOW CALIFORNIANS BILLIONS
DANGEROUSLY IN THE MARKET EVEN
PRIOR TO THE ONSET OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE HAVE TO
TAKE BOLD ACTION NOW IMPACT THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COLLISIONS LEGISLATION AB
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A-
OF PEOPLE WAITING IN PUBLIC.
AND I WILL OUT THAT YOU ARE
FROM. THE SAME COALITION THAT
YOU STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. BY WHERE
YOU'RE CALLING FROM PLEASE. AND
WE KEEP IT- MOVING AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE SO THAT WE CAN GET
TO AS MANY PEOPLE ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR COULD PLEASE
CONTINUE. GIVEN OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COME- COME FROM ONE FIFTY TWO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARLIN
THERE PRIOR. I MEAN I'M
CLICKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY WHAT. I'M TO SEE IF
THEY SPEAK UP ADVOCATE. AND ONE
SEMESTER WITH THE SENATE. PLAN
TO HAVE THIS. CAN LEAD IN SOME
SPOTS WAY TO THE- BC I'VE BEEN
QUITE HOMELESS FOR. PERIODS
FROM MY DOG LIFETIME. STORY
BEGIN TODAY TO YEARS OF WITH
BILL NO BEING A- WITH MY
THOUGHTS. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
TWO THE CENTER IN HOLLYWOOD. I
RECEIVED A CORD YOU'VE BEEN
SYSTEM MATTER. BUT CLINTON IN
TWO SHELF PLUS CARE INITIATIVE.
IN CAR OKAY. AFFRONT NEARLY
FIVE BE SINCE BEING HOW I HAVE
A- THERAPIST M. C. K. IN MARIN
BILLS. BE GOOD QUALITY OF. AND
DRUG FREE EXCEPT WHAT'S THIS.
IN ATTENDING CATION PROGRAM A
NEW CAREER I BACK TO
OPPORTUNITY SUCH AS- HUMBLY
REQUEST COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTY
Y. IT IS BOTH THE HUMANE AND
SOME APPROACH TOWARD REALIZING
THE VISION AND RESTORE OF THEIR-
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU FOR
THAT IN A PRE- THE STORE AND SO.
FOR THOSE FOR THOSE OF YOU ON
THE I WILL SAY THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF. WAIT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND IT WOULD BE REALLY HOW. IF
CAN HELP GET THROUGH ALL THE
THAT ARE FOR COM IF YOU CAN
YOU'RE- WHERE YOU'RE- FROM AND
IF YOU'RE- INTO. OF A SEVENTY
ONE- SUPPORTER OPPOSITION- WITH
THE BILL THIS IS SUFFICIENT SO
THAT WE KEEP THE LINES MOVING.
OPERATOR PLEASE CONTINUE.
YOU'RE NEVER COME FROM LINE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- WE AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A DEDICATED
REVENUE SOURCE TO PROVIDE
ONGOING FUNDING TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS. WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT THE COMMITTEE CAN PASS THE
CONTENTS OF THE POLICY IN AB
SEVENTY ONE TO GENERATE
RESOURCES FOR THAT PURPOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR THANK YOU EXCITABLE.
COME FROM SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU CAN LIVE
WITH REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND CHILDREN NOW NOT AFTER AT
AND CHILD POVERTY CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT OF MY COMMENT ON ISSUE
ONE AND SEVEN WE'RE SUPPORTIVE
OF INCREASING INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND THANK THE
CHAIRMAN OF QUESTIONS AROUND.
YOU THINK THEY'RE BEEN HOME CAN
ARE EAGER TO SEE THE DATA FROM
H. B. D. WE NEVER YOU HOME THAT
HAVE WAY TO MCMATH AND THE
CONTINUE HONORED BY IN THE
PROGRAM MEANS THAT WE DON'T GET
OF THE LARGER HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES. AID AND DEVELOPMENT
APPROPRIATE PROGRAMS FOR YOUTH
ARE CRITICAL WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO HAVE A HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME DEDICATED
CREEK UNIT THE TYPICALLY FOR
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH
KERN A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
JUSTICE INVOLVED HERE. WE
CONTINUE TO BROWN FUNDING
HOMELESS WHAT THE 5% SATISFIED
FOR YEARS BUT HAS BEEN A IN TO
OUR YOUNG. AND ARE DIFFERENT
NEED A LEADER I IMAGINE ANY
MORE TO THAN CHAU OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE ONE NIGHT ON STREET
BELOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND AGAIN. I JUST ASK I
WANT TO BE AS- TO EVERYONE ON
THE- BUT DO HAVE LOT OF
WAITING IF YOU CAN BE ESTAS. AS
POSS. YOUR ORGANIZATION REGION
AND OUR POSITION IS SUFFICIENT
THANK YOU. OPERATOR. YOU'RE THE
NEXT LINE WILL BECOME PROMINENT
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANNA
JOHNSON WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YEARS WE ARE
CALLING TO REQUEST THAT A
MINIMUM OF 10% OF THE STATE'S
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SPENDING ON HOMELESS
INCLUDING HONKY. BE DEDICATED
TO ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
AMONG YOUTH- WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF IT AS AB SEVENTY ONE
AND THE COMPANION BUDGET THERE-
WE DO HAVE I REQUEST THAT 10%
OF HOME KEY FUNDING IS SET
ASIDE FOR A PRIORITY PERIOD
DURING WHICH THE FUNDING WOULD
BE RESERVED FOR PROJECTS.
APPLYING TO THIRTIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
SPECIFICALLY- IN THE MANNER
THAT IT WAS DONE AND WE ALSO
SEE THAT YOU SATISFIED TO WORK
WITH 5% YOU SATISFIED IN THE
KEEP PROGRAM THAT WAS MENTIONED
ON TODAY'S HEARING.
JURISDICTIONS BUT MORE THAN
THAT ADDRESSING YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS BUT WHEN THERE'S
NOT ARE YOU SATISFIED IN OUR
FUNDING STREAMS- WE SEE THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO NOT BE SERVED-
SO THAT IS OUR POSITION AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT AND- AB SEVENTY ONE AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO PLEASE. EDEKA FROM NINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY IS MATT
JOHN. AND ARE YOU WITH THE
UNITED NETWORK WITH OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. A MEMBER OF THE BAY.
A MEMBER OF THE OUTBACK. HELLO
COALITION AND- IN MY LIFE I'VE
BEEN CHRONIC HOMELESS. AND JUST
THREE ONLY A AGO I GOT MY OWN
PERMANENT ROLE IN HOUSING SO
FAR- URGES THE KCA. TO AN IN
FONG FUNDING FOR ALMOST. WAS
THIS PROGRAM AND IF YOU'RE I'M
FROM THE CITY OAKLAND AND I'M
STANDING FOR- AB SEVENTY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THEN ONE
WILL COME FOR NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE OF THE- HI GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS A-
BERRIES A FORMER TRUSTEE. AND
MUST SAY THAT YOU NEED A PERMIT
SOLUTION THE 10% SATISFIED AB
ONE FOR THE CALL TO GET THE-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. TO I
STRUGGLE URGES THE- THANK YOU.
MEXICAN ONE HUNDRED LINE OF
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON- COMMITTEE
MEMBER ALEX THE STOCK FROM A
LOT ANGELES HOME SERVICE OF
CALLING AS WELL AS PART OF THE
BRAIN CALIFORNIA HOME A
COALITION TO SUPPORT AB SEVENTY
ONE AND THE COMPANION BUDGET
ASK AWKWARD TO BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ONGOING
FUNDING. TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CAN GO ONLINE A
LOT OF THREE I WILL JUST SAY IF
YOU ARE CALLING FROM THE LARGER
COALITION BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME. YOU CAN STATE YOUR
LOCATION AND VISIT YOUR NAME
LOCATION A POSITION IS
SUFFICIENT THANK YOU WE I JUST
WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
EVERYONE THAT'S ON HOLD THAT
SHOULD GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
TO A STATE THEIR POSITION THANK
YOU. OPERATOR YOU'LL NEVER COME
FROM ONE ONE ALL THREE LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ZACH SCHLEGEL REPRESENTING
PATH PEOPLE WITHIN THE
HOMELESS. IT'S GOING TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE CORPORATE YOU
SEVENTY ONE BUT ONE OF THE
STATE'S LARGEST HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS WE KNOW THAT
TRUE PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING
HOME WITH WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE
WITHOUT OR ONGOING INVESTMENT
FROM THE STATE. BOTH WELL
INTENTIONED TO HAVE. ONGOING
FUNDING RATE IT CANNOT WORK
CANNOT A RELIANT A ONE TIME
FUNDING AND PILOT PROGRAMS
ONLY. IF YOU JUST LOOK FOR AB
SEVENTY ONE THE COMPANION
BUDGET REQUESTS FOR THE TRULY
TACKLE THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT I LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
WITH FOLKS ON THE LINE WE HAVE
A. LOT OF PEOPLE WAITING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND SO I TO BE
RISK. OF A- TIME ALL WE KNEW.
IS YOUR NAME. LOCATION AND
POSITION. THERE'S NO NEED GO
INTO DETAILS OF THE BILL- WE
WANT TO BE. MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET TO AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU PLEASE CONTINUE OPERATOR
AND I WILL- FROM THE LINE OF
ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JENNY
ABOUT VOCAL CRIMES AND I
VOLUNTEER WITH THE PLAY FOR
HOUSTON LEFT SIDE BOX ANGELES.
I SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE. YOU THAT
WAS EXACT RIGHT PER WE REALLY A-
SO THAT WE CAN GET TO AS MANY
CALLS AS POSSIBLE. GEN X. FIVE
COMFORT ONE TO FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU I MEAN WITH OUR DELTA
THE PRO OF MARRIAGE. THREE CAP
PRESS WE SUPPORT A PEACE ONE
THERE IS A MISSION ON- AND-
DIVORCE GONNA CUT YOU OFF RIGHT
THERE ONLY DOING WE'RE ONLY
DOING POSITIONS OF SUPPORTOR
OPPOSITION NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YOU'LL NEVER BE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS. STILL
YOUR CUNNINGHAM I'M CALLING
FROM OPEN CALIFORNIA. I'M WITH
DOCTOR VERY EAST BAY HOW OLD
ARE. AND THAT'S THE PASSED THE
BILL SO ONE PLEASE HELP US GET
THAT BILL PASSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU CALLER PLEASE. AND
COME FROM WIND NINETY YOUR LINE
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS DAMIEN
SCOTT ALSO WITH WHICH HELPING
ORGANIZATIONS I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU AND NEXT
LINE WILL COULD BE FROM THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
THIS IS MARK STIVERS THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
I'M CALLING ON A SEPARATE ISSUE
I'M SUPPORTING THE- THE BUT
GOVERNMENT BUDGET REQUESTS THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT SO THE ISSUE
EIGHT. I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS
SUGGESTED BY ASSUMING CHIU TO
ALLOW THE ADDITIONAL STATE
GRANTS TO BE ADMINISTERED
EITHER WITH THE 4% OR NINE
PERCENT. FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I DON'T
COMPROMISED ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME THE REMAINING MONTHS OF
THE YEAR  BELIEVE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA. I SUPPORT- THE WORK
BUT EAST BAY AS GOING TO CHURCH
AND THE ACTUAL THE AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK. THANK YOU. AND I
FILE COME FROM ONE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARKET CARRERO REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AND WE ARE ALSO A
CO SPONSOR OF BRINGING
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION AND-
WE ALSO SUPPORT PROJECT HOME
KEEP FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DOING. THANK YOU LET'S
KEEP MOVING BUT ALSO OPERATOR
WHAT. YEAH BETTER COME FROM ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JULIE SNYDER
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE
FOCUSED ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE POLICY WE ARE A
CO SPONSOR OF AB SEVENTY ONE
AND URGE YOU TO INCLUDE ITS
ONGOING FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT PRIME BE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI AUDREY
RETIRED ON BEHALF OF HIM CAN
AND OF ISSUE ELEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THAT'LL COME
FROM NEXT FINAL COME FROM FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS KEREN ERRORS THAT THE
E. Y. R. YES I'M FROM THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
AND L. A. COUNTY AND WE SUPPORT
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PREVENTING AND REDUCING
FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I FINAL COME FROM ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JANE SCHROEDER
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST
PAGE FOR YOU NUMBER HERE TO
STRONG SUPPORT THE EIGHTEEN
POINT TWO. DOLLAR PREVENTING
AND REDUCING FOSTER YOU
COMMITMENTS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU AND THEN I FIND WILL
BE WIND ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN BEHALF OF
COLLEAGUES AT IRVINE COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
RELATIVE TO ISSUE ONE ON
TODAY'S AGENDA WE'D LIKE TO
EXPAND OUR GENERAL SUPPORT FOR
ADDITIONAL STATE INVESTMENT IN
HOMELESSNESS. THEY TOOK THE
PANDEMIC COUNTY STEPPED UP AND
COMPETED FOR PREVIOUS ROUND THE
PROJECT HUNKY FUNDS AND WE
BELIEVE HOMES WAS A GOOD AN
EXPEDIENT USE OF FACULTY R. F.
RESOURCES WITH LIMITED
FLEXIBILITY IN A STRICT
EXPENDITURE DEADLINE. BARBARA
COUNTY HAVE ALSO DEPLOYED MULTI
FACETED APPROACHES TO REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING OR START
UTILIZING SEAT AND HAPPEN. WITH
MORE FLEXIBLE FUNDING SOURCES
LIKE GENERAL FUND COUNTY
SUPPORT STRUCTURE IN THE
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL THAT
PASSES SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITY
TO COUNTY. BUT I THINK WE
UNDERSTAND THE STATE'S
RELUCTANT TO COMMIT TO ONGOING
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING BUT YOU
CAN COUNTY BUDGET PUBLIC
GOODNESS WE CAN'T BUT- AND WE
WANT TO SURE THAT. ARE OVERCOME
TO ON COSTS FACTOR ONE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT
FIVE COME FROM ONE TWENTY THREE
OF THE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
AND COMMUNITY THANK YOU FOR
THIS. TO SPEAK NAME IS GOOD ONE
I'M WITH THE TO NAY AT HOW
CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF THE
BRING CAL HOME. AND A MEMBER OF
THE OF PROGRAM WITH HOPES OF.
HERE INCOME COSTA. I'M CALLING
IN SICK OF THIS BILL ONE
BECAUSE THAT THIS HEARING HAS
REFLECTED THERE IS A REAL NEED
FOR A LONG TERM SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. I URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO AND FUND FROM
SO. FROM HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM
IN THE YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU
I'M GETTING. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE AND AGAIN. FOR ALL THOSE
THAT ARE. FOR PER COMMENT IF
YOU CAN JUST SIMPLY SAY YOUR
NAME YOUR LOCATION AND YOUR
POSITION AFTER CALLING ON AB
SEVENTY ONE. GIVEN THE NEXT
FINAL COME FROM ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI NECRO
LOBBY APPLE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS ELEVEN THANK
YOU CAN. THE SHAPE THE PARTNER
WITH THE LEAD. AND PUNISHMENT
MEDICAL EMPLOYED THANK. THANK
YOU AND I FIND WILL COME FROM
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JORDAN
CRIMES ON THE RESIDENT SAN
MATEO AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY TWO. AS WELL AS
POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF PENINSULA
YOUNG DEMOCRATS HERE TO SHARE A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF ITEM THREE-
IN THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
UNIT AS WELL AS AB SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND OUR
NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI AMY
JOSEPH A CO PRESIDENT OF
RIVIERA HOMEOWNERS AND MEMBER
OF UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AND ON A DIFFERENT
TOPIC. IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE
WHILE SOME SENATORS CREATE EVER
MORE TOXIC ZONING BILLS THAT
PRETEND TO BE CONCERNED WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WHEN ALL
THIS WILL ACTUALLY DO IS GIVE A
GLIDE PATH FOR DEVELOPERS TO
INCREASE PROFITS BY JAMMING FOR
SIX EIGHT EVEN TEN MARKET RATE
FOR LUXURY UNITS ONTO A SMALL
SINGLE FAMILY POT. IN A STABLE
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS
RATHER THAN BUDGET DESPERATELY
NEEDED DOLLARS INTO UNFUNDED
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADE OR TO
ACTUALLY FIND TRULY AFFORDABLE
UNITS SOME INSTEAD THINK IT'S A
GRAND IDEA TO WASTE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO MONITOR CITY
MEETINGS. TO MAKE SURE LOCAL
OFFICIALS ACT THE WAY THEY WANT
THEM TO WITH AN ACCOUNTABILITY
AND AT. IF THIS AND- TO FOURTH
LEGISLATURE. THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO FIX A LACK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
DISGRACEFUL THAT THE NEWS MEDIA
ENABLES YOU TO GET AWAY WITH
THIS. WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
UNIT AND T. S. IF THE DISPELLED
MYTHS THAT WERE THREE AND A
HALF MILLION UNITS SHORT PLEASE
CHECK REAL MATHIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT QUESTION
WILL COME FROM ONE PORTING YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU THIS OF JAIL VARADA
WITH THE CITY OF PALM SPRINGS
RAIMES THE DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIX. AND THE
REQUEST FOR A LOAN LOSS RESERVE
FOR THE COACHELLA VALLEY
CATALYST FUND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THEN NEXT LINE WILL COME
FROM LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
HAVE A RESOURCE NAVIGATOR
FORGET THE NEEDS PROJECT IN
PALM SPRINGS ON. TO FORTY
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU. AND
THEN I FINAL COME FROM ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA LEE I AM
A CASA ADVOCATE IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION PREVENTING AND
REDUCING COSTS ARE HOMELESS THE-
OF THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUR NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM
LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BLIND AT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO
YOU HAVE A SON MUTE HELLO.
YELLOWHEAD HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND
RESIDENTS THE VOICE AND MOBILE
HOME PARK WE ASK THE STATE'S
INVESTING NEARLY TO RELOCATE
RESIDENTS IN ADOPTION OF
HOUSING OPTIONS SO THAT WE CAN
RESIDENTS CAN LIVE IN A SAFE
COMMUNITY WITH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT FINAL COME
FROM ONE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS EMERALD
ADVANCE AND I'M WITH SHAPING
AND LET SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I'M A FORMER FOX NEWS AND
CALLING TO REPORT THE EIGHTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
PREVENTING REDUCE AND REDUCING
FOSTER YOUTH AND HOMELESS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
FINAL COME FROM THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
CAESAR SALAD OTHER WITH CLINTON
SERVICES I AM HERE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS PREVENTING
AND REDUCING FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THE NEXT ONE WILL
COME FROM TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THE BIG. CYNICAL
WITH CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION A
COLLEAGUE HERE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS PREVENTING
AND REDUCING POVERTY
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL- WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE CRITICAL FUNDING-
DURING KOBE FOR HOUSING
SUPPORTS KERN FORMER FOX YOUTH
AND SUPPORT. FOR A BEACON ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NECRO
COMPROMISED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY BEING BROKEN COALITION FOR
SAN FRANCISCO SPEAKING ON MY
OWN BEHALF THE COALITION IS
OPPOSING THE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS FOR A HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT ATV ISSUE
NUMBER THREE INSTEAD OF THEIR
THAT THESE FUNDS BE USED FOR
POLITICAL HOUSING NOT
BUREAUCRACY. THE GOVERNOR SPENT
HIS CHILDHOOD IN SAN FRANCISCO
THE CITY HAS KNOWN HIM SINCE HE
WAS JUST ABOUT. IS ALLOCATION
ABOUT THIS. ABOUT ENFORCEMENT
WAS IT REALLY ABOUT THE
CONTINUATION OF RHETORIC FROM
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHEN AS THE TENET GOVERNOR HE
PROPOSED A PLAN FOR HOUSING
BASED ON A FLAWED STUDY BY
MCKINSEY. THEN IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AS GOVERNOR
HE CALLED IT A MARSHALL PLAN.
THEN IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BACKTRACKED ON THE THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION MACKENZIE
HOUSING NUMBER CALLING IT
ASPIRATIONAL. AGAIN USE THESE
FUNDS FOR HOUSING NOT PUROK
RECEIPT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXTERA LINE WILL COME FROM
NINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIND SEVENTEEN YOU ARE WE
ON MUTE. BERMAN BONTA NECK FINE
OF ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS RANDY BOYD- WHEN THEY
HOUSING ORGANIZATION. AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THAT
BADLY ONE. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
ONE WILL COME FROM WIND ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME AT THE
MONTERREY COOLEY I'M CALLING
FROM JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOU I'M HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLAR PREVENTING AND
REDUCING FOSTER YOU COME WITH
THE PROPOSAL WHICH WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING DURING COVERT
FOR HELPING SUPPORT AND IT'S
POPULATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARVIN BARGAINS CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AN ACT OF A LINE OF ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS JUANITA BLACKWELL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LINE TO CARE
GIVERS AND MEMBER OF THE BRING
HOME BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COALITION AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
A ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YES GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SACRAMENTO YOU WILL I'M
WITH THE ENSURING OPPORTUNITY
CAMPAIGN TEN PART IN CONTRA
COSTA AND I'M COMING TO THE
PORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER A LINE OF ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS TOBY MARCIANO I'M
CALLING WITH ABUNDANT HELPING
LOS ANGELES FROM LOS ANGELES
THE REPORT OF ISSUE THREE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT OVER
THE LINE OF ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS KATHLEEN THEM WITH THAT WORK
FOR EVERYONE THE ACTION I'M
CALLING FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY FOUR- IN SUPPORT OF
FUNDING THE CRITICAL WORK AND-
EACH TV- HOW CAN YOU CAN
ABILITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THAT'S A GOOD LINE F ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROBERT TUCHMAN
NUMBER OF SAN FRANCISCO AGAIN
BE I LIVE IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM THREE AND AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU EXCELLENT A LINE OF ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU HAVE A TIME MUTE.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA TAURUS AND
I'M A HUGE ADVOCATE FOR JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YEARS- I
AM ALSO A CURRENT OF FORMER
BASTIA'S AND I WAS CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLAR PREVENTION
AND REDUCING POSH. TO
COMMONSENSE COUPLE. THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT OVER THE LINE OF ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT AT THE CALCULATE FROM NB-
I'M CALLING A STRONG SUPPORT OF
I DO THREE TO HAVE REASON TO
BELIEVE IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT OVER THE LINE A ONE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS. APRIL WITH THE
SACRAMENTO HOUSING ALLIANCE
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I MEMBER
OF THE BRING HOME. BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION
URGING THE CORPORATE AB SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE
OF ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS DOUGLAS LEACH
AND I REPRESENT THE MULTI FAITH
ACTION COALITION IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND I'M URGING
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE
OF ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEBORAH
ARMSTRONG I AM FROM PEPPERDINE
UNIVERSITY LOCATED IN VENTURA
COUNTY MY GOAL OF THAT
FINANCIAL AID ADVISOR AND
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR A FOSTER
HORIZON SCHOLARS PROGRAM ON
CAMPUS. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTING AND REDUCING FOSTER
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN
OCTOBER LINE OF ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
HAVE A SON MILT. OKAY NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE NOT ONE AT
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KRISTIN THEM BUT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND ALSO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION BALLERS LEAVING
AFRICAN AMERICANS. IN THE
CORNER OF AB SEVENTY ONE BEING
AN ONGOING WAY TO JUST ALMOST
NOTHING PARTICULAR ABOUT OF
OTHER OF THE VIOLENCE AND-
FIFTIETH. THANK YOU ANNEX OVER
LINE OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
A- HI YES THIS IS LINDA KELLY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FATHERS
AND MOTHERS WHO CARE IN LOS
ANGELES BOB THANKS AND A BIRD
IN THE SUPPORT OF THREE AND AB
TWO SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND MEXICO LINE A
ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
HENRY HOOKER I LIVE IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT NUMBER TWENTY NINE AND
I'M CALLING AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF SANTA CRUZ GMB. ONLY SUPPORT
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OVER LINE A
ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS YVONNE AND
I'M CALLING WITH INDIAN CAPTAIN
PLANNING PARTNERSHIP. REPORTER
ISSUE THREE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT THANK YOU
HAVE A HAVE A GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE LINE OF
ONE OF SEVENTY SIX. ADD FISCAL
COURT FROM OAKLAND CALL-
CALLING ON BEHALF I MEAN AS A
MEMBER OF THE STATE CAPITOL
AND- ASSEMBLY CALLED THE PORT
OF ISSUE THREE THE HOUSING COME
BILLION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT LINE OF ONE SIXTY YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
TAYLOR I'M CALLING NUMBER
BROKERAGES AND ALSO SEPARATE
THE GARBAGE INDIE- GRANT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINETEEN AND
I'M CALLING TRUMP PART OF ISSUE.
THREE HAVING CREDIBILITY UNIT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN MEXICO
LINE A ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JACKSON PAPER WITH HE- VENTURA
COUNTY IN THE ORGANIZATION. BY
MEN DISTRICT FORTY FOUR TRACK
YOUR RUNS DISTRICT AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
UNITS KEEP. THANK YOU. AN
ACTUAL LINE A ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT I'M SURE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS RYAN CHOI CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BE TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL'S.
CIVICALLY ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NEXAVAR LINE OF ONE SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALLISON
RADIANCE I'M A RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
A MEMBER OF THE BRINK
CALIFORNIA HOME CORRELATION I'M
INSTRUCTABLE ACTIVE AB SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU ANNEX OVER LINE
A ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S TOMMY APTLY AND THAT
RESIDENTS OF ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY THREE AND A MEMBER OF
ABANDONED HOUSING LOS ANGELES
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITEM THREE DAY- THAT HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OF A LINE
OF ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO I'M JOSHUA BLOOM A
COP I MEAN PASADENA DISTRICT
FORTY FORTY ONE ABOUT THE
CALLING AT THE PORT OF ITEM
THREE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT ON THE LINE
OF BY ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI I AM SPEAKING ON
ISSUES ONE AND SEVEN I AM AT-THE COURT IN INCREASING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS SORRY
MY NAME IS CHERYL NOW ITEM FROM
SAN FRANCISCO BACK INTO
SERVICES. AND I APPRECIATE THE
KIND OF QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
COME UP AROUND YOUNG PEOPLE
THIRD GET HOME KEY AND WE'RE
EAGER TO SEE THE DATA. EIGHT TV
ABOUT THAT TWENTY YOU PROJET
FOR YOUTH ARE SERVING WE KNOW
THAT YOU COME WITH THAT THAT
THAT PATHWAY TO CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AND THAT CONTINUED
UNDER INVESTMENT IN YOUTH
PROGRAMS MEANS THAT WE'LL NEVER
GET AHEAD OF THE LARGEST- BUT
THE HOMELESSNESS TOUT
CHALLENGES. WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO HAVE A HUNDRED
MILLION AND ONE TIME DEDICATED
FUNDS FOR HELPING PRIVATE
COMPANIES USE- AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. I'M AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
FUNDING PER 25% BUT IT'S RIGHT
FOR YOU AND ALL- IN IN ALL OF
THE FUNDING ALLOCATIONS OF THE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF. IN
SUPPORT OF. AB. SEVENTY ONE
THANK. THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE
OF FIVE YEAR LINE OF OPEN. WELL
YES JUST RECALL FROM FRANCISCO
WITH CAL. R. EIGHT CD AS GIVEN
THE CITY'S BONDAGE WILL OF
HOUSING NUMBERS BASED ON A
FLAWED METHODOLOGY. THE CITY'S
NEEDS STATE FUNDING IN ORDER TO
MEET THEIR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TARGETS NOT BLAME AND NOT
POLICING- WE HAVE MEMBERS THAT
GO TO LOCAL MEETINGS ALL THE
TIME HAVE THE AND HA YOU
POLICING- PRESENCE IN OUR LOCAL
MEETINGS WILL HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON COMMUNITY DIALOGUE.
WE OPPOSE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF- TWO OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ZACH
BOWLING I'M- CALLING THE B.
ACTION AND I'M RESIDENTS
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTEEN IN
THE BACK. AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE HOUSING
CALENDAR THE UNIT AND EIGHTY
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER A LINE OF TWO OH
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS LAURA I'M CALLING FROM
THE IN THE ACTION AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE THREE
THE CREATION OF A HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT. IF THE
STATE ACTUALLY HOPE TO HAVE THE
LAWS HAVE ANY MEANING WE NEED
ACTUAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE
NEED THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT TO THE LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
RIGHT. THANK YOU HI THERE MY
NAME IS NOT POSSIBLE AND I'M
FROM LOS GATOS CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT OF ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY EIGHT I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM THREE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
A LINE OF BY TWO EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING OR
GOOD AFTERNOON RATHER THAN I'M
GOING TO LUIS WITH TOPICS THAT
PARTICIPANTS THE GROUP FROM
AMONG THE MEMBERS. OF THE BRAIN
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE FOR FAR TOO LONG
OUR STATE HAS CREATED SHORT
TERM OR ONE TIME PROGRAM. AB
SEVENTY ONE WITH OUR ACTION TO
CREATE A SUSTAINED RESOURCE TO
HELP GET MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
OFF OF THE STREET SO I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT IT ALSO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUE STEPHANIE RICHARDS IS
UNABLE TO GET IN THE QUEUE
SHE'S FROM THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY. AND
TRAFFICKING OF LOS ANGELES- TAB
AND SHE ALSO WANTED ME TO
STATEMENT- SHE SUPPORT AB
SEVENTY ONE TO PREVENT AND
ENTERTAINMENT TRAFFICKING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THAT
ADJUSTED A- REMINDER THERE ARE
A OF. ON THE PHONE WAITING
PUBLIC. AND WANT TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF TIME. AS WELL AS
ENSURING THAT WE ARE BEING OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT EVERYBODY GETS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO I WILL ASK THAT YOU KEEP
YOUR COMMON SHORT. YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION. WHERE YOU'RE
CALLING FROM AND THE POSITION.
OF THE- ITEM THAT YOU'RE
CALLING FROM IS ALL THAT WE
NEED THANK YOU. OPERATOR PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU AND THAT
WILL COME FROM WIND UP TO
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JESSICA MCBRIDE I'M
WITHIN THE LAW CALLING FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE IN
LOS ANGELES- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ISSUE THREE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE UP TO SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M DAVID WALKER
I'M CALLING FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW
UNITY IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY FOUR YEAR STRONG
SUPPORTER ISSUE THREE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT OVER TO
A LINE OF. I'M SORRY ONE MOMENT
HERE. TWO OH EIGHT. WAIT IN
LINE. THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
JACK SB I'M A MEMBER OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA WORTH PONDERED AB
SEVENTY ONE AND A MEMBER OF THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME CAMPAIGN
WE ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
INCLUDE AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THE HOME OF THE PROJECT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
OVER A LINE OF ONE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE. YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH BUT YOU KNOW-
BOTH THERE WAS A GREAT S. S.
OPERATOR IF ARE ON TO HEAR THE
IN ON THE PHONE PLEASE LET'S
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU. NEXT
FINAL COME FROM NOT TO TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS I'M CALLING FROM WALDEN
FAMILY SERVICES MY NAME IS IT'S
THEIR WEAPONS AND WE HAVE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROVIDED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
TO PREVENT AND REDUCE COSTS
THANK YOU FOR HOMELESS THE
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT FINAL
COME FROM CHINA TWO OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS JOE JOHNSON
AND SUBJECT TO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM I'M USE THAT BECAUSE
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOU I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION.
PREVENTING AND REDUCING CLASS
REFORM. MOVEMENTS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MANAK
FINAL COME FROM Y. AT TWO
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS EATING THEM
WHEN THAT THAT HE- I AM WITH
THE NEXT PROGRAM AT EAST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION PREVENTING AND REDUCING
FOSTER YOU'LL HOMELESSNESS.
KAON ARE NOT FINAL COME FROM
LINE ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS HEADED BACK ON OUR WITH TO
WRITE THE COULD TELL VALLEY I'M
CALL IN. OF THE BY PART OUR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIN THAT WE
MEMBER CAR. FOR THE COULD
VALLEY HOUSING. FUND RADICAL
INCREASE CREASE APPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COACHELLA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NXR LINE WILL COME FROM NINETY
OR IS OPEN. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
GONE FOR HERE AND I'M ON THE OF
LIVE TO RIGHT. IN THE KITCHEN
VALLEY AND ALSO SUPPORTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND MAIN FOR
THE CONTROL HOUSING. FUND THANK.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OF THE LINE OF
TOURISTS THREE YEAR LINE OPEN.
TO THREE LINE OF THE. HELLO.
OKAY I WILL JUST MOVE ON THE
NEXT LINE- TWO NINE YEAR LINE
OF THE- HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN MARK AND I AM A
APPROACH OF. TO EXPRESS MY OF
THE BANK PASSED FOR THE COULD
VALLEY HOW CARLA BY. BIPARTISAN
EFFORT BY SOME MEMBERS OF
CANCER THE GENTLEMAN CHAD MAYES
TOGETHER OUR GOAL IS TO
INCLUSIVE OF BUYING HOUSING FOR
ARE SIGNATURE VALLEY BE IN
BANKING. THANK YOU. I'M NEXT
OVER LINE OF ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE SIX FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LINE OF-
TWO THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS POONAM A
RESIDENT FAMILIES THE BILL
WON'T PARK I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE URGE FOR FUNDING
FOR MY COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. AT
ONE WILL COME FROM ONE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HAVE A SOME NEW. OKAY NOW
WE'LL JUST MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
LINE OF TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KEVIN MA AND CONGRESSMEN AND
THE FOR EVERYONE FROM PALO ALTO-IN SUPPORT OF THE HOUSING
COUNTY THE UNIT AND AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANEXO
BOTTOM LINE A ONE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND ONE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MMHM WE'LL GO ON TO THE NEXT
ONE OF FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME IS JOE
SOME CRAP AND I'M CALLING FROM
THE CITY OF PALM DESERT. TO
EXPRESS MY FULL SUPPORT FOR THE
BUDGET REQUESTS THE COACHELLA
VALLEY HOW THE CALIFORNIA. IS A
BY PART NUMBER LED BY SOMEONE
IN A BAR GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEN
CHAD MAYES. GATHERCOLE DIRECTLY
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY REGION AS A MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS IMPORTANT TO ME.
OTHER REGION BECAUSE NEARLY
HALF LOCATELLI VALLEY RESIDENTS
LIVE AT OR BELOW 2100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE THEREFORE.
INVESTMENT FOR HOUSING IN OUR
REGION IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE OUR
COMMUNITIES. NEED A FORMAL
PLACE TO CALL HOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NO NOT FOUND COME
FROM MINUS ONE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS OUR SORRY HEALTH BOX AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF WITH YOUR
RIGHT TO SUPPORT THE BIPARTISAN
OUT. OF PARTICULAR VALUE
HELPING PALESTINE KERRY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND ABOVE
AND BEYOND. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND THE NEXT FINAL COME
FROM LINE. TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE OF SEVEN.
HELLO ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT I
BROUGHT UP WELL ARE NOT BROKE
WITH SEVEN ASAMBLEíSTA THAT
YEAH BUT A POOR THEY'VE BEEN
INFORMED BOTH THE MIDDLE EAST
TODAY BY YET A COACHELLA ON
BOTH THE CATHOLIC SETTLEMENT
BUT UP WITH IT AND THERE MIGHT
BE ELECTORAL AFFAIRS BUT NOT NO
WANT BANCO NOT GOT THAT THE
NEXT IT FOR YANDLE IT'S A
BUNDLE BUT OUR COMPANY SETTLED
BACK YET. SYNONYMOUS WITH THE
SEASONAL OF A FULL. OUR GOING
TO KEEP UP WITH THAT AB ONE
ECHO MONEY THAT THE NOTCH IN
NAY LET THAT ARE YOU THE CLIP.
PRESAS SUPPORT FOR THE BY ASK
THE COACHELLA VALLEY. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT CALLER WILL COME FROM
NINE TO FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HE WENT ON THE NUMBER
THAT AMONG COURT OR NOT. YOUR
MOTHER BOUGHT A PLAN THAT THAT.
YEP YOUR ON REPORTS AVAILABLE
THE HECHT OF THE FOLLOWED IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING. AT
YOUR. HAS THIS SUPPORT FOR THE
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. AND OUR NEXT
FIVE WILL COME FROM TWO THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS KAREN
STORIES AND THE HOUSING CO
CHAIR- HOUSING CAN CULTURE FOR
LOOK TO RISE AND I'M CALLING
FOR SUPPORT THE BIPARTISAN ACTS
FOR THE COACHELLA VALLEY
HOUSING CATALYST FUND CARRY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MSJ ARE MADAM
CHAIR LASSEN WILL COME FROM
LINE OF. ONE NINETY FIVE ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NUMBER NUMBER. ONE NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. WE
MAY HAVE LOST THAT LAST CALLER
BUT IT MAY HAVE BEEN ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR THE COACHELLA
VALLEY BUDGET ASK. WE DID HAVE
ONE FURTHER ONE CAME IN Q. OKAY
ANALYSIS FROM LINE ON ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS BEN AND I'M CALLING
WITH THE BUDGET HOUSING LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER THREE HOW CAN YOU KIND
OF BELIEVE THAT THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY MADAM CHAIR THERE'S TWO
MORE. THE LINE TO FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY THIS IS
THAT THEY NEED TO DO SAYS
CALLING FROM ABOUT THE HOUSING
LA JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THANK YOU AND THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY GO TO. THANK YOU.
NOW AFTER LEARNING QUEUE IS
LINE OF THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CAN THE TANK OF THE DAVIS
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAMS
WITH CRITICS SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES I AM HERE
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION. DOLLARS PREVENTING AND
REDUCING FOSTER YUTH
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR AND
GREAT JOB IN GETTING THROUGH US
WITH ALL THE ALL THOSE CALLS
MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU FOR
EVERYBODY THAT'S CALLED IN WE
WANTED TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
EVERYONE'S TIME AND COMMITMENT%
TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING AN ASSISTANT.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THE WHAT WE HEARD IN TODAY'S
HEARING- I GUESS THAT'S IT
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH THIS-
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.